hey guys welcome to this front-end full
course video
now front-end development is one of the
most commonly heard phrases today now
front-end development is basically the
part of web development that involves
coding and creating the front-end
elements of a website
now the front end is typically what the
end user or the client interacts with
so in this video we're going to be
learning all about front-end languages
and libraries
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what we'll be learning today
first we look at a complete tutorial on
version control systems that is git and
github once you're familiar with that
we'll move on to understanding the basic
front-end language that is html
we'll also look at how to implement html
registration forms and build a simple
app using html that is the quiz app
moving ahead we look at a detailed
tutorial on css after that we look at
javascript and how to add interactivity
to our web applications
now javascript offers some really cool
libraries and frameworks for front-end
development
so first we'll learn react.js which is a
javascript library and moving ahead
we'll understand how angular is used to
build apps
so now that you know what's in store for
you let's go ahead and jump right in
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to delve into git
and what it actually is and how it fits
within your devops stack so a little
scenario before using get one of the
challenges that a lot of developers and
development teams would have had is
developers would be working on different
types of code whether it was database
code whether it was python or whether
it's java or net and they would have a
central server that they'd be pushing
all of their source code in but there
was little or no communication that was
actually going on in between all the
developers you know the challenge you
had with that scenario is that when
people would be checking in code you
could be like you know there'd be
conflicts and you'd have to roll back
different code versions and and this is
really kind of the challenge that git
addresses git is a tool that allows all
of the developers no matter what stack
they're working in to have access to all
of the code and it makes it much more
effective at being able to have
development teams work on small medium
or even massive applications and some of
the biggest applications out there are
managed through a get distributed server
environment so let's jump into what
we'll be covering so you have a clear
understanding of the value that you're
going to get out of watching this
presentation so we're going to go
through devops and the tools have
available for devops we'll talk about
what version control means within a
devops environment and cover the two
different types of version control
centralized and distributed and then
we're going to zero in on git which is a
really fantastic distributed version
control system i'm going to go through
understand the features workflow
branches and commands in git we can give
you a demo and then summarize all the
activities at the end of the the
presentation so what is devops well this
is one of my favorite questions i love
the idea of what devops is so devops
really is a culture of being able to
deliver solutions faster where your
development teams and your operation
teams work effectively together the idea
is to be able to continuously build out
solutions and have testing codes that's
built into your solutions so that no
matter where they are in the stage of
the integration and deployment life
cycle they're always being tested and
you can always have code being ready to
be released out the idea is that instead
of having big releases that you'd have
maybe once every two weeks or once a
month that you would actually have a
continuous stream of releases because
you always have code that is being
tested you have your network that's been
tested you have your environment being
tested and you'll be able to provide
feedback directly to the appropriate
person whether they're in devs or
whether they're in ops to be able to be
successful at being able to deliver
solutions faster the bottom line your
dev team things like operations and your
operations team begin to feel like think
like developers it's really a fantastic
way of being able to speed up delivery
and have your team just think and feel
and act in a different cultural
environment so let's have a look at some
of the tools that are available to you
in devops environments if we look at
devops it's really kind of split into
two areas the dev side you have building
code planning and testing and then on
your upside you have release deployment
operating and monitoring but the tools
really all interact with each other and
what's really great is that the tools
are either open source or very very low
in cost in fact most of the tools you're
seeing in front of you right now are
open source tools which means there's no
licensing to you and you can actually
effectively manage them and implement
them within your team right now so let's
have a look at some of the dev tools
that you have for doing code versioning
and so some of the tools that you may
have used in the past include subversion
team foundation service and git these
are all different types of version
control software that you have out there
one of the oldest ones is subversion
it's a centralized version control
system it's one of the tools i used
years ago it really is good at doing
what it's supposed to do which is just a
very simple version controlled solution
it's open source so it's free and
there's no licensing there are
challenges with working with it because
it is a centralized tool rather than a
distributed tool we'll get into that in
a little bit but for a very basic
version control system you know it does
what you wanted to do team foundation
service solutions something that many of
you in microsoft world may have been
using for a long time and the thing
that's great about tfs is it's built
right into the microsoft environment
it's the server side the services side
of building out your solutions with
microsoft um just recently in the last
couple of weeks at the beginning of
september 2018. microsoft actually just
re-branded tfs as azure devops and so
you have azure pipelines and there are
five now azure tools that you replace
tfs but these are all tools that are
very similar in concept the old tfs
tools are very similar to the
centralized svn tools whereas the new
tools that are part of azure are
actually much more aligned with git so
what you're seeing is microsoft moving
from the centralized server to a
distributed server with their new azure
devops tools which is fantastic news for
every developer listening to this and
then we have get and git is a
distributed version control system it is
again open source which means that you
can start using it right now without
fear of having to have any costs or any
penalties and the thing that's really
good about it is that it's really you
can use it for almost any kind of
digital project and what it's good at is
being able to create that historical
record and versioning of your source
code whether you're doing a web
application a mobile application or
you're actually building a python script
for a machine learning solution so let's
dig into what version control systems
are and how they can be of value to you
so the role of version control system is
to allow developers to be able to check
in their files into a repository and
here you can actually see how we can
check in three files into a repository
and that repository then becomes a
snapshot or a historical record of the
files that we're working on and you want
to be able to have it so that the
repository is flexible enough so that as
you want to be able to scale and add in
new files or new versions of a file that
you can actually do that easily within
your vcs environment and the goal is to
be able to constantly have each of these
versions available so that anybody wants
to be able to check out the file can
actually have the latest version or see
a history of how that file became what
it is today let's look at centralized
version control systems and then we'll
compare it against distributed version
control systems so a centralized version
control system has a central server
where all the files are stored and
everybody has to check in and check out
from that centralized server and all of
the versions are managed within that
server environment the problem is is
that if that central server crashes
which doesn't happen but very often but
it can happen you end up losing all of
your files and i was actually on a
project where that actually happened to
us and we lost six months of history of
how the application was created
fortunately for us we actually had a
backup but it didn't have all the
historical data so we were able to at
least continue working but we just lost
a lot of files and it took a while to
get back into place so let's now look at
and compare this to a distributed
version control system with a
distributed version control system you
still have a centralized server that
manages the files but the difference is
is that as a developer you check out all
of the files for a project so you can
actually manage the whole project
locally on your develop machine and make
your changes and then you can just check
in and out the changes that you've made
to the centralized server the
opportunity you have here is that the
server itself if it goes down you're not
going to be in a situation where you
lose all of the history because
everybody that's working on the actual
application has all of the versions of
the code locally on their machine
now one of the more popular distributed
version control systems that out there
is git i mean it really is probably the
most popular buyer margin compared to a
system out there so you know let's dig
into you know what actually is git so
git is a version control system for
managing files and as a developer you
have a git client on your machine and
you're able to make changes and create
local repositories of a program on your
computer and then you can sync up with a
remote service such as github or get lab
or the new azure
labs environment where you can actually
store files remotely and then allow
remote teams to have access to
those changes in the actual application
you made so you can track your changes
easily you have it's the the tool is
inherently distributed so it makes it
very easy to manage the code for large
teams and you can bring people in very
quickly and you can have people come in
as specialists and spin them up quickly
and have them work on a piece of the
code and then drop them out of the
project if you want to have a check on
how this works go and start contributing
to any of the the many thousands of open
source projects at github where you can
go in with your get tools and just
contribute to those projects and then
finally one of the things that i really
like with git is that it's not a linear
development approach it's not starting
from a and going to z it's a non-linear
approach which allows you to have
branches that people are working on in
parallel to your master branch where
people are actually doing the delivery
of the production code so let's step
through some of these features uh so get
as you can imagine the first thing it
does is track history that's probably
the most important part of having a
version control system it's a free open
source you can actually go and use it
right now there are no costs of actually
using it it is a non-linear environment
that allows people to be able to build
out new features in parallel to the
master branch so that you can be
constantly having the master code out
there without and adding in new features
without breaking the code and you can
automatically create backups by because
each developer has a version of the code
remotely it's incredibly scalable some
of the biggest projects out there now
are being managed through git and
because of this scale the collaboration
becomes a byproduct of teams working
together and branching just is so much
easier within git so as you can see this
whole thing leads to a very effective
distributed environment
so let's step through some of the the
workflow that we have available for git
so the way that git works is that
you as an operator as a developer you
have the get client on your local
development machine whether it's a linux
machine a mac or a pc and you connect to
a remote server and you pull down the
latest working copy and then you're able
to make all of your changes uh locally
and you can modify the codes you can
review changes and you can commit those
codes to your git repository that you
have locally and then you can push those
changes back up to the remote server and
as soon as you push them into the remote
server those changes then become
available to everybody else working on
the project so they can be constantly
keeping everybody updated on all the
work that is happening so you know
typically the way that it would work is
you know you would start off with having
the working file working directory that
you have locally then you would stage
those files into a staging area and then
you get those files ready to be
committed to your git repository and
these are all actions that you would do
locally and then connect to a remote
server and then later when you go back
into work on your project the first
thing you should always do is check out
that code so you always have the latest
version of the code and everybody is
kept in sync so let's talk about
branching in git so the way that
branches work is that if you imagine
you're working on a project and projects
always have a tendency of getting bigger
than you imagine and what you want to be
able to do is keep that main product
working and keeping it working
effectively but if you want to be able
to add a feature to that product you may
have two or three different groups that
are working on multiple features
simultaneously
and what you want to be able to do is
give them the freedom to work on those
individual features and the way you do
it in git is that you can create
branches off the master and while you're
off the the main branch which is called
the master and so each person could be
working on their own separate branch and
then when they want to they can then
later merge those branches back into the
main master and all this time the main
master still works and still able to
produce the right code for the customer
but at the same time it allows the
developers the freedom to be able to
write in their new features and so we
can look at this in a little bit more
visually with the master branch and we
can put in small features of large
features and we can then merge them back
as we need to so this kind of covers
some of the commands that we have in git
so the first command you'd want to use
is called git init and that's allow you
to go into a folder on your local pc and
or your local mac and convert that file
that folder into a local git repository
and that creates that repository then
you want to be able to make changes to
that repository and the commands you'd
be using in this instance would be add
commit or status and you want to be able
to sync your repositories with the
remote server so be able to put the code
that you have on your computer on the
remote server you just push you know get
the code from the remote server you'd
use pull and then add origin and then if
you want to do parallel development from
the master branch the main branch you
would use branch merge or rebase as ways
to be able to do parallel development a
very warm welcome to all our viewers i'm
anjali from simply learn and today i'll
be showing you the installation for git
on windows so we'll start by downloading
and installing git on our system we'll
then have a look at the git bash
interface we'll type in some basic git
commands next we'll create a local
repository that is we'll create a
repository on a local machine we'll then
connect to a remote repository and
finally we'll push the file onto github
first things first we need to download
and install git so download git for
windows and i'll select the second link
so
2.19.1 which is the most latest version
of kit that's the one we want for
windows system choose your version so
mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while
so git is finally downloaded now we need
to install this on our system
click here run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path
uh just so just click on in quick launch
and on desktop
next
next again next nothing to change here
either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash
so let's just tick that and then click
on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version
and as you can see version 2.19.1
on our windows system which is exactly
what we just downloaded we'll now
explore the help command so let's just
type get help config so config is
another command and as i hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it so in case you have
any doubts regarding how a command is
used what a command is used for or the
various syntax of the command you can
always use the help command now there's
another syntax for using the help
command itself which is git config dash
dash help enter this does the exact same
thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir
test
now test is my new directory i'll move
into this directory so cd test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so git
init is the command for initializing the
directory and as you can see as you can
see the path here this is the local path
where a directory is created so i'll
just show you the directory test and
it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and i'll
just name this demo
i'll open this and just put in some
dummy content
so hello simply done
save this file and go back to your bash
interface
let's just check the status now so get
status and as you can see
our file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is we
will be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we will
be applying is the commit command and
when you add certain files to the
current directory the commit command is
applied on all the above directories so
git commit minus m and a message that
will appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion
i'll just clear the screen next thing we
need to do is we need to link our git to
a github account so the command for
doing that is git config
global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
github account
so this is my github profile and my
username is
simplylearn.github so guys before you
begin this procedure just make a github
account type in my username here simply
learn github and enter and there you go
a git is successfully linked with github
next thing we do is we'll just open our
github
and we'll create a new repository give a
repository name so i'll name it test
underscore demo and create repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and our
local repository so git remote origin
and then paste
the http link and now that our local
repository and our remote repository are
linked we can push our local file onto
our remote repository so the command for
doing that is git
push origin master as we are on the
master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to github i'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo if you have any queries
regarding this please post them in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as possible and now we're
going to go through and do a demo on git
so we're going to do a demo on git so
you can feel comfortable running the
commands in the interface and you're
able to get get running correctly in
your environment so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to set
up which version of git that you have
and then we're going to see if we can
establish some global configurations
within your git environment and we're
going to do sandeep.dash as the name the
email address is sandeep.com and then
we're going to do a list of the
different configuration settings we have
so to check the version of git that we
have we do get dash dash version in our
terminal or command line window you can
also use powershell that'll actually get
you running in the same environment as
well all of these tools are going to be
command line tools and then the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to assign some global usernames and a
global email address and so that we can
actually access the git account itself
locally on the device and so we're going
to dash and we're going to put in config
dash global user dot name sandeep and
then a git config
global user dot email and sandeep dot d
at
simplylearn.net and now we're going to
check the list of usernames and email
ids in our configuration environment
with dash list and you'll see that we
have everything in there correctly here
is our username right here and our name
and our email id
so if you need any help when you're
actually doing any of your work in get
all you have to do is to get help config
or get config
help and this will allow you to actually
get access to the help screens so let's
just go and type that in git help config
return and this takes us to the help
page that's running locally on your
device and here we have a breakdown of
all the different commands and what
those commands actually do within a git
configuration
and we can go ahead and we can do git
config dash dash help and that will
actually take us to the same page so two
ways of doing the same thing so we're
gonna go ahead and we're gonna create a
test repository on our local system and
we're going to do that with
make directory called test and then
we're going to move our cursor within
command window terminal window to the
test folder and then we're going to
initialize that folder to become a get
repository so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to make a new directory
i'm going to call it test and we're
going to move the cursor so it's
actually in the test folder we do cd
change directory to test and you can see
now we're actually in the test folder
and now we have to do is initialize this
folder as a git repository and so we're
going to do this as git init and it's
now a new git instance that we can
actually now use for managing our git
environment so we're going to create a
new file and we're going to call it
info.txt and we're going to put some
content in it and we're actually gonna
put it in the folder that we've just
created so you can actually see what
it's like to test out the get
environment with a file that hasn't been
checked into it yet so let's go ahead
and do that so we open up our folder
directory and here you can see we have
the test folder and we're just going to
go ahead and create a default test file
so right click text new document
info.txt open that and we'll just you
put really whatever you want in here
we're just going to put in this
information right now name equals sam
registration number
one two
four seven nine and save that file close
it out now if we actually go ahead and
run a get status command you'll see that
the info.txt file is in red that's
because that file has not actually been
checked into the project it's a new file
that we've added but it hasn't been
committed yet into the git repository so
let's go ahead and see what it takes to
actually add the file to the git
repository that we just created so we're
going to do that by doing git add
info.txt and then we're going to commit
that into the history of that git
repository so we can do so it now has a
version control and we can start doing
uh forking and other kind of similar
activities when we connect later to our
github git environment so we do get add
info.txt
and remember we're actually still in the
test folder so it's going to look for
that file in that folder and just add it
in and now if we go ahead and do git
status we'll actually be able to see
that the info.txt file is in an active
color first of all we have to commit it
so we go git commit dash m and then
we're going to commit and we add in some
quick text you can write if you want
committing the text file it's now
actually committed into the git
repository and it's all running locally
on your pc so we're going to go make
some changes to the file and we're going
to save it and we want to be able to see
how we can use git to compare the
differences between the two files so
let's go over and we're going to make
some changes to the info.txt file here
we are here's info.txt which is going to
add in a new line we're going to add in
the line address and we're gonna save
that file and now when we go over to get
we're going to
be able to review the difference so
we're gonna do git diff and here you
actually see that we've added in a new
address file so now you can actually see
this is the difference and the
difference between the two documents now
as you can imagine when you have code
this could become more elaborate where
actually it will show you code that's
been pulled out if you've reduced any of
eliminating code or if you added a new
code really useful so we're going to go
ahead and add our get username to a
remote location so we can actually start
testing out the
file that we've created into a remote
repository in this case we're going to
use github and you'll be able to see how
we can actually then save that file into
a git repository that somebody else
could then access and be able to make
edits to so let's just go ahead and make
those changes so git config dash global
user dot username and we do simply learn
and that will associate it with this uh
git repository that we've just created
locally so simply down dash github so
simply learn github is the username that
we use on github so we're going to go
over to github here we are in github and
then correct new repository
and then as you can see with simp so
we're in simply learn dash github and
we're going to call the new proprietary
test we're going to make it public so
anybody can access it and you'll see
that it automatically adds a readme file
and we have our test environment set up
correctly so we'll go ahead and copy the
url link which is github.com simply
learn dash github forward slash test.get
copy that and we'll go back over to our
command line window and so now we're
going to add the username to the github
configuration so what we're doing is
we're connecting the local repository to
the remote repository so we type get
remote add origin and then we'll paste
in the address and this then allows us
to connect the local repository that we
created in the test folder with the
remote repository and now we're
connected so now that we've connected we
can actually push the file that we have
in the local repository on your pc or
mac to the remote repository in the
github server environment so let's go
ahead and do that so we do get push and
push is the command to push the
documents from the origin which is the
local file to master and must as a
remote file okay and there we are
success so what we have now is the file
that we just created in our local get
repository is actually now in the remote
repository as well so anybody can access
it so let's go have a look at that so
we're gonna refresh the github page and
hey there we are there's info.txt has
been uploaded and we're ready to go
that's great that's uh that's what you
should be seeing so refreshing your web
page on the remote github folder and it
could be any git service we're just
happy to be using github because it's
free to use you'll be able to see that
the local file has been installed and is
now part of the get repository in the
remote server so what we can do now is
we're going to create three more files
and we're just going to call them
info.txt info 2 and info 3. and then
we're going to push them out to the
remote server and we're going to merge
everything together into a single
environment so let's go ahead and create
those three files and we're just going
to add those into the folder so let's go
ahead create new text document info one
and then we're going to create info two
and then info
three look at my typing right here okay
here we go there we are okay i'm opening
info three and i'm just gonna enter some
text in here and what we're gonna do is
illustrate how we can do branching and
each of these files i'm gonna save and
then close out and now i can go over and
so let's create a new branch and we're
going to call this one first underscore
branch and we go get branch first
underscore branch and this will be a new
branch of the code environment that
we're creating and so hit return and
that allows us to create a new branch
and so what we do is we're going to move
to the new branch so we're going to do
git check out first underscore branch
and that allows us to move into that
branch and you'll see that info.txt is
already there which is good that's what
we want to see now what we need to do is
um add in the new documents so here we
have the different steps we've taken we
created a branch we moved to the new
branch and now we're going to go ahead
and add the info 3 txt to that branch so
you can actually see everything coming
together and we're going to go with get
add info three dot txt so we're just
adding a file like we were previously
with our initialization our first
initial git folder and that file has now
been added to the first branch so we're
going to go ahead and commit the file to
the first branch and then we're going to
merge the documents into the master
branch so we have everything together so
let's go ahead and do those steps we're
going to do the commit first and then
we're going to merge everything together
all right so we do get commit dash m and
we just put in we're just gonna say uh
made changes to
first branch and that's just uh
documentation so that we know what we've
done and there we are we've uh committed
the file so we had that file info 3 txt
committed and now we're going to go
ahead and merge the files into the main
master and
so we can actually have everything
together as one consistent environment
and we do that by typing in so this
lists out what we have in our master
file so we just do ls and that shows
everything in the folder and we have
info.txt
info 1 txt info 2 txt and info 3 txt are
now all in the first branch so let's go
ahead and we're going to merge okay so
actually before we merge we have to
check out the master branch so we do get
checkout master so it gets us into the
master branch and you'll see that we
have just one file in there info.txt so
we're going to list out the files in the
master branch and so so what you'll see
is info.txt info one text and info2 text
are there but
info.info3d text isn't there because
that was created in a separate bunch so
let's go ahead and merge the first
branch into the master branch so we do
git merge and we do first underscore
branch and there we are we've merged it
in and
excellent that looks good
so let's go ahead and list out the files
that we have in the master branch and we
do ls and then you'll see that we have
four files including the info three dot
text that we had in a separate branch
now all in the master branch in this
session we will have a look at the
basics of github
before diving deep into the subject
let's first have a look at a use case
the used case we will consider today is
of the world's largest sporting goods
retail brand decathlon
decathlon has 1600 stores spread in 52
countries with around hundred thousand
employees
the iit team of github consists of one
thousand members that helps decathlon to
bring its shoppers journey to their
devices
so here we will first see the problems
that they faced and then we shall see
how did they sort out that problem
in the beginning decathlon worked on the
data center with the help of a vpn
and using a vpn was a huge challenge in
terms of workflow visibility and
avoiding redundancies
so the first problem is how to maintain
workflow visibility and avoid
redundancies
then since there are so many stores
located at so many different places
hiring of developers seemed to be a
difficult task as a physical workplace
was always needed
so the second problem is
how would they hire developers
now let's see how did decathlon solve
these two problems one after the other
in the first case the entire decathlon
shifted from any other remote repository
to github
github turned out to be an amazing open
source community as the code became more
visible across the organization and now
anybody could contribute to it
then
let's talk about the second case for
hiring the developers
as we know github is an open source
community so it helped in collaboration
with any developer all over the world
the potential developers could now
contribute to benefit the global
community
now the question arises what made this
contribution possible
so the major contribution role was
played by the version control system
this was just a single case amongst many
others
there are many organizations that have
benefited from github
now when we have realized how github has
revolutionized the market let's start
learning more and more about github it
is time for us to jump on the topic what
is github
github is a service hosted on the web
where all the projects are stored
every project on github has its own
repository and its unique url
git provides a graphical interface to
store the files and helps team members
to coordinate on the project from
anywhere
github provides several access control
and collaboration features like wikis
and basic task management tools for
every project
let's now have a look at the features of
github
the first feature we will see is easy
project management
github helps project managers and
developers to coordinate better on the
project
the work can be easily tracked and
updated which makes sure that the
project is on schedule and as entitled
second feature is increased safety with
packages
the packages on github can be published
as desired
they can be published privately or
within a community or can also be
published publicly
the packages can be easily downloaded
from the github to use and reuse them
next feature is the effective team
management now as all the team members
can stay updated with all that's
happening on the project so this helps
them in staying organized and well
coordinated the pull request and other
modification tools make sure that the
team focuses on the code
moving on the next feature is improved
code writing
with the help of github the quality of
code has significantly increased
now with the help of gitpull command one
can review improve and propose new codes
along with that suggestions or
modifications may be discussed before
changing the original code
the next feature is increased code
safety
github uses codeql which is the
industry's leading semantic code
analysis engine
this tends to find risks in the code
which other tools tend to miss
the last feature we shall see
is easy code hosting
as the name suggests
the codes and documentations are hosted
in one place
we also know that there are thousands of
repositories on github so each
repository has their own set of tools to
release and host the code finally let's
have a look at the competitors of github
there are several competitors in the
market
here we have just put the most common
ones
first is atlassian bitbucket
then comes fugbugs
followed by surround scm and gitlab
then we have buddy and finally followed
by beanstalk let's see the differences
between git and github
git is a software that can be installed
directly onto our systems whereas github
as we saw in the demo is hosted on the
cloud then git can be used offline we
don't typically need an internet
connection unless we need to access the
github whereas github can only be
operated when we have an internet
connection next difference is git is
something independent and can be used
without github whereas github has
nothing to do unless we make
repositories in git which means it
cannot be used without git
then git is a version control system
that helps in source code management
whereas github provides centralized
hosting of the code on the cloud next
difference is git does not work
according to a graphical user interface
while github is a simple graphical
interface
next difference is git is a command line
so it operates on several commands like
commit merge push pull etc whereas
github is a web-based service so it has
nothing to do with command line then
git is released under the gnu general
public license which is an open source
license it ensures that the software is
free for all its users whereas in the
case of github there are two tires a
free tire and a paid tire
in the end let's have a look at the
competitors of the two as a competition
git has mercurial supervision ibm
rational team concert and clearcase
while for github the competition is
bitbucket and gitlab hello and welcome
to git commands my name is chidanand and
i am with the simply learn team today i
am going to cover few essential git
commands and walk you through a
demonstration for most of it i begin by
installing a git bash or the git client
and configuring it for its first time
usage once i'm done with configuring the
git client i'm going to spin up few
repositories locally and work on these
repositories using git commands once i'm
happy with my local changes i'm going to
commit few of them and then push these
changes to a git server of my choice for
today's demonstration i plan to use
github.com which is a cloud-hosted free
service and it provides free account
registrations for anyone eventually i
will cover few topics regarding git
branching and merging because these two
in my opinion are the killer features of
the git distributed version control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed version control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed version control tool it
allows us to perform various version
control tasks without really needing a
network connection before i jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like windows
all flavors of windows
linux mic os and other operating systems
so once you install git bash you get a
command line utility using which you can
fire up your git commands and ensure
that you can bring up repositories you
can work with these repositories by
adding files to it committing changes to
it and all those git commands would work
perfectly well so you can bring up a
small repository and you can work with
your repository using this git bash but
what does it take for you to share this
repository with another user who has
also got git bash installed on his
system this is where you would need
something called as a gig server
so for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that i can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud would go for this github
enterprise servers wherein they buy
these servers and these servers are
hosted on their data centers other
popular variant of the git server is
bitbucket this is from the famous
atlassian products and it integrates
very well with all other atlassian
products like jira in recent times
there's one other variant of the git
server called gitlab which is getting
very very popular these days because
gitlab not just provides a git server it
also provides something called as a
runner this is a part of the continuous
integration strategy where as soon as
you have a source code check-in that is
going in you have this runner that kicks
up and builds your particular project so
all these are bundled together in a
gitlab and gitlab also provides you with
a community edition which is almost free
of cost having said that there are a
bunch of these tools available for my
demonstration what i'm going to do is
i've already registered myself on the
github.com by providing my username and
my password and i'm going to use a free
account so whatever repositories that
i'm going to put up on this server is
all public by default so i want to
register myself by using my username or
my email id and my password so this set
of authentication is also referred to as
https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user 2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user two or the other developer
who wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it on to my account within my
git server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my phrase correctly i can
authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that i can go ahead
and install it so i just type in get
client for
windows open up a browser and type in
for this the first one that i find as a
gui tool i don't need this gui client i
need this one
so this is the git client or the git
bash that i was referring to it's about
40 megs and let me just download this
pause this video for some time so that
the download happens and come back to
you once i have the download the
download seems to be complete when i'm
recording this video the version that i
have the latest version that is there is
2.19.0 and this is a 64-bit version for
windows so i've got that downloaded let
me go ahead and find it and install this
exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder
everything looks good for me i'm not
going to make any changes here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
looks good looks good
no i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
and the version that i'm using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say launch
git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say get to
version it sounds good say get help all
right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so
i ended up installing the git bash i can
go ahead with all other commands
now that i have get bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
user name and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double quote in my
case i am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular user name of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
a global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id that
i would be setting update to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo so this would be a
folder so i would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first
repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty
there's nothing much in this folder at
all at this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing on it was
an empty repository so it initialize an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you would see that there's a hidden
folder this would be a hidden folder
since i've configured my explorer to
view all hidden folders i see it
otherwise you wouldn't see it so a
folder by name dot get is created within
this first repo and this was created
because we ran the command git init
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and there's info there's
objects
there's references a bunch of stuff that
is there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when i was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when i say git init there
is something called as a master that
shows up so typically what happens is
whenever a git repository is created for
the first time it creates a default
branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches
the branch name within this brackets
would change
all right so far so good so we created a
folder we made it a git repository by
initializing that with the git init and
then have not put anything yet in the
repository so let me try to do that let
me create a few files within this
particular repository so i use a touch
command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if not
you're not comfortable with the file
creation by this way you can always use
a file explorer and create some files in
this so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add i
can specify either the name of the file
or i can give a while character saying
git add dot now if i run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet
added a file and the file which was
earlier in red now shows up in green and
it says it's a new file master dot text
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked has been added into
the git index or it is ready for staging
or it's in a staged state
now i can go ahead and commit this file
if at all that's what i want to do so
let me do that
i'll do a kit commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first get
commit
all right i run the git status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit
id or the commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first command is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a kit server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my
is already there on the local system so
what i essentially need is just a
placeholder for my repository so that i
can link them together and push the
content from my local repository to the
server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name
so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub
repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice
i can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that i'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so i choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go and click
on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server
and also important point it shows me two
urls one is the https url and the other
one is the ssh url as of now we do not
have any ssh keys that is set up so let
me use this https url to connect my
local repository with the repository on
the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repository set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
with essentially links or adds an origin
with the url of the git server i just
copy this command
and run it here
git remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push
hyphen u this is for linking the
upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen u upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to an origin
and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i have
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server so let
me go back to my server and refresh this
page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master1.txt if at all i see the
commits there seem to be two comments
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash id which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the commit
this is the commit which was committed
for 15 minutes ago so what does this
mean is that the commit is the timestamp
when we actually commented the code in
the client the pushing is just after we
committed the change we pushed it so
there's no timestamp of the push that
happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i create a repository
on the client and then i pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh keygen
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify the email id using which
i'm going to connect to or i need to
create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should i create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a dot ssh folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase
so let me enter some passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i'm
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys so i've
logged in to github using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you will see an ssh and gpg keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
ssh key or gpg keys so i will click on
new ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i've copied
and i would say add a ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully
let me check if my ssh keys are working
well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t
i would say get
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase
i hope i remember it correctly
all right
pretty good i have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh alright so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository
linking the origin so that i create an
exact replica of the repository which is
there on the server on my local drive so
let me first create a repository on the
server i will create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that i don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now i want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then i want a repository to be
created on the server alright i say
create a repository
so
a random readme file with some content
in it gets created and i can see there
are two urls to this repository https
and ssh so this time let me copy the ssh
url so that i will use this url to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that i created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that i
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the url of the
repository that i want to clone
oops
looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again
copy this url
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
report this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt
some text file i'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
gonna save this
and if i do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository you want to track this
file yes i definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
i'm giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me i don't really need
to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i'll just say git
push to be on the safer side i would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it pushed the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second comment it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when i
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you're creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kit gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file ten files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen m with a
meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you have done in terms of the files that
got changed the more files that got
added all this with one particular
message gate status will give you the
status of all the files and folders any
file that got added any file that got
created any file that was deleted all
status of the files will be obtained
using the git status command git log
will show you all the commit history
with the latest history or the latest
commit showing up on top git add remote
origin this command is used whenever you
want to link any local repository to a
server and this is when you want to
really push a repository from the local
to the server for the first time git
push hyphen u origin and master this is
the command that you would use whenever
you want to push contents from the local
repository to the server git clone and
the url of the server this is the
command that you would run whenever you
have an existing repository on the
server and you want to make a fresh
clone or a fresh copy of that particular
repository onto your local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of get
this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the change that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who will
be using it you need to be really
cautious while running these commands in
case your repository contents are local
you have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's say i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i
have added another file called m4 now
this is my commit history now let's say
i made these two comments but possibly i
want to club them together along with
some other changes because whatever
changes i did did not really fix things
the way i expected it to fix so there is
a git command called git reset this
would allow me to go back in history to
go back to any of the snapshot get rid
of all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
commits but a soft would ensure that the
file changes that were done as a part of
these two comments would still exist a
full remain so the command for that is
git reset hyphen f1 soft which is the
snapshot that i want to get back to if
this is the commit that i want to get
back to i just copy this
and i paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a good log pretty one
line
what it says is c 1 c 2 now the head
which is nothing but the current pointer
which is earlier pointing to c5 it's
gone back to c3 now what happened to the
changes that were there as a part of c4
and c5
if at all you do a git status
if you see the changes that were part of
c4 were some changes to m1 and m2 and c5
a new file got m4 got added if what i do
a git status
you would see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history c3 is the topmost commit
that exists as of now c4 and c5 have
been gotten rid of but the changes that
were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit all
together maybe i'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.txt
and say
one new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say git add dot
i'll also get
commit hyphen m
c4
rewriting history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was a part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and is not
being pushed to the repository take this
scenario wherein let's say i have a git
server
and i have the changes
which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer one is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all this c2 and c3 and
get into c4 and he's pushed all these
contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server was pulled this repository and
all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer
one then figures out that by mistake he
put in the c3 which was the wrong thing
to do and possibly you know he could
have done a better job of fixing this in
a different way so he wants to get rid
of the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and were planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the git
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do get log
pretty one line
i have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 hour
another file in c3 i've added one more
file and in c4 i made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest comment so if at all i see
the contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and
let's say looking at the previous use
case that i mentioned i may want to get
rid of this particular comment i want to
get rid of the c3 which is nothing but
i've added a file called m3.txt but i
added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i look at it later on but for
now i don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the git revert
command so git revert
and the commit id whatever i want to
revert so if i want to revert this
i copy this particular commit id
and bear in mind that considering reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do
one commit revert at a time i can club a
bunch of them together and do one commit
but otherwise the revert always works on
one commit at a time so get revert
paste this
essentially what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while i'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit it unders
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this comment so if i say git
revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from c5 i see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
commit actually is getting rid of this
commit c3 so if at all i see my files
here there's only m1 m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding git which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it's a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space
however in git you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive and great so go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then i'm going to
create a new folder here
i'll create a folder called arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository a dot git
folder is created without any files in
it so let me create a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name.text within this maybe
i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.text
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this
save this content
all right
so if i try to go get status i just
see two files in it so let me go ahead
and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes so get
commit iphone am or iphone m
first comment
so if i do a gig log
i see only one commit and there are two
files and you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch
so let me name my branch as bangalore
branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here
i've just created this branch so if at
all i do a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blr branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is get check out
blr branch now actually switched into
bangalore branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because i've
created a branch from my base branch
which is a master branch and when i
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a
file that is specific to panel branch
so i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put on the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address dot text so i say
notepad address.txt
also simply learn
bangalore office
say located in
[Music]
some arteries
i would say bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot
and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address.text which is there only in the
bangalore branch that i'm presently on
now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is get
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this address
or text in it so let me go back to get
get check out master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.txt
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you were in
the master branch the file that was
there in the bangalore branch which was
called the
address dot text didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to get check out
bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i am switching to bangalore
branch i see this address.txt when i go
back to my master branch i don't say
this bangalore branch
contents which is the address.txt
all right now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so
the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right this
is the name of the repository
git
branch demo this is what i'm going to
put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use
the ssh url yeah this is the ssh url
this is good for me so let me copy this
url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say git
push hyphen u origin
master it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch it looks good
it says new bunch master is created so
if i go back to my server and i do a
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u
origin
and the name of the branch that i want
to specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if i get into this bankrupt branch i
would see the address dot text if at all
i go back into master branch i would not
see this address.txt
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by merging i would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangalore branch to come back
into my master branch so if i go to get
checkout
bankrupt branch i see this attach this
is there only as a part of bangalore
branch now assuming that i'm done with
the changes from the banner branch i
want to get those changes back into my
master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangalore branch changes
and where will it merge it will merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address.txt this file should appear
as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
would see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
all right so there was only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the bangalore branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well
gate push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i mean two branches
the branches master even if i'm in
master brands i should see this address
dot text that is there even if i'm in
the bangalore branch the content is all
same because we have merged these two
branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch
hyphen d and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say get branch
and i'm presently in the master branch
so i can go ahead and delete the other
branch so get branch hyphen d bandwidth
branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen way
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iphone delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
branch please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the gate branching commands
are as follows to create a new branch
you issue a command git branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git branch new underscored
branch it creates a new underscore
branch from the master branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this branch you type in git check out
the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command get
push hyphen u origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new branch are pushed
onto the server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be get branch hyphen av assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
branch into a master branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you are on the master branch and
if you issue a command git merge new
underscore branch this would merge the
contents of the new branch onto the
master branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get branch
hyphen capital d and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this branch from the server
the command to do that is get push
origin hyphen iphone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
branch that you created on the server
welcome everyone to this lesson by
simply over here in which we are going
to talk about the git merge conflict of
this one now we all have worked on gate
and we know that git is a very good
version control system which we have all
together but how to resolve a problem
which is known as git merge because
during the developers check-in or do any
kind of merge activity this is uncommon
problem which they face on daily basis
now this isn't something which we are
going to talk about in this so that we
can give an kind of an insight to all
those developers and to other particular
different people who are using the git
version control system here now what
exactly we are going to talk about here
we are going to talk about what exactly
is git version control system we also
going to talk about what exactly is the
basic git commands used in git
and then we are going to talk about that
what exactly is a merge conflict all
about and then the different type of
merge conflicts which we encounter while
doing any kind of merging or any kind of
modifications
and then how to resolve these merge
conflicts
faced by a particular individual or a
particular developer
and then the last one is that the
various git commands which is involved
in resolving these conflicts
and then we will be going on with a
small demo to better understand that how
these conflicts can be resolved all
together
right so let's first of all talk about
that what exactly is a git version
control system now git is a kind of a
version control system which we
basically used for storing our kind of
source code there which
can be used for storing a source code of
java dot net android node.js different
kind of programming languages can be
stored all together in this virtual
control system so in an organization you
will be having a full-fledged version
control system known as kit
now you may be having different projects
different repositories multiple
developers multiple collaborators
working on different different projects
so it's a very extensive tool which is
used by different developers and
in fact it is not only limited to
developers lot of other people also
exactly use this specific tool now the
main task of using this tool is to
perform a better coordination of the
work here among the different people
among the different developers and also
to have a proper track of the particular
progress of the specific project so
using the repository you can see that
over the period of time you can do the
tracking that how the different commits
are happening here how the different
source code modifications are being done
so the complete status and the complete
stats you will be able to get from this
a kind of a version control system here
now it's mainly used for source code
management here in any particular
software uh development process or a
particular team here so it's a very
important and in fact a key tool for any
kind of development project so the
development cannot survive without
having a git version control system
now
git favors both programmers and
non-technical users now if you are a
programmer definitely you will be using
it for
storing the source code and having those
particular files having some
dotnet source code java or some
particular source code present there but
in fact if you're not a particular
developer if you're not a programmer you
are working as a non-technical job so in
that case also you can store it for
keeping your project files
best example a particular devops
engineer can also use these repositories
to store their version control systems
to have these scripts python scripts
shell scripts configuration management
tool scripts any kind of automation
scripts they can store they want to have
it they can keep use of these particular
version control system here so it's not
a dedicated tool for a particular
developers anyone who wants to utilize
the features of version control system
can make use of this specific tool
in fact it allows a multiple users also
to work together so different people and
different programmers can collaborate
with each other with the help of this
particular specific tool here
and uh it can also handle large projects
if you feel that you are working on a
particular big project which is having
multiple repositories
multiple uh projects are there so in
that situation git version control
system will survive and will provide you
a better performance in different
different aspects so it's a very good
tool for you to handle which big
projects where you are involved with
multiple changes multiple programmers
multiple collaborators and different
kind of source codes
now what are the different basic
commands which we use in git to manage a
git repository now first of all the a
very basic command of a git over here is
git config
whenever we work with any kind of git
repository locally when we do a git
clone and we
manage or we do the modification to the
git repository locally there so in that
situation we often have to provide some
details like the username email id so
that whenever we provide whenever we do
some kind of commits the author details
should be submitted according to that so
in that situation we have the particular
command called git config which will
definitely help us to do some
configurations so that we will be able
to have some configurations configured
and we will be able to have some author
details or some additional parameters so
all those things we can configure using
this git config command here
now
if you want to initialize a
local repository now you're not working
on a remote repository and you want to
initialize a local repository in that
case you can use the git init command in
a specific folder so that you can
convert that a simple folder in a
full-fledged git version control
repository so init command is used to
initialize a local empty bear get
repository
next command is git add now git and
command is used whenever we do any kind
of modifications or into my local
repository so that file will be present
into the working area into the working
copy over there now the moment you run
the git add command on couple of files
or on an individual file so what will
really happen that all those files will
be added to the staging area now why
these files are adding to the staging
area so that at any moment of time when
you run the git commit command these
files will be picked up from the staging
area and will be preserved permanently
into the git repository so when you do
get add command it moves the files from
your working copy to the staging area
and it will remain there itself unless
and until you don't do any kind of git
commit command further so that these
files from staging area will be
permanently written off into the local
repository so it's a very important part
that you run git add command before
running any kind of git commit command
now git commit command will only pick up
those files which is present in the
staging area so if you have done
modifications to 200 files or 20 30
those kind of files there if you do the
git add command only for five six files
so only those five six files will be
taken care in case of a particular
commit so you need to make sure that you
select the desired amount of files
before doing any kind of git commit
activity
right now next command which we have
here is git diff command now git div
command is a kind of base tool which we
have here which really helps us to
understand that how we can check the
difference between two files and in fact
this git diff command can also be used
to see the difference between two
different branches also
so if you feel that if you have done
some changes to the file to a specific
content here now if you want to see the
difference between your particular
head revision number and whatever the
modifications do you have done right now
so in that situation you can run get
tiff command it will let you know that
what the different kind of changes and
modifications you have done so if at any
moment of time before doing any kind of
commits you want to do some kind of
review you want to see that what
different changes you have done so in
that case you can go for the git diff
command so get div command use to see
the content the difference or the
modifications which you have done
recently to the specific file
right and the last one we have already
discussed the git commit command which
commits the changes to the head revision
number and this commits are something
which is stored locally and you will not
be doing the direct commits to the
remote repository so commit is something
which is done into your local repository
only but yes this is the last stage of
doing a modifications here once the
comment is done it will directly modify
your history your git repository history
there and the changes will be
permanently preserved into the
repository so git command is primarily
used for permanently preserving the
changes into your local repository
right so these were some of the commands
there now there are some further
commands also let's discuss about them
now next command is get reset command at
any moment of time you want to do some
undo activity for some local changes
done to your local repository into your
git repository in that case we can use
the git reset command
then next command is git status now git
status command will show you the state
of the working directory and the staging
area so both these area will be shown
when you run the git status command if
you have done any kind of modifications
to the working area that will also be
visible to you and if you add some files
to the staging area that also will be
displayed using the git status command
so git status command is very important
because ultimately it let us know that
how the different things and then how
the different files are modified over
here
right the next thing is get merge here
now git merge is a very specific command
which is used to move the changes from
one branch to another now
at any moment of time if you feel that
you are working on some other branch
like develop branch or some other
feature branch and you want to move the
changes from this feature branch to the
master branch so in that case
you don't have to do the commits all
together again in the master branch all
you can do is that you can go to the
master branch and trigger the merge
activity so this merge activity will
check what is the difference between the
two branches and whatever commits is
missed out it will also be synced back
into the master branch so get merge
actively helps us to move the changes
from one branch to another one
next one is the git push command here
now git push command will eventually
help you to move the changes from your
local uh to move the different comments
from your local repository to the remote
repository now in this case what happens
that if you are working in offline mode
if you have done some couple of commits
now git push will help you to sync those
comments back to the shared to the
remote repository now these remote
repository can be github bitbucket or
gitlab that is a different story but yes
all your changes will be synced or will
be moved from your local repository to
the remote repository right and the last
one is the get pull get pull is an
opposite activity of push here now you
might have seen that some other
developers are also doing some check-ins
or some push activity to the remote
repository now if you still work on an
old version of your source code it may
cause a lot of problem for you so at
frequent intervals you may have to
pull the changes or you may have to
download some changes from the
particular network or from the remote
repository now once that is done you
will be able to see that uh those
particular changes will be pulled down
and you will be pretty much able to do
the uh you will be able to fetch and
download the changes from the remote
repository to your local repository here
so this is an activity which really
helps us to understand that how we can
pull some changes from the remote
repository to your local repository so
that you can have the latest source code
which might be uh pushed by some other
developers or by some other
collaborators so that you can always
work on the latest source code into your
local system so this is again a
mechanism in which we are trying to see
that what are the different git commands
we can explore and we can utilize here
to interact with the git repository so
this was some of the basic commands
which we can use for managing the git
repositories here now let's talk about
that what exactly is a merge conflicts
now merge conflict is something which
gets originated the moment we do some
kind of merging activity now merging is
an process in which we move some source
code from one branch to another now all
the developers cannot work on the same
piece of branch there so what really
happens that in that situation all the
developers mainly work on some couple of
branches and then they all collaborate
to some other branch or different
developers try to push their changes
from the local repository to remote
repository so in all these situations
the source code gets moved from one
location to another now what happens in
as for this diagram we have a remote
repository over here now all we are
trying to do is that we are trying to
push some source code over here from a
particular developer here now he is
doing the pull and push activity and uh
this another developer is there who is
also doing the pull activity here so
merge conflicts uh basically happens
then for example this uh particular
developer a is trying to do some push
right so that push is almost done here
and when the particular developer v is
trying to
push the particular results or try to
push its own content to the remote
repository he got a merge conflict which
means that his particular developer b
merge activity is cancelled is differed
here now it could be a possibility
because of the changes on the difference
on the two piece of source code there so
let's talk about that
now in order to prevent such kind of
conflicts developers usually provide it
with the isolated branches so that they
can work on their branches and once the
development is done they can do a single
merge and they can sync their changes
into a single branch so the git merge
command combines separate branches and
resolves any conflicting edits over
there so once the developers are done
with the specific changes with the
modifications to the source code later
on they can combine those things they
can work on these components and they
can resolve all these conflicting
modifications
right so a merge conflict is an event
that takes place when git is unable to
resolve the differences in the source
code between the two commits
automatically
normally the git is having the
capability to understand that okay these
are the two different piece of source
code which is getting pushed to a remote
repository but in any case it does not
happens automatically
there is any kind of conflict which
arises over there and git is not able to
take any kind of decisions so in that
situation we will be able to get a merge
conflict now it could be a possibility
that one merge can happen successfully
then the next merge will be cancelled
and will be differed due to this merge
conflicts so git can automatically merge
the changes only if the commits are on
different lines or the branches here so
if at any moment of time you are
devoting from the process you are having
some different lines of source code so
that is where the merge completes comes
into the picture
now what are the different kind of merge
conflicts which we normally face
uh the main types of words conflict is
first of all uh there are two points
where we can say that a merge can uh
happen or can come into a conflicted
state the very first one is the uh
started the merge process now if at any
moment of time there are changes in the
working area or working directory and we
are moving or these changes are getting
moved to the
particular working area of the stage
area of the current project so during
the merge activity itself the particular
merge will fail because there are some
changes or there are some kind of
modifications which is right now present
over here in the working area so in this
case conflicts happen due to pending
changes
now for instance you have done some
modification to the changes now you were
planning to do the commit but before
that you felt that i want to do some
kind of merge now since there are some
pending changes which is available there
into your working area so what will
happen that your merge will definitely
will there itself so before even
starting before even initializing the
merge
as in particular pre-check your merge
activity will fail there itself so in
that situation you have to either remove
those pending changes or you have to
resolve those pending changes before
even going for the merge activity
second
during the merge process definitely if
you are getting some conflict so the
merge conflicts gets originated so the
failure during the merge process uh
indicates that there is an conflict
between your local branch and the branch
being merged right so you're trying to
move the changes from one branch to
another so it means that there are some
particular conflicts which is coming up
in the uh particular branch in which you
are trying to do the merge so in this
case get results as much as possible so
if there is any kind of difference
in the source code in the comments and
the different line of source code there
so git automatically try to resolve it
as much as possible but at any moment of
time it's not able to do it's not able
to manage in that case a particular
humor interruption is required so that
we can merge or we can
resolve this particular conflicts
manually there so these are the two
types of situations in which a
particular merge can enter a particular
conflicted area
now how to resolve these merge conflicts
now what happens that in order to
resolve this merge conflicts the simple
way to do this is that we open the file
which is in conflicted uh
status now once that is done you do the
required changes
whatever source code you feel you want
to proceed you will select that source
code you will use that source code and
once the addition or editing of the file
is done so what you can do is that you
can run the pretty much straightforward
command called git add to add that file
to the staging area and then what you
can do is that you can do the git commit
activity so that the particular merge
completes can be resolved and you will
be able to see a merge here now this is
a something which is known as one of the
best approach for resolving the merge
conflicts because even if it comes up if
git is not able to handle it
automatically and it requires for you to
manage it manually here so definitely in
that situation we have to open the
source we have to select that which
portion of a source code we want to keep
do the modifications manually and then
follow the traditional approach to
perform a custom commit so git add and
get commit command you will be doing
there in that situation to have a
particular final merge executed all
together so this is the steps which we
can follow to perform a custom uh to
resolve a particular custom merge
conflicts over here
right now the various git commands which
we can use to resolve the conflicts here
now get log hyphen event merges and
command which helps us to list down all
the commits that are causing the
particular conflict here if at any
moment of time your mergers fail down
and you want to see that what are the
different commits which is causing the
issue here probably you might be you
know ignoring some comments which is not
that much important or you can manually
override the content so that those
conflicts data can also be added and
whatever the changes you are trying to
add that also should be modified
second command get diff command you can
always use the uh to check the
difference between the particular files
between the repository
git checkout is something which you can
use to particularly check out a file so
that uh if you want to check out the
latest content of a specific file or a
folder so in that case you can make use
of this git checkout command here so git
checkout command will definitely help
you to understand that how we can go for
or how we can do the checkout of this
particular repository or a particular
file here
right so then we have a command called
get reset hyphen for mixed so git reset
hyphen f1 makes is then command to undo
the changes of to the working directory
and whatever the particular changes you
have so that will be undo there and it
will be
able to do the undo changes to the
working area and the staging area here
now then we have git merge hyphen if an
award which will be used in order to
exit the merge process and return back
to the state before the merchant begin
if you're not able to resolve the merge
conflicts manually also so in that
situation we will be aborting the merge
situation or a git merge over here
and the last one is get reset so get
reset command is used at in time to of
merge conflicts to reset the conflicted
file so that what we can happen that we
can go back to the previous situation
before even starting or the state before
the merge activity was started there so
git reset will eventually help me to
reset all the files which is in
conflicted area and all latest files
will be checked out and will be replaced
so these are some couple of commands
which we can actually use in order to
resolve the merge conflicts into a git
repository now that was something which
we were trying to understand that what
exactly the git merge was there and how
the git merge originated and how they
get particular merge conflicts gets
created and how we can resolve it now
let's go for a proper demo on this one
so that we can understand it properly
that how exactly get merge conflicts
really work and how we can resolve it
now this is the git bash which we have
installed to run some git commands now
in this one first of all i'm going to
create uh two repositories so i'm going
to run the command call git init
a
that will initialize a repository
get init b that will initialize a b
repository here so to repository i have
got a and b now in uh basis a what i am
going to do is that i am going to add
the remote so get remote
add origin so i'm just trying to add the
origin over here so the origin over here
in this one is the maven build so this
is a repository which i have got into my
github account the moment you do this
what next you can do over here is that
you can run the particular
next git pull command to fetch the
latest updates here right so next move
to the particular next command here
now when you do this what will happen
that all the changes which is present in
the remote repository or central
repository will be available here also
right so you will be able to see some
couple of files all together here now
the same activity you have to do in the
particular
b directory also or in the particular b
repository also so you have to add the
url the remote url here
and in this case also we are trying to
fetch the particular values here now
what will happen that uh we will be
doing some modification in the
particular a repository and then we will
be pushing that change to the remote
repository and then through the b when
we try to push the changes so in that
situation we'll try to see that what
really happens do we really get the
merge conflicts because both of them
although is trying to do the changes to
the central repository but these two
repository represents two different uh
local repositories probably in two
different developers machines over here
so that's what we are trying to
replicate here so i'm going back to the
a directory here so that i would be able
to do some changes all together so i'm
just opening readme.md file here so
pretty much i'm just trying to add some
particular changes over here to this
particular file so
this is what we are trying to do here
now let me add some particular
additional and a particular new line
over here in the file and then save the
content now once this is done i will be
able to see that yes there is an
particular change which is done all
together here so you will be running git
add command
and then get commit command to save the
comments all together
so we are giving a particular commit
here so that we will be able to identify
that this is something which we have
committed from repo a now once this is
done i will be doing the push activity
so that i can push these changes to the
particular remote or the central
repository here so exactly what we did
over here so far we have a particular
downloaded remote repository in a
repository a and then we are doing some
changes some modifications and once
those modifications are done we are
pretty much changing or putting up that
new commit all together to the github
repository so this is what we are trying
to do so far over here in this one so
this get push activity will uh take the
particular access
right so when i do the particular push
activity here so if the credentials are
saved then that's fine otherwise it will
ask for the particular username and
password all together here so that will
be asked by the particular activity here
so it will ask for the password so all
you have to do is that you have to just
share that password
and your git push activity should be
passed on or should be you know
done there and as you can see that
changes really got moved to the github
repository now sometimes the credentials
get expired so you may get some
particular message saying that you have
to put some password there a particular
interactive window will be open there
and you have to prompt or you have to
provide that password and according to
that it will proceed further right so
this will eventually help you to move
the changes into the github repository
altogether so all of your changes will
be pushed to the github central
repository
right after some time it really pushes
my comments to the remote repository it
will take some time depending on the
network connectivity and the kind of
changes you are trying to upload so now
since uh my particular repository is
done so what i can do is that i can
further go back to the particular
directory here now what we can do is
that we can go back to the beat
repository over here and in this case
also i'm just trying to do some
modifications so for instance that uh
i'm just trying to
do the changes here to the readme file
again of kind of for changes in this one
now in this case i'm trying to delete
this line the last line i'm trying to
delete here or a couple of modifications
i want to do over here like
added data
from
repo
and then for the most i want to have
let me do some arrangement like let me
have this
data added all together over here
or i can add it
yes
so data is added and this data is
removed so the idea is that we can do
different kind of reshuffling of the
data up and down so that we can
understand that how it really works so i
have shuffled the data i have removed a
couple of lines and let's see that how
it works right so i have even added some
couple of lines of voltage here in this
new line i have added one line i have
removed from the last and this
particular line i have shifted five six
line up over here now let's me save this
file and then run the git add command
after this we are going to run the
particular comment here saying
commit
from
repo b
once commit is done same activity
pushing it to the remote repository now
let's see what really happens now when
we are trying to push uh this particular
change to the remote repository after
the change was pushed from repo a it
will throw an error saying that uh the
particular due to the conflicts the
updates are simply rejected here right
so in this case what really happens that
because
we are having a different stream of
source code in a remote repository and
from local repository you are trying to
push some different line of source code
so what next you need to do is that
first of all you need to do the activity
called git pull
hyphen hyphen release origin master so
you're going to pull the changes from
the remote repository so that you should
be able to get some particular content
all together in this particular ripple b
over here now the moment you run this
let's wait for this activity
now once that is done you will be able
to see that you are seeing a message
saying that conflicts
are there so first of all you have to
resolve this conflicts and then it will
be proceed further you have some couple
of options like you have to resolve the
conflicts manually and uh because git is
not able to handle it otherwise once the
gate conflicts is resolved you can run
git reverse or iphone iphone continue if
you want to escape this comment so you
can say get rebase hyphen iphone skip
and if you want to abort the particular
this rebase here so in that case you can
run git rebase hyphen iphone
abort
now
since we want to manage or we want to
resolve this conflict manually over here
so what we need to do is that we need to
open the merge tool on this one so once
you open the merge tool from there you
will be able to resolve those changes
manually and then continue with the
array base so let's go with the get
merge tool here so we are going to use
the command called git merge tool now
when you run this so what will happen
that uh it will process it will open the
normal vi command line over here and all
the files will be processed all together
now uh this is the modifications right
which is uh you know which is done over
here uh so we are just trying to see
that which particular file or what
resultant file we want to configure here
right now in this case
since you are able to see that this is
the final file which is present and uh
here exactly the merge conflicts comes
up because you can see that three
different files are given to you in uh
this side so you have some files in
which you added new two lines and here
you added this line there this artifact
will be there now here you also added
this particular new line instead of
having this line default here
so what exactly happens when you scroll
down you will be able to see that where
exactly is the particular issue or what
are the different modifications you
stand there so in this one if you scroll
up and down you will be able to see that
what exactly it happens so the main area
of conflict is first of all this area so
this should not be there as per git as
per the normal file but yes if it is
there so we have to see whether we want
to continue or we want to proceed uh
with this particular specific file or
not so yes so i will say that okay uh
let's
remove
this line let's not uh
just copy this line
let's delete this line here
and
add the line over here in this one
and uh
please this line also from here so this
is what i'm just trying to make use of
case now here i just want to have
the particular
line
pasted okay delete it
so this line i will
okay so i have added this line in the
final i'm just trying to resolve this
conflicts manually i'm just editing this
file here
trying to remove this one this one this
one
and this one so this is how my
particular
final file looks like and i'm good to go
to this one now you have resolved the
conflicts manually by
doing the modification to the file now
just press colon wq save the file okay
and uh then close the other files also
right
so this is how i have done the
modifications and i should be
able to continue further now so what i'm
going to do is like i'm going to run
command git previous i will even
continue now once that is done so
the particular commit which uh or the
modifications which you
have got over here so that is something
which is totally done and yes the
reverse is finalized over here now again
this is the manual modifications which
you have done so you should be good to
go to push to remote repository so again
in this case what you're going to do is
they're going to run like git push
before that if you want to check the uh
particular git log
so you can check the particular git log
over here so the last commit which we
were try to doing like commit from repo
b is also available over here right so a
and b both changes are present now so we
should be able to
push the changes to remote repository
so it will take some time to do the push
and as you can see it's trying to uh put
some content so we'll still wait for the
final confirmation so that we can ensure
that yes all the conflicts is resolved
and yes that's correct all the
particular conflicts are resolved and we
should be able to see both commit a and
commit b into the repository so let's go
back to the github portal and see that
if we really got those particular
comments in that
so let's when we access our particular
repository on github so we should be
able to see that uh we have got an
activity that uh the commit is checked
in there so if you go to the comments
part you should be able to see
that you have got these commits gun
process altogether if you click on any
one of the commit you will be further
able to see also that what different
changes you actually moved so this is
the way that how you can resolve the
conflicts and you can take care of the
changes from two different developers
or for two different push activity so
that's it for this particular demo i
hope you liked it thanks everyone
today's topic is learn html in 10
minutes let's begin
first we'll go through a quick
introduction to basic web architecture
to understand how the internet works
then we'll understand what exactly html
is
after that we'll have a look at what css
is then we'll go through javascript
and in the end we'll create a simple web
page using html and css to gain a better
understanding of the html tags
so without further ado let's begin
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user
then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data
and finally there's the ip address that
is the address assigned to a website in
order to be accessible on the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is
so your browser starts by loading the
main html file and then the css and
javascript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the back end of an
application now secondly we have
the server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of our website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's ip address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an ip address
we put a domain name over that ip
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is html
html is the most widely used markup
language for developing and structuring
web pages on the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is css then
now css is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any html element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is javascript
now javascript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development
it is used for making web pages
interactive and bringing the web pages
to life
so now let's create your first website
now html short for hyper text markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings
paragraphs div containers tables and
more html tags are nested meaning there
are opening and closing tags with the
content in between those tags
so now let's write a simple html code
that will help you understand the basics
of the language so for this i'm using
the text editor that is visual studio
code you can go ahead and download this
text editor from their official website
so here i've created a simple.html file
in my vs code and i've added the initial
html files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction now this
indicates the browser that the document
type to be served to the user is in fact
an html document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your html page
next up you have the html tag that is
used to contain all the web pages html
code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the html tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page
followed by the html tag there's the
head tag now this is the first section
of the code that contains all of the
information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
pages title description additional meta
tags and css code
so here i've used the title tag and
let's give a title say
html
in 10 minutes
all right you can also add css to the
head tag by using the style tag and
change the display styles of html
elements that are being used
the next section is the body tag now the
body tag contains all the displayable
contents of your web page including
headings paragraphs div containers
tables and more
now the html header tags are used to add
headings to a web page
there are several types of headings
available for developers to add to a web
page right so first up let's have a look
at them i'm going to create a simple h1
heading tag
and the message i'm displaying is
this is
the first heading
all right
after this i'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so i'm gonna add a p tag
and save
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
now you can also add line breaks which
are helpful from time to time if you
want to provide a single line break in
your content you can do so by adding the
br tag
so here let me just add one for
better understanding
now the html div tag defines a division
or a section in an html document that is
used as a container for other html
elements
now these elements can include content
areas sidebars page bars page headers
footers etc this tag is used to apply
styles to html elements that cannot be
added otherwise
we can also make use of the html image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a webpage are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say img
within which i mentioned the source
[Music]
i'm adding the html logo so let me just
mention that here
and then i'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file
and when you look at the browser
you can see that uh the first heading is
displayed then your paragraph tag is
displayed followed by the second heading
and then the image
now let me show you how you can add
styles for some of these uh headings and
paragraph tags so here in back in my
first heading tag let me just say styles
and let me change the font of the
content that is being displayed and i'm
going to change it to career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so i'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when i look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
html tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website so it's time for us
today to talk about something very
interesting feature of the html because
this particular session which we are
recording it for you it is designed
dedicated for html based hands-on
so in this html base hands-on we are
expecting that all of you are aware
about the basic concept of html as well
as the css so this
kind of learning is going to help you to
understand like how html and css can
connect together while offering you a
mini application the first application
on this track we're gonna offer you that
is related to your html registration
page okay so
as you know for this particular
registration development application i
would like to use the visual studio code
which is a very very popular tool
provided by microsoft so this tool we
will be using it for our mini
application development so let's get
started with this so step number one let
me go back and create a new folder now i
will create a new folder name called
registration
and inside this i would require two
files number one it's called index dot
html
another one that is called
css we can say
app.css
so in index.html file
we want
some standard development so
i want to start with my html tag
so
i already have this html base auto fill
code provided by your visual studio code
so there are plugins are available
inside this so that you can
automatically create the basic
structure for this html which you can
have the html tag head tag
as well as the body tag and from this
point onwards we will start developing
our code now so
i want to develop a registration page so
in this registration page i will start
from my
form tag now so inside this form it is
saying like form action to something i
really do not have any backend so i just
leave it as a blank and here i will
start with my h1 tag where i want to say
register
after this register i want to offer the
paragraph tag
where i can say please
fill
in this
for
to
register with us
register
with s
okay
now after that i would like to start
with horizontal row so hr
so
starting with my horizontal row
and pause this because see we would like
to organize our application and now
level
in this level for
i just want to give the name called fm
it's just the name
and after this fn stands for the first
name
and within this level i would like to
use the b tag which is
i would say that
here i will pass first name
bold tag is closed it's a label
inside this label i would like to use
input tag
here i will call input app equal to text
and offer a few other details also like
i say
a placeholder
placeholder will offer you what to be
said i'm saying first name
that is
the
placeholder value after this name
equal to
fn that is a stand for first name
after that id
id is option
but if you want to pass we will use this
id fn
id equal to fn
and uh
required
because i want this field cannot be
blank
so this is my
first text box where i have this
first name with me
like that i will go ahead and talk about
my
next property or password and for
password also i would like to have the
similar details with me
so this level i'll
copy and paste it below
and this is for
your password so we're giving the name
called psw
here we are saying password
and uh input typically text so here i
will change input application password
because password field
details would not be visible to you
please
here we will say
placeholder i can say enter
password
name equal to
we can give psw
id equal to we can give same psw
so
we have a password in a similar line we
would like to offer the confirm password
fields too
i will copy this line
and paste it again
and here we can say confirm password
you can say
cpsw
again password enter
confirm password cpsw
and cpsw
now it's over
after this we want to make it as a
horizontal row
closed
and once it is run then we'd like to
have the button with this
so here is the button we can say
register
and here in my button
i would like to offer the type equal to
submit
are we going to
so that's it so this is
the simplest form i have it
now i would like to see how it really
looks like it
so from here i would like to open it
revealing finder
let's open this
well it looks like that
fine so this is what my formless form is
ready and now we would like to go back
and start developing my css in which i
would beautify my form to offer some
more details of this
well friends as we know the html page is
ready it's time to go back and start
developing a css to beautify my html so
inside the css i would like to start
with the tag which is a call body
and
inside this body tag i can offer some
basic setups but
i just want to give the basic background
color now which is called
hyphen color
i can just give the name called d here
that's a background color let's the rest
of the things i can just leave it as it
is now for all the other properties i
can say box sizing
[Music]
auto iphone box
after that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits
now first thing you need to understand
which other places i will be using the
container so you see here in my
index.html file
when we talk about form actions and all
okay we say h1 register we haven't used
any container right now so let's get
added the container
div
class equal to
container
okay and this particular div tag will
get closed only at the last
so
the step tag
will close at the last
here
so i want to make
the look and feel for this complete
container
in much more better way so here in my
container we want to say
margin auto
let's press enter here
margin
auto
now width
50 percent
then adding
16 pixel
followed by background color
which we want white
then box shadow
this box shadow we want to give some all
four origins 20 pixels
continuation to save 20 pixel
and 0 pixel
and which color we want so i just say
rgba
in this rgb just give the value called
zero
again
again 0
and
the value which you want to give to this
alpha because it
is always between
zero to one we are saying zero point
seven that is an opacity
well four properties is given
now let's see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a css
in my html so let's add the css so
inside my
browser html
now inside my head let me add link
rl equal to style sheet href equal to
app.css
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now
so this is your container okay which you
can see it is having some shadow i would
like to organize this all set of text
boxes in much more better way
so after this
we want to offer the other
properties to liken for my input
go back to my css
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now
also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one
width
which is 100 percent
after
sorry
then padding
one second 15 pixels
then
margin you're offering 5 pixels
22 pixel
followed by display
display i will say inline block
inline block
followed by border do you want any
border
so i say null
borderline and background
we can offer the color so we can say
right smoke
that's it let's see in my html
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized
so this is
your form but i want to make it even
more better now because i want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the beautification needs to be
added more here
we want to offer the same input type
text input type password i copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
focus
this has to be on focus
focus and here also
on focus
now background color
we want to change to anything but for a
typing we can just give
same
and
outline
now
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button
so
here we say dot
i do not have that class for register
button so i have to create this class
inside my
button
register
i would like to offer the properties for
those like background color
d
followed by color
which is
white
then padding
we offer 16 pixel
then border
no
then cursor
i think it is better to have pointer
only
then width
solve it by margin
this auto
then opacity
then i say 0.8
fine so this is for my registration
button
let's see
wow this looks better now
so this is a full size button
so this is for my button
and i want the moment i take my cursor
on button the color should change or it
should look like in hover
copy this
over
and here we say opacity
which is with the value called 1
that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working when i press on
register you see the messages
please filter field blank and it is
changing
the
when we talk about the situation
called focus so in this it works like
that when i give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so friends this is what
your registration page with the basic
setup
having this html as well as the css
together so this time we gonna develop
another very interesting example
using this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all i'm gonna
give the name called
html
quiz
now i'm gonna create a three files
inside this number one i'm gonna say
index.html
index.html then i need another file that
is called app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and
see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards deb tag
so within my tip tag
we would like to create
another div tag
okay
so the first top level class
to this particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we see
the class equal to container
now we have got another tab tag inside
this we will set div
id
equal to question hyphen container
question iphone
container so that is the name or id of
this div
and we say class
equal to height
now within this step tag
we would like to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tip tag here
and this step id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we're just creating it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer a few buttons
now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer once so that i can have this
button class
copied three more times
and now we can change
the names to
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
tip tag is getting closed here
and now here
before that last step tag is getting
close we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another div tag so under this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start iphone btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
btn
space
btm
and we say start here
i'll just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we
say next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
btn and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
tab tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span
and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that the div tag is getting closed
and
that's it
and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this div tag i would like to close even
before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip tag which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
script
src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
yes i can see
some standard buttons has been created
now we would like to look may give some
better look and feel to this kind of
button cell
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a route
and with this root some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
the value is giving a score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
hue
again
hyphen rom
this value we are giving us
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyper hyphen hue
this we are making with the variable
hyphen iphone u
neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain zero
after that display
and then
after that not display i would say none
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we're providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contends i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
hyphen hyphen q
and followed by
comma
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
refine the styles we always use
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we're providing
you
wire and here we would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just work
correct
and we can use
body
dot wrong
body dot round
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than saying correct
we're using
wrong
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
box shadow we can say 0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file
so we have a call button grid this
button grid we would like to start from
here
btn create betting grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then zero
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot btn
followed by the details so
i can open you
var
we'll be using neutral
okay
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
were
hyphen iphone u
followed by
okay these are the values for
border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
and 50
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
adding
just
5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my
button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button over
dot ptn
dot
or
and for this performer
you want to say border color
this border color you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen pt
common look and feel for both
font size
one
dot five
rem
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is be like 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next
cursor will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls reset display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and
last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start then only the
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button
equal to
document
dot
get element by id and here you will get
the name called
start
hyphen btn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here
another one
here we change the name
and give the name called
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element documented good element by id
here we'll be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shuffle question because
we want every time the questions to be
get shuffled
shuffled questions
current question
index
shuffle questions and current question
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
const
equal to
eric
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here you will see
javascript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay so i would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i see text
first will be python
python
okay
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so i can say true
last i'm keeping it's called
false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so i just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who is the prime minister of india
so we can have two
answers available
okay
talk about kundalini removing value is
called work true
second we're going to give the name call
this value is called false
so taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 x 3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called
six
which is false seconds 12
like that total we have created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be notes called clear
status class
function
player
status
class
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
dot
remove
element.classlist.remove
correct
and once again i copy the same line
raw
[Music]
so we have two options available
call what
right and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached
there's only one function we've attached
that's called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
called
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
then
element
dot
class list dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
but we'll try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
selected button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class function
in this set status class we'll be
passing
document
dot body
as the first parameter
and
correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay followed by
dot
for each here
we're using
this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
data set
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called if
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current question index
plus one
then what
then we are saying
next button
dot
classlist
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
called if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot
get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot
inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class list
add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we'll be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is
something which you wanted to start with
okay
well
reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
in a text
equal to
question
dot
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers
dot
for each and here i would like to use
we are passing what
answers and parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document dot
get sorry document dot create element
i'd like to create a button
now okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
class list
dot and here we are
offering
btn
okay now you're saying
if
the condition is
answer dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot
dataset
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay
now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child
of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state the function we are calling
it and saying
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is water set
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal
we have called to
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
five
we are passing this value
okay
after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are giving 0 right
now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
remove
height
okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is a function we are calling it
and initializing our quiz score
with the value call 0
well start game is
ready
next thing which you to start the cover
button
so here we are saying
start button
dot
add event listener
here
in this
on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button
dot
ad event listener on click
on click
we're using
okay so here we are calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with this
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see
is automatically making the rest of them
as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
narendra modi
great next
and i say
four multiply by three i said twelve i
said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask as a flask it says splitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how dear
friends your project is now completely
working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button now it's giving me four multiply
by three
that means it is one second have taken
random question cascading style sheet
which is also called css is an important
aspect of web designing
it has made our web page responsive and
user friendly this video will help you
understand all the concepts of css and
provide lots of hands-on examples
we'll start with understanding selectors
box model grid layout flexbox
differences between grid layout and
flexbox and some more basic topics
then building on these basics will make
a navbar learn how to create animation
and transitions and finally we'll move
on to css advanced functions so let's
begin
in this video you will learn what are
css selectors and what are their
different types what are css selectors
css selectives allow you to select and
style html elements selectors are used
to find elements based on their id
classes types attributes value of
attributes and much more
let's discuss the most common selectors
there are several different types of css
selectors the most common of them are
css element selectors css id selector
css class selector css universal
selector and css group selectors so what
is the css element selector
the element selector selects element
based on the element name
this is a css selector
it means it will select all the p
elements on the page it will style all
the p elements to the central aligned
having blue color
this is a css selector
it is set to p
this means it will select all the p
elements on the page it will style all
the p elements to be center aligned
having blue color
let's look at what it looks on a page
so as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned with the text color
blue
css id selector
the id selector uses the id attribute of
an html element to find a specific
element
an id should be unique within the page
so you should use the id selector to
find a single unique element
to find an element within a specific id
use a hash character followed by the id
of the element so
here
we have used the hash paragon so all the
rules will be applied to the html
element with id equal to para1 so this
is an id selector
it will be applied to all the html
element with id is equal to para1
as you can see it is applied to the
element having the id parameter and all
the other elements are defaultly styled
css class selector the class selector
finds the element with a specific class
set by the html class attribute to
select an html with a specific class use
the period character followed by the
name of the class so this style will be
applied to all the elements having the
class name class 1. this is a class
selector it is denoted by a period
symbol
all the elements having a class name
class 1 will be styled with centrally
aligned and color blue
as you can see the element having the
class name class 1 is styled and all the
other elements are set to default
css universal selector the universal
selector selects all the elements on a
page the universal selector is assigned
by a star character the universal
selector selects all the elements on a
style sheet
as you can see it is generated by a star
mark all the elements inside our page
will be centrally aligned and the color
will be set to blue
as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned and the colors are set
to blue
css group selector
in style sheets there are often elements
using the same style to minimize the
code you can group selectors to group
the selectors separate each selectors
with a comma here we have group
selectors for h1 h2 and p
so style is applied to h1 h2 and p
elements only
it is better to group the selectors to
minimize the code
here we have group selectors p h2 and s3
so style will be applied to only
elements having p h 2 and s 3
as you can see so all the elements of p
h 2 and s 3 are centrally aligned and
colored to red in this video we will
discuss what is the box model and its
various properties
we will also do an example to understand
the box model better
so let's get started
every element that can be displayed on a
web page is comprised of one or more
rectangular boxes css box model
typically describes how these
rectangular boxes are laid out on a web
page
these boxes can have different
properties and can interact with each
other in different ways but every box
has a content area and options
surrounding padding border and margin
areas
the following diagram demonstrates how
the content padding border and margin
css properties determine how much space
an element can take on a web page
the content area consists of content
like text images or other media
it is bounded by the content edge and
its dimensions are given by the content
box width and height
the border area is the area between the
box padding and margin
its dimensions are given by the width
and height of the border
the margin area consists of spaces
between the border and the margin
the dimensions of the margin area are
the margin box width and margin box
height
it is useful to separate the element
from its neighbors
the padding area is the area
that includes the elements padding this
area is actually the space around the
content area and within the border box
its dimensions are given by the width of
the padding box and the height of the
padding box
now let's jump to an example to
understand the box model better
so we are on the sublime texture to get
started i have created a box named
simply background color pink the font
size is 30 pixel and we have set the
border to zero solid green
let's see how it looks on our page
so as you can see we have a box named
simply learn with background going all
the way to the end
i have also removed all the padding and
margins from the page so that the boxes
are pushed just at the corner of the
page
as you can see
let's start by adding a padding of 20
pixel to the box
if you save the file you can see the box
increased by 20 pixels from all the
sides
padding occurs inside the background of
an element it goes around the content of
the element
most of the buttons inside the css are
designed using padding so that the
background of the button becomes wider
than the actual text
the next thing we can do is change the
border of the element if you change this
border size to 15 pixel we will get a
nice solid background of color green
the border goes around the padding of
our element so we have the 20 pixel of
padding around our content and 15 pixels
of water around the padding which is
round the content
now we'll see that working on the margin
if you add 30 pixel of margin to our
element you can see the spacing on the
outside of our border
so let's add that to pixel margin and
refresh
you can see the spacing on outside of
the border
margin is used to space two elements
apart from each other
now let's change these values to see the
difference
let's make the margin 40 pixels
we'll make the padding 30 pixels
and let's keep the border 20 pixels and
make it color
red
this is 40 pixels
let's observe the changes
so as you can see our border now has a
red background the padding is 30 pixel
the margin is 40 pixels let's inspect
the elements to understand it better
by clicking on inspect you can see the
different styles
here in the computer tab you can see the
box model
this is a content area
this is the padding area this is the
border and this is the margin area
we have the margin of 40 pixels around
the
border so you can when you click on this
area you can see the margin
gets highlighted
the border area gets highlighted of 20
pixels
this is the padding and this is the
content
you can change the size of the content
by adding the height and width
so let's try adding height and width
we'll give the height 50 pixels and
we'll give the width also 50 pixels
just save the file
now when you refresh you can see the
content area of 15 to 50 in this
tutorial
we will discuss everything needed for
you to get started working with grid
layouts
we will start by discussing what is a
grid layout
then we will move on to the features of
the grid system and some basic
terminologies which will help you
understand the grid system better
in end we will work on an example to
understand the grid system
so let's get started
what is a grid
a grid is a setup intersecting
horizontal and vertical lines defining
the rows and columns
and what is the grid layout
so css gridloud is the most powerful
layout system available in css
it is a two dimensional system
meaning it can handle both columns and
rows unlike flexbox which is largely a
one-dimensional system
you work with grid layout by applying
the css rules to both the parent element
which became the grid container and the
elements children which become the grid
items
the css grid allowed access at dividing
a page into major regions or defining
the relationship in terms of size
position and layer between parts of a
control build html primitives
you can see this is the basic layout of
a grid system
like tables grid layout enables an
author to align elements into columns
and rows
however
many more regular layouts are either
possible or easier with css grid than
they were with tables for example
a grid container's child element could
position themselves so they actually
overlap and layer similar to the css
positioned elements
so here are the features of the css grid
layout
they are fixed and have flexible track
sizes
you can create a grid with fixed track
sizes using pixels
for example
this sets the grid to the specified
pixel which fits to the layout you
desire
you can also create a grid using
flexible sizes with percentages with the
new fr unit designed for this
purpose you can place the items into a
precise location using the grid
line numbers names or by targeting an
area of the grid
the grid also contains an algorithm to
control the placement of items
not given an explicit position on the
grid
you can define an explicit grid with a
grid layout the grid layout
specification is flexible enough to add
additional rows and columns when needed
features such as adding as many columns
that will fit into a container are
included
it also gives you control of overlapping
content
more than one item can be placed into a
grid cell or area and they can partially
overlap each other this layering may
then be controlled with the z-index
property
so
here are the basic terminologies you
should know to work with the grid system
better
the grid line is the dividing line that
make up the structure of the grid
they can either be vertical or
horizontal and reside on either side of
rows and columns
a grid column is spaced between two
adjacent vertical grid lines
the size of a grid column is determined
by the grid template column's property
on the other hand a grid row is a space
between
two adjacent horizontal grid lines
its size is determined by the grid
template rows property
the grid cell is the single unit of a
css grid
and in great design a gutter is
basically the width of the space between
columns a gutter margin is this white
space formed by the adjoining inside
margins of two facing pages in a book or
a space between columns on a page
so
with this
let's now move on to the hands-on demo
and see how the grid system works in
actual world so we are in the sublime
text editor open with a project with
some basic background styles and nothing
inside the body
you can see this is a basic background
style we have pre-applied just to have a
good look of the
box model
we'll start by creating a container and
wrapping our grid items in it
so let's create a grid and give it a
class name grid container
and inside of it we'll put our different
grid items
so we'll just create different grid
items and give them a class grid item
followed by a class number they belong
to
so that we can easily distribute between
them
just copy paste this five times
so we'll have the five elements on our
page
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so you can see we have the different
grid items on the screen so that is easy
for us to visualize
we have not applied any styles to them
other than the visual styles
so we'll go back to our code
let's go back to the css styling sheet
so to create the grid we will open a
style sheet we need to display grid on
our grid container so we'll select the
grid container and set the display to
grid
it is saved now
you will see nothing changes this is
because the grid itself doesn't define
any rows and columns for us to work with
it just they give the alignment properly
therefore by default it looks just
exactly the same
to make the grid look actually great
what you need to do is define columns
and rows for a grid
so to do this you will use a set grid
template and set the column if you want
to set the size of the column
we'll set the size to 100 pixel 150
pixels
now
if you refresh you have the 100 pixel
column on the left and a 150 pixel
column on the right
and then the grid captures our next row
but what if we want our box to flexible
size themselves according to the items
inside of them
here we'll use a fraction unit instead
of a 150 pixel column we want one
fraction of our size and instead of 100
pixels we want the two fractions of our
size
so we'll just replace with two fractions
and this with one fraction
now if you save the file
and go back to the page
you will see that the items on our left
here in our first column are twice as
large as the item on the second column
and that's because of the fr units we
have defined
you can see the difference in the sizes
the item one is the twice of the size of
the item two
another thing you can do is with columns
is use repeat
suppose you want four columns of a size
100 pixel wide you can just write repeat
command and inside of it how many times
you want to repeat the size
so we'll just delete this
and use repeat
we'll set the number of times we want to
repeat and the size of the
columns
now if you save the file you will see we
have a four columns of 100 pixel wide
we can do the same things for row
just set the grid template
rows and define the size you want
now you can see we have the symmetric
size all around our container
if you don't know how large your grid is
going to be you can use the grid auto
rules and this will determine the size
of all the rows that is added after the
template rows
suppose we want all our rows to be 100
pixel
so we'll just delete the grid template
rows
and set the grid auto rows to 100 pixels
now you can see all the rows are now 100
pixel tall
let's change our colon back to 100 pixel
and 150 pixels
so that it will be easier for us further
we'll just delete this grid auto rows
now we'll talk about the spacing of the
rows and columns apart from each other
we can do this with the help of the grid
grab property grilled row gap will give
some spaces between the rows similarly
the grid column will give you the spaces
between the columns
now you can see the gaps between the
rows and columns
now we want the same value for both the
columns you can use the grid grab
property and mention the space
we'll just delete these two
and instead of it we will use just the
grid gap
and set the
size to 20 pixels
now you can see the evenly spaces
between the rows and the columns
this is all you need to know about the
sizing of the different columns and rows
now let's talk about the positioning
items within its grid cells
so for horizontal positioning we could
use the justify items and we can set
that to center
so that centers each item within the
cell
by default it is set to stretch
you can also set it to start
or end
or space around
we will leave this to center
to vertically position the content we
could use the align items
the
items also accept the same values
we can set it to center
we can also set this one to start or end
just will keep this to center as well
you can also align the entire grid
within the container
so let's get rid of these to just
demonstrate them
in a proper manner
we could use the justify content and
that will align the content horizontally
within the container
we can also set this to start or to end
just set this back to center
to align the content vertically we could
use the align content and the align
content also accepts the same value
you can set it to center
or start
if you inspect the elements
you can see they are aligned centrally
between the container
we will just close this
okay so this is everything you need to
know to get started with the grid layout
grid works very similar to the flexbox
but it allows it too much in terms of
laying your elements because of its 2d
nature in this video we will learn
what is a flexbox and how it is useful
in designing the layout of the website
we will also try to understand the
different properties of flexbox with the
help of an example
so let's get started
what is a flexbox flexbox
also called flexible box model is
basically a layout mode or model that
provides an easy and clean way to
arrange the items within a container
if you are using a css for a while you
must have used the old block model where
you assigned width in terms of
percentage or fixed width
and then use the float to arrange the
items on the page
suppose for example
you want to arrange three boxes in a row
then you have to enter everything
manually from width height and to
padding flexbox can do all these things
with ease
some of the concepts of flexible box
model is the ability to alter the item
width and height to best fit in the
containers available in the free space
flex model is the direction agnostic
which is different from the box model
which is vertically biased and the
inline which is horizontally biased
flexbox works for both
flexbox is more effective in small scale
layouts
so here are the main properties of the
flex
ok
so let's jump to some code and learn how
these flex properties work
okay so we are in the sublime text later
to get started let's add a div inside a
body here and we'll give a class of
flexbox container since this will be the
container where all our flexbox item
will reside
then inside this container we will add
another div and give it a class flexbox
item and one more class flexbox item 1
which will help us to understand which
items we are referring to when we style
our elements individually
let's just save the file and see how it
looks on a page
now if you save the file you can see we
have the box because i have already
applied some of the styles to these
flexbox items
let's just see the styling
so you can see we have the item styled
just a basic styling so that we get the
box on our page
now let's just copy these and add two
more flexbox items and you will see we
have two more boxes on our page
just copy and paste them below
give them the class name flexbox item 2
and flexbox item 3.
just save the file
now you can see we have three boxes on
the page
now to create a flex container
we will add display flex to our flex
container and this is how we create a
flex
box container
so here we will just add
display
flex
just save the file
now you can see all the items are in the
same height and they are all in the same
row
you will also notice that if we shrink
our browser the items adjust themselves
accordingly to fit within the browser
now if you want to style the elements on
the main axis we will use the property
justify content inside of flexbox
container
let's
make it a center
the file
now you can see that all the elements
are in the center of the page
another thing we can do is if we want
our layout to have a spaces between the
elements
we will set the justify content to space
between
you can see all the items are evenly
spaced
if you want to lay out your items on the
cross axis we would use the align items
property
the default value for this is stretch
if we want to keep the size of our items
we will use the center and then all our
items will be centered vertically
before flexbox aligning the items
vertically inside the container was
nearly impossible
with flexbox you can do it easily
now you can see the items are aligned
vertically inside the container now
let's just delete everything and we'll
just keep the display flex
now if you want to have a column layout
instead we will use the flex direction
and change it to column flex direction
column now if you refresh the page you
will see all the items are shown up in a
column
now we can start talking about the
different properties that can be applied
to our different flexbox items as
opposed to flexbox container items the
flexbox container is only for laying out
and spacing between your items as well
as the positioning of your item inside
the container
the actual flexbox item properties are
used to override those item properties
or to apply different sizing to these
elements now if you want the first item
that it does not shrink when we shrink
our browser we'll set the flex shrink to
0 to our first item
so we'll set the flex
shrink to 0.
now if you go back to the page
and try to shrink this
you see the first item remains the same
it does not shrink
now
in the same way you can set the items to
grow in proportion with the web browser
suppose we want our flex box item to to
grow with the as the page grow and cover
all the empty spaces
so we'll set this flex grow to one
now
you will see the all these empty spaces
are taken by the second item
let's say we want our second box to be
the center of the container instead of
stretching to full height we can use the
align self property and set it to center
now you will see that the alliances
property overrides the align content
property of the
container can see it is centrally
aligned
so this is all you need to understand
and get started to work with the
flexboxes
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new about the flexbox
and how you can use the flexbox to
create the dynamic layout for your site
in this video we are going to discuss
one of the most important topics of the
web development which is css display so
without wasting any time let's get
started
so what is the display property
the css display property controls the
layout of the element on the page
the default value of the display
property is block or inline
let's jump back to our sublime text
later to see the various display
properties by using an example to get
started i have a really simple example
setup
as you can see inside my html i have the
two paragraph tags
and
i have a formatting
with the background pair of scan color
and font size 30 pixels
as you can see this looks like something
like this on the page
the very first property we are going to
discuss is the display block property
the drug display values make an element
a block element
the block elements start a new line and
span the entire width of the viewport by
default
like how p elements behave
there are also line breaks before and
after these elements
the default value of the
p element is a display block
so here
this looks something like this
what display blocks does is it means
that it is going to take the entire bit
given to it
this is going to force a new line above
and new line below it so you cannot have
something next to here now if we change
here this to
[Music]
the next property we are going to
discuss is inline
the inline display value turns any
element into an inline element
these elements will appear on the same
line without breaks
now if we change here this to display
inline now all the p tags will behave as
an inline element
now if we go back to our page and
refresh
you can see now this is an inline
element
the inline element takes the minimum
amount of space possible
as you can see here the cn color takes
the minimum amount of space to fit all
the content inside of this p
so this is what an inline element does
also all the inline elements are on the
same line
they share the space together because
they take the minimum amount of space
possible
there are no line breaks in these
elements and they try to fit as closely
as possible
now
one of the demerits here is we cannot
change the height and width of the
inline element
if you change here height
to 200 pixels
and with 200 pixels
and save
just go back and refresh
you'll see nothing happens
this is because in the inline display
property you cannot change the height
and width of the element
the next property we are going to
discuss is the inline block value the
inline block value is a hybrid of inline
and block element elements assigned
display inline block appears on the same
line with the other inline elements
a characteristics of inline elements
however inline block elements are also
like block elements in that you can
change the width and height of the css
now if here we try to change the height
and width
of the element
just change this to inline block
now if you go back to the page and
refresh
you will see the height and width
property works this is one of the major
difference between the inline block and
the inline l inline display property
the last name type of display we are
going to discuss is the display none and
this is a really straightforward display
property
you just delete this
and change the display to display none
now if you save the file and go back and
refresh
you'll see both the element disappears
the display name removes the targeted
elements and all its child elements from
the page
this causes accompanying elements to
behave as if this element does not exist
in this video we will discuss everything
you need to know about css positioning
by the time this video is over you will
be able to position the elements in css
like a pro so let's get started
first let's cover the theoretical part
here we will discuss what is the ss
position property and its different
types
after that we will jump to practical
example to learn how to work with these
properties
so let's get started
so what is css position property
the css position property allows you to
define the position of an element on a
web page
the top right bottom and the left css
position properties
are used to determine the final location
of the element
there are four values that you can use
to set the position of an element on a
web page
they are static fixed relative and
absolute
using one of the four values above you
can specify how an element should be
positioned
you can also use the top bottom left and
right properties to further define the
element position on a page so let's
discuss each of the properties
individually
css static position
this is a by default position for html
elements
it always positions an element according
to the normal flow of the page it is not
affected by the top bottom left and
right properties
it is important to note that having a
static position is the same as not
setting the position property at all
the next is css fixed position
the fixed positioning property helps to
put the text fixed on the browser
the fixed test is positioned relative to
the browser's window and does not move
even when you scroll the window
the next is css relative position
the relative position property is used
to set the element relative to its
normal position
the relatively positioned element
behaves the same way as a static element
except that it is now subject to the
values of the four other css properties
we will discuss each of them with more
detail in examples
now there is css absolute position
the absolute positioning is used to
position an element related to the first
parent element
that has a position other than static
if no such element is found the
containing block is html
with absolute positioning you can place
an element anywhere on the page
now let's move on to the example to
understand each of the properties better
to demonstrate the properties i have the
simple example setup
currently we have three elements with
just basic coloring style
we have not applied any position style
to them
now let's click on this
element too and inspect it
just go to the computed
and type here position to see the
position of this element
so you can see that currently a position
is static
static is the default value of all the
elements of the page in starting
the next position we'll see is a
relative position
it works almost in a similar manner to
static
if we go here and change the position to
relative
you can see nothing changes
relative act is the same as static but
the only difference is that the relative
allows you to change the top left right
and bottom of this element let me show
an example
now if we change here to
left
20 pixel
and refresh
you will notice the elements move itself
to 20 pixels from the left let's set the
top to 10 pixel as well
you can see the element has moved 10
pixels from the top and even overflows
the element below
this is because relative position when
applied with the top right left and
bottom actually takes that element out
of the document flow
so let's just reset it
next property we are going to discuss is
absolute position and this property gets
well along with the top right left and
bottom
so let's make this position to absolute
and you can see the changes made due to
this by just
saving
the absolute value completely removes
the element from the document flow
this is useful when you want a
particular element to be a specific
position but you don't want to disturb
the other elements positioning
accurate position positions the element
inside the some parent container that it
can reference
now just
let's shift the top to 10 pixels
you can see the movement of this element
[Music]
the absolute position always position
the element inside some parent container
that it can reference to
now if we change the here body position
to relative now the
this nav bar will position the element
according to this body so if you go here
and refresh this you can see that this 2
is in relation to with this container
and this is where relative is very
useful
next is fixed positioning which is very
similar to absolute positioning with
some differences
so let's change this to fixed
and just save this
now you can see it completely ignores
this relative positioning and goes
entirely at the top
this is because fixed position elements
are always fixed based on the entire
html element
it has nothing to do with the parent
elements
one unique feature of the fixed element
is they stay in the same place when you
scroll
let's make the height here
to 200 vertical height
now if you scroll down you will see that
the element two will stay on the same
position
see
the two element is stick to the same
position
but actually it does not work that way
when you change this here to absolute
you can see it does not stay
at the top now
this is one major difference between
absolute and fixed
so that's it you can see the working
with the css position super easy in this
video
we'll discuss the differences between
both the layouts and we'll discuss which
one you should use
i will also show you both the layouts in
a practical example without diving too
deep
so let's first understand the theory
css grid allows developers to construct
custom grids with more flexibility and
control than ever before
it is for two dimensional positioning we
got rows and columns here
whereas flexbox is for one-dimensional
layout it is useful in allocating and
aligning the spaces among the items in a
grid container the flexbox layout
pattern makes it easier to design and
flexible and effective layouts
the grid is used for creating more
complex and organized layouts on your
pages whereas the flex items is used to
design the responsive pages without
using
too much of positioning or float in our
css code to work with the css grid
layout you have to add display grid
property to your element
whereas to create the flex container you
have to use the display flex property
so this is the main difference between
the layout of the
grid and the flex blocks
here in the grid layout you can see that
there are rows and columns with all the
header menu main right and the footer
included whereas the flexbox is only for
one dimensional positioning
now let's move on to the example to see
the working of the both the layouts so
here is an example of the web page that
does not have any function other than
some basic styling
here on the page we have a header which
is blue in color
this is a sidebar with a red background
and this is the main content and this
black color is the footer of the page
here you can see this all these items
are stacked on top of each other
in the code you can see um this is the
footer part of the page
this is the main content of the page
this is for the sidebar and this is for
the header area of the page
for the styling part we have used some
basic styling just so as to understand
the example better
now
we can turn the body into a grid by
setting the display property to the grid
so here under the body we'll set the
display to grid
just save the file and refresh
you can see nothing changes because by
default the css grid starts creating
rows automatically and adds the content
in these rows that's why it didn't
change
we can change it by adding the grid
template column property in our body
in our case we'll need two columns one
for sidebar and other for the main
content
let's set the side area to 30
and we'll keep the main area to auto to
cover the remaining spaces
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are broken into the
cells we created
we'll also define the rows for our
header and we'll use the grid template
rows
we'll set the grid template rows for the
header to 60 pixels
for the sidebar and for the main content
we'll set it to auto
and also for the footer we will keep it
60 pixels
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements adjusted in a 2d
manner just as we wanted
this shows the power of the grid and the
flexibility it provides to the developer
however
we can see that items are not positioned
properly in the header
and the footer
this is where the flexbox comes into
play as discussed earlier flexbox is
about positioning elements in a
one-dimensional area
so what we'll do is we'll go back to our
navigation list class here
and will add display as flex
now if you save the file and reload
you can see these are sitting next to
each other
by default the display sets them into
the rows
now we want the contents to be in the
center of the main axis
so we will use the justify content and
set it to center
you can see the items are now in the
center of the main axis
to center them vertically we'll use the
align items and set it to center as well
this will position them in the center
across the axis
for this to work we have to specify the
height so we'll set it to 100 percent
so now you can see the items are aligned
centrally both on the main axis and the
cross axis
let's now add some spacing between these
items
so to give some spacing between we'll
add a margin to navigation item class
we'll set the margin to 0 for top and
bottom and 10 pixel to left and right
if we save the file and refresh
you can see we have the spaces between
the items
in this video you will learn how to set
a background image on a webpage you will
also learn so the basic properties of
the background that are used to set the
image
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
in this tutorial we will discuss what is
css background image after that we will
discuss some of the basic properties of
the background image in the end we'll
add a background image to our webpage by
adding the code to our text editor
so let's begin by discussing about the
background property of the css
the background image property specifies
an image to use as a background of an
element
the background is defined in the body
element of the html code
to add a background image on an html
element use the html style attribute and
the css background image property
and mention the path of the image inside
the url attribute
there are several properties of the
background that are used to define the
image on a page
some of the common ones are background
image background repeat and background
position
by default the image is repeated so it
covers the entire element
let's switch to the text editor and see
how we can add the background image to
our page so we are on the sublime text
editor let's start by opening a style
tag
the background image is always set on
the body tag so type body and open the
curly braces
the background image is always set on
the body tag
so open the body type with curly braces
and start typing background image
use the url value of the background
image to set the path of the image
make sure the image is in the same
folder as of the html file here we have
our file nature 3.jpg
so mention the path inside the double
quotes
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a web page
as you can see we have the image on the
web page let's format this image a
little bit we'll start by setting the
background size so type background size
and there are three values to the
background size first one is auto
it will set the image as it is
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page
as you can see the size of the image is
as same of the original size
the color value will set the image size
that will be fit to the web page
as you can see the image is set to the
whole web page
we can also set the image size to manual
let's say we want the image size of bit
500 pixels so
now as you can see the width of the
image is 500 pixels next we will set the
background repeat property
there are three values to background
repeat first is no repeat with no repeat
value the images will not be repeated on
a page
now as you can see the images are not
repeated
second is repeat text it will set the
images to be repeated on the x-axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated on the x-axis
similarly repeat the images on the
y-axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated to the y-axis and there is a
default value repeat which will repeat
the images on the web page
so let's keep it to cover
so let's keep the background size to
cover
and set the background repeat to no
repeat
let's save the file and look it on a
webpage
now as you can see the image is fully
put to the webpage
let's add a text above our image to see
how it looks like
so i'll add a paragraph tag
and type some random text here
let's set the text color to red and
align it to center
i'll type p and open the curly braces
i'll set the color to red
and i'll set the text align to center
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
as you can see we have a text above our
image which is centrally aligned and the
text color is red in this tutorial we
will learn how we can add colors to our
page using different methods we will
start with discussing colors and then
see the hex value and rgb format of the
colors in the end we'll do an example to
understand how we can add colors to our
page
css uses the color values to specify the
colors on a page
they can be specified using predefined
color names hex or rgb format they are
nearly 140 standard color names
hexadecimal is a sixty representation of
a color the first two digits are
represents a red value the next two are
green value and the last is a blue value
all the other colors can be created
using the combination of these three
colors
there are several websites available
where you can know the hex value of the
different shades of color
as you can see the black color is
signified by hashtag and the six zeros
the red is hashtag ff and the four zeros
followed by it
the rgb color value is specified using
the rgb property this property takes
three values one for red green and blue
the value can be the integer between
zero to twenty five or a percentage
as you can see the black color is
signified by zero zero zero the red by
two fifty five zero zero the blue by 0 0
255 and the green by 0 to 55 0.
now let's move to an example to
understand how we can add the colors to
our page
in this example we will see how we can
add colors in different ways to our html
so we are on the sublime text editor as
you can see we have the standard wallet
ready with an h2 and a paragraph on our
page open the style tag and make the
font size of the paragraph to 25 pixels
so it is clearly visible
let's start by adding colors to our text
just by color names html supports nearly
140 standard color names
we'll make the color of the paragraph
green for that just type color and set
the color to green
as you can see our paragraph is changed
to green
let's try one more
this time we will add the color red
just refresh
as you can see the color is now changed
to red
there are nearly 140 html standard
colors that are supported by the web
browser
you can also add colors using the rgb
format there are many websites available
to know the rgb or hex value of the
desired color
one such is html codes.com
as you can see in the htmlpost.com we
have the hex value and rgb value of the
desired color
let's try one
we'll add this color with rgb value 171
229 and 27 to our paragraph so for that
just type rgb and the color code you
want
as you can see the color is not changed
to our rgb value let's try one more
this time we'll use this rgb value to
our text
you can see the color is changed to our
desired value
in this way you can use the rgb format
to change the colors
the next way is using the hex values
hexadecimal is the sixth representation
of a color the first two digits are red
next one two are green and the last are
the blue value
let's see how you use the hex
values as you can see the hex value for
this color is hash 31787f
we'll use this value to our text
to add the hex value you have to use the
hashtag followed by the color port
you can see that color is changed to a
hex value let's try one more
you can see the hex value for this color
is hash f14a07
just copy the desired value to your file
you can see the color changes
you can also add color borders to our
heading
do that just mention the border style
along with the color code
we'll add the border color red to our h2
now you can see we have the border
around our h2
i hope you have understand how to use
the color values to a web page there are
mainly three ways by which you can add
the colors to your web page there are
hex rgb values and the color names
in this video we will discuss what are
keyframes and how you can use them to
add animations to your page
we are going to discuss what are
keyframes and will try to understand the
syntax of the keyframes so let's get
started
the keyframes are used to specify the
animation code in the page they are used
to change the animation from one pattern
to another keep in mind that the
keyframes do not have any selectors on
them
they are not tested inside anything
they are on the root of the css page you
write at the right keyframes and the
name you can name it anything you want
we are going to use that name later on
to call the selector in this case we are
looking at from and two from implies the
initial state and to the ending state
here in this example the element will
start from 0 pixel and will go all the
way 200 pixel so what we are going to do
right now is we are going to jump to the
keyframes and work out some examples to
understand the working of the keyframes
better so we are on the sublime text
later and this is a simple setup
we have created one html element named
box and we have a css body of padding 50
pixel and the box element has an inline
block
background red with height with 200
pixel
and also i have an animation stand
declared on the box
currently it's doing nothing because it
is calling keyframes called my frames
but we have not yet created any keyframe
we will discuss what this animation line
means at later stage but right now i
need those lines to be able to expose
you to the functioning of the keyframes
you can see we have a box on our page
with the color red
and padding 50 pixels around it
we are going to write add the keyframes
and i am going to use the name my frames
then we will write prompt condition to
have the starting state and let's just
keep the height 200 pixel
and then we want it to grow and we'll
set it to increase till 500 pixels so
let's just create our keyframes
this is a from condition
we will set it to 200 pixels
and we want it to grow till 500 pixels
just save the file
now as you can see our box is going all
the way to 500 pixel and when the
animation is done it resets back to 200
pixel and starts again because the
animation is looping you can also put
multiple style declaration
for example i am going to write
background pink
in the two condition
just save the file
you can see that the animation is
starting at
red and ending at pink now instead of
saying from and do we can also say from
zero percent to hundred percent
this is as same as doing from and two
but what it enables you to do is you can
add something in the middle of here say
30 and we will make the color any
different
so in the place of prob we'll write zero
percent
and we'll replace true with hundred
let's just add one more condition in
between say 40
so at 40 we want the color to change to
say something uh
green
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so as you can see it starts with red it
turns to green in the middle and then
all the way converts to pink
as you can see there are lots of
interesting things you can do with the
keyframes
all of the things that i am showing you
today are just like how this works
to really get a great understanding of
how it works you just have to open an
editor and start experimenting on it
okay so now let's go back to our code
and learn about animation property
so here we have the animation name my
frames
the animation name should be as same as
keyframes name to work it properly
the animation duration specifies for how
long we want our animation to last in
this case 2 seconds
let's just change this to say
10 seconds
just save the file
now as you can see the animation is
going at a slower speed just to cover
the 10 seconds of that
let's just reset it to 2 seconds
the timing function used to mention the
transition there are some keywords such
as easy and linear easy now and some
more the animation delay is interesting
to understand it means how long we are
going to wait once the animation is
triggered before the visual starts
happening
let's change it to 3 seconds
as you can see the animation starts
after the 3 seconds
iteration count specifies how many times
the animation should happen here we have
set it to infinite
which means animation will keep on going
let's change it to something say 5.
as you can see after the count of five
the animation stops
we'll set it back to infinite
animation running state can be paused at
the running state
in this video we are going to break down
everything there is to know about the
css animation css animations make it
possible to animate transitions from one
css style configuration to another
animations consist of two components a
style describing the css animation and a
set of keyframes that indicates the
start and end states of the animation
style as well as possible intermediate
now to understand this better i have an
example so let's get started now
so we are on our sublime text editor now
to get started i have a very basic
example with html and css
i have a parent element here
and inside this parent element i have a
div class child
so when you go back to the page it will
look something like this
this pink color is the parent element
and the small box with the red color is
a child element
whenever you hover over the element the
child elements move from left side to
the right side of the parent
we want to talk about animation
in case there are two different ways to
animate one is the css transition
property which works well with only
simple animation
if you want to learn about css
translation property you can refer to
the last video on css translation
there is a full-fledged animation
property which is used for more complex
animation
i am going to show you how you can make
this simple transition into animation
for this example we'll make this child
element move all around the box using
animation
so let's go back to our code
so just like the translation property we
have the several properties in the css
animation as well this consists of like
timing function fill-in mode and several
other functions in the css animation
so to convert the transition into
animation all we need to do is write the
word animation and you write the
animation where you want it to happen
in our case here is our hover so we
write the animation here and as you
write you will notice that you have more
properties in animation than transition
in general you will write everything in
this animation keyword because it is
easier
you can write it separately as well like
animation delay duration animation name
but
we will use the shorthand property of
the animation
so we'll select the animation
and the first thing that the animation
needs is the animation name
so we will give some name to this
animation
say
example
this is just like transition we can
specify our duration
in our case we will use one second
so we have given the
name of the animation
will give the duration we can define our
timing function which will be ease out
this is all the code we need for our
animation
this line is same as writing this
individually
like animation name
[Music]
animation duration one second
and animation timing function
which will be ease out
or let's say easing
so for the better understanding let's
just remove the shorthand property and
use it individual properties
now just save the file
let's understand briefly what each of
these properties do
the animation duration property defines
how long time an animation should take
to complete if the animation duration
property is not specified no animation
will occur because the default value is
0 second
the animation timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
animation
now comes the keyframes keyframes are
used to define the animation name
we come down here and write at the right
keyframes
followed by the name of the animation
the keyframes has to be put outside any
selector
keyframes essentially determine what our
animation looks like between the values
0 and 100
so at our animation we want to have this
translate
so
we'll write 100
and we'll write
transform
translate x
percent and save the file
now when you save and go back to the
page
you will notice the smooth transition of
the animation
when you hover over
one thing you will notice that as soon
as the animation is over the box goes
back to the original place
the reason for this is all the process
happens inside this keyframe
this one
as soon as the animation is done the
default state kicks in
if we want this to stop in the transform
state like box should be here is on the
right side
we have to specify it in the animation
property we will set the animation fill
mode to forwards so here
we'll set the animation field mode to
forwards
just save
and then when you go back to the
page and refresh
you see the box stops on the right side
and doesn't go back to the original
state
now that you have a basic understanding
of the animation and its different
properties let's work around our main
aim to move this child element all over
the parent element from this to this
side to this side to the side so here at
the keyframes we just delete this
and we'll start with zero percent
so here at the zero percent
we'll set the transform and translate x
to
zero
after that added 33
we want
this box to move down so we'll work on
translate y
so
we'll translate the y two hundred
percent
at sixty six percent
we want both the x axis and y axis to
to move from here to this side
so
we'll set
translate x to hundred percent
and translate
y 200
and finally at hundred percent
we want to translate x
back to 100
on the upward side
so when you save and refresh
you'll see we have achieved our target
the child elements move all over inside
the parent element
to watch it little bit more slowly let's
change the time here to 3 seconds
when you go back and refresh
you can see the box move little bit
slower
so
with the animation property we can go a
step further we can tell our animation
how many times to repeat the order of
the animation
among other things
so the animation iteration count
property specifies the number of times
an animation should be played
let's set it to three
so here
we'll set the animation iteration ground
to three
the animation direction property defines
whether an animation should be played
forwards backwards or in alternate
cycles
so
for the animation direction we set it to
alternate
now if you save and go back
that's one
two
and three after the three count the
animation will stop and you must have
noticed that the box were moving on the
alternate rounds
let's go back to see it again
this is the first cycle now it moves out
on the other direction
and now on the other direction
so this is for animation you can see
animation property is as
same as the translation property with
some more functions and sub properties
you can add more complex animations to
the page with the help of this animation
property
the css translation property is the
simplest way to add the animation to our
website
and in this video we are going to see
how to use it
so animation is a good way to catch
attention on the page and if done
properly it increases the user
experience
the most basic way to animate something
is by transition
according to the mdn definition
transition enables you to define the
transition between two states of an
element
basically when the state of an element
changes such as hover focus or anything
else we can change the css property
through a transition
there are handful of transition property
let's discuss what they are and how they
work
so
we are on our port pen
i have a box that changes the color on
the hover
the first property that we are going to
start is with the transition duration
property
the transition division property
specifies how many seconds or
milliseconds a transition effect takes
to complete
so here i can write transition duration
and i can write here a number
take note that here
we can enter time in milliseconds or
seconds i will suggest you to use the
millisecond since javascript does not
accept time in second so i will enter
here 500 milliseconds
now
when you go here and hover over this box
you will see the color changes from pink
to green in about 500 milliseconds
let's
change this to say two seconds
and see the difference
now if you hover this box
you see it takes two seconds to change
the color from pink to green
[Music]
the next one we are going to look is a
transition property the transition
property sets the css properties to
which a transition effect should be
applied
suppose we want to rotate this box when
hovered over
so first we'll specify the transform
property here and will set it to rotate
45 degrees
now here we will specify the transition
property and set it to transform
now if you hover over this box you'll
see it takes about 500 milliseconds for
the box to return to 45 degrees while
the color changes instantly
suppose we set it here to two seconds
and save
now you'll notice the box will take to
about 2 seconds to rotate to 45 degrees
while the color will change instantly
you can see the difference here
now the next property is transition
timing function
the transition timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
transition effect
the default value is ease
ease means it specifies the transition
effect with a slot start and then fast
and then end slowly
suppose here
we set the transition
timing function
to eve
there are four major values for this
timing function they are ease linear
ease in and ease out
let's see one by one in detail
so
the linear function specify the
transition effect with the same speed
from start to end
so if we change here to linear
you will see that it rotates with the
same speed from start to end
now if we change this to ease in
the ease it specifies the transition
effect with a slow start so now if you
hover over this
you will see the box rotate the slow
start
and then increases the speed at the end
the ease out specify the transition
effect with a slow end
so if you set it to ease out
you'll see at the end the speed
decreases
the last property we are going to
discuss is the transition delay the
transition delay property specifies when
the transition effect will start
the transition delay value is defined in
milliseconds or in seconds
let's set the transition
delay to 2 seconds
and just remove this
now if you hover over this box you will
see it will take two seconds to rotate
the box to 45 degrees
so you can see after the two seconds the
transition property takes place
now if we change here
to background
you see the box will rotate instantly
while the color will changes from pin to
green after two seconds
so
this is a transition property is it as
simple as it can be
in this video you will learn how to add
interactive hover effects to your
element
we will do an example where we will
create hover effects to our buttons
so in this tutorial we will discuss what
is the css hover effect and then we will
do an example to understand it better
so what is the css over effect
a css hover effect is a style technique
where the user interacts with an element
with a pointing device but it does not
necessarily activates it
it is triggered when the user hovers
over an element with a pointing device
now let's jump to an example
in this example we will create the hover
effect which will look something like
this we have different hover effects for
all the buttons
so let's get started and see how you can
make this all by yourself
so we are on the sublime text later
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will write our html
and css code respectively
start by linking the css file with the
html file
now we'll add four anchor tags we will
specify the class name for each of them
so that we can style them separately
later
put all the anchor tag inside the div
tag and name the class
middle
we'll name the class btn btn1 btn btn2
btm btmc and btn btn4
just copy paste it four times
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page right now
as you can see we have the port text on
our page
with this we are done with our html part
now let's shift to css and design the
text and add the hover effects
so in css we'll start by setting the
margin and padding to zero we'll also
add the background body color
as you can see the margin and padding is
now zero and we have a good background
color
now we will design the buttons and give
them proper formatting we will start
with the class middle
set the position to absolute
the top property affects the vertical
position of a positioned element the
left property affects the horizontal
transform property applies a 2d or 3d
transformation to an element this
property allows you to rotate scale and
move the elements
as you can see the elements are now in
place
now let's format the buttons
set the position to relative
display block
we'll keep the color as white
font size 25 pixels
we will use the font family as
montefrett
keep the text decoration to none
we will set the border to 2 pixel and
solid
we keep the text transformation repeat
we'll keep the text transformation as
upper case
transition allows you to change the
property values smoothly over the given
duration
the before selector is used to insert
something before the content of each
selected element
keep the position to absolute
we'll keep the transition as all 0.6
second and eve
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
now as you can see all the elements are
in place with proper background and text
we have the padding and border properly
formatted and now we can add the hover
effects to this button
now we will add the hover effects to the
first button
as you can see we have the hover effect
on our first button ready
in a similar manner we can add the
effects to the second and third button
as well
we'll just copy and paste this above
code below and make changes to this code
we'll set the width to 100 here
height to zero
we'll change it to height hundred
percent
just save the file and
refresh the page
as you can see both the buttons have the
hover effects now
now it's time to add the hover effect to
our third button
i will add the hover effect to the
button third
just save the file and go to the page
as you can see all the three buttons are
ready
now it's time to add the hover effect to
the fourth button
we will set the color to hash ff
this will change the text color to red
when we hover over the fourth button
set the position to absolute
keep the weight as 200 percent
we'll set the background to hash dcd159
we'll keep the z index as -1
keep the transition to 0.8 seconds
set the height to 180
percent of the page
now to add the hover effect
write the following code
just save the file
refresh
you can see we have all the hover
effects on our 4 button
as you know css animations is a powerful
concept that is used to make your
webpage engaging and attracting visitors
to your website
they make the user experience smooth and
entertaining
so in this video
we are going to learn how to create some
cool css effects using just html and css
so without further wasting any time
let's jump to our sublime text editor so
we are on our sublime text editor
for our example purpose i have used one
image from an unsplash.com and we have
created a simple class div class
container for it
now let's go and style these images to
get a 3d effect so first let's design
the body part
we'll set the margin and padding to 0
pixels
we set the width to 100 percent
and will set the height to 100 vertical
heights
we'll keep the display as flex
and will align the items in the center
and we'll justify the content in the
center as well
now we'll design our container class
so for the container class we'll set the
position to relative
we'll set the width to 360 pixels
and we'll keep the height to 640 pixels
we'll set the margin top
to 150 pixels
and we'll keep the
background to white
we'll use the rgba format
we'll use the transform property to
apply a 2d or 3d transformation to an
element
so
we'll use that transform and we'll
use it its properties will keep this to
degrees
we'll set this q to
say 25 degrees
and we'll scale it to 0.8
let's discuss more about these
properties
so
the translate property defines a 2d or
3d translation the scale defines the 2d
or 3d scale transformation
and this q property is used to skew
transformation along the x or y axis
now let's design the images
we'll keep the position to absolute
we'll set the width to 100
and we'll keep the transition time
to 0.5 seconds
let's go back to our page and see how it
looks up to this point
so as you can see we have the images
aligned as we want
on a flat side
now we'll create the 3d transformation
when we hover over it
so let's go back to our css file
so for the 3d effect we are going to use
the edge child property
the end style selector allows you to
take a single argument that describes
the pattern for the matching element
indices in a list of siblings
we'll design the each image separately
so for the fourth image
we'll use the transform property and
we'll translate it to 160 pixels and
minus 160 pixels
let's copy this code
four times
okay we have to set the opacity as well
so we'll set the opacity here
to
1.
the opacity property sets the
transparency of the element
just change the number of the nth child
elements so here we'll keep it to 120
pixels
minus 120 pixel will set the opacity
to 0.8
for the second element let's keep the
translate to 80 pixels
minus 80 pixels and we'll set the
opacity
to say 0.6
and for the last image
we'll translate it to 40 pixels
and minus 40 pixels and we'll keep the
opacity
to say 0.4
so now when you save the file and you
will go back to the page
let's see how it looks
so if you refresh and hover over it
now you can see the image has a 3d over
effect over it
there are four layers to the image and
we have
designed the opacity according to the
image layer
so this is a 3d image hover
the next property we are going to
discuss is a 3d perspective image
so for this let's use a new set of
images
so we will go back to the unsplash.com
again
and let's select one image
this one looks beautiful
so let's copy the image address
and mention it
under the image tag
just save
[Music]
now when you go back to the page
you'll see you have your image here
now let's add the 3d perspective image
design over it
so under our css file let's first design
all the elements
let's keep the margin and padding to
zero
let's keep the
width of the container elements 200
pixels
or say 100
let's keep the minimum height
to save 100 vertical heights
and we'll use a background color of hash
let's design the image as well before
going back to the page
so we'll set the perspective to save
4000 pixels
the perspective property is used to
determine the distance between the z
plane and the user in order to give a 3d
positioned element some perspective
let's keep the width of the image 70
percent
we keep the position to absolute
keep the left margin to 50 percent
and drop to 50 as well
we will use the transform property
and use that translate value of it to
minus 50 n plus 50 percent
we use the transform style property and
set the value to preserve 3d
the preset 3d indicates that the
children of the element should be
positioned in the 3d space
so just save the file and let's go back
to the page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see we have the required
background image and we have the image
in a required position
now it's time to style our image
so use the transform property
and will rotate
will use the rotate x property of it
we'll keep it to 70 degrees
let's discuss this property translate 3d
the translate 3d css function
repositions an element in the 3d splits
it results in the transform function
data type
the transformation is characterized by a
three-dimensional vector it coordinates
how much the element moves in each
direction
let's set the box shadow
to minus 80 pixels
60 pixels
15 pixels
itself an rgba value to
zero comma zero comma zero
point four let's say
let's set the transition to all point
four seconds
and we'll set the transform style to
preserve 3d
so just save the file and let's go back
to our page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see the image is flat for
and ready for 3d effect
now let's design this 3d hover effect on
it
so for the 3d over effect
we'll use the
cover property image
colon hoover
over the image
we will set the transform
rotate x
0 degrees
rotate flat
to 0 degrees
and translate 3d to
zero pixels comma
zero pixel comma zero pixels
let's check this once again
this is right
now we'll set the box shadow to
zero pixels zero pixels zero pixels
zero pixels and rgba
zero comma zero comma zero comma zero
just save the file
and refresh
now when you hover over it you will see
that the perspective of the image
changes
so this is a 3d perspective image
now
there are many css effects that you can
design using these properties
in this video you will learn what is
navigation bar and its importance on a
web page
you will also learn how to create a
basic navbar using html and css
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
we will start with what is navigation
bar and why navigation bar is required
in a web page
you will look at some of the well
designed navigation bars on websites
after that you will work on the code to
create the basic navigation bar using
html and css
so let us begin by discussing what is
navigation bar
a navigation bar is a graphical user
interface intended to aid the user in
accessing the information
it is usually placed at the top of the
page a navigation bar needs standard
html as the base
navigation bar can be created either
vertically or horizontally
so what makes a navigation bar so
important
a navigation bar is an important element
of website design since it allows user
to quickly visit any sections within the
website
if you have ever visited a website
without a navigation bar you may have
found it difficult to locate the page
you need
you may have also had to click back
several times in order to find a link to
the next section you wanted to visit
thankfully web design has become more
standardized in the recent years and
nearly every websites now include a
navigation bar keep in mind that you
want to keep people on your site to
explore further a well-designed
navigation bar is an important part of
the user experience now let us look at
an example of a navigation bar on our
website we are on the homepage of amazon
website as you can see this is the
navigation bar that has several elements
on it
as the user clicks on these elements
they will be directed to the different
sections of the website the navigation
bar allows the user to easily move
through any section of the website
by clicking on the best sellers button
you will be redirected to the best
sellers page on the amazon
now we are going to create a navigation
bar with html in css that's going to
look like this
we'll have the following sections with
sub menus and some of them
make sure you have a text editor to
write the code
i will be using a sublime text later for
this purpose we will create two new
files index.html and style.css where we
will be writing our html and css code
respectively
let's start by adding the standard
boilerplate
keep the title as css navbar
link your
css file with the html file by using the
link tag and htf attribute
this navigation bar is going to consist
of a bunch of ul tags which means and
another list and list items
let's create our first another list and
this will be our main menu of the
navigation bar
i have options such as home about
contact services and news so this is
going to be our main menu
save the file let's see what it looks
like right now by opening it inside our
browser
you can see it is just an unordered list
with no menu at this point let's go
ahead and add our sub menus home will
not have any submenus but the about list
item is going to have a sub menu
add another ui tag inside the ally tag
this will create a sub menu inside the
about item save the file
just copy paste it and paste it inside
the ul tag
name them as team
clients
careers and legacy
just make the indentation properly
if you see this in a browser you'll see
that we'll have
the sub menus inside the above let's do
the same thing for contacts just copy
paste this whole section and place them
inside the contacts list rename them
according to your wish and save the file
if you go back to the browser
you will see that we'll have the sub
menus inside the contacts as well
as you can see this is our complete sub
menus without the styling all the html
content is ready now we are going to
write the css for it in the css file
let's apply the background image first
because it will make the page look a
little bit nicer
i have my file on my computer make sure
the image file is in the same folder as
your html and css file i am using
attack.jpg
and for the background size i will set
it to the cover which is going to adjust
it to the image screen and it's going to
cover the whole background of our web
browser
keep the font family as arial
let's see what it looked like at this
stage you can see we have a background
image and the font is changed to arial
now let's make sure our unordered list
does not have any margins or padding by
setting it to zero
also put the list style to them because
we don't want to have any kind of
bullets under our listing
now another list list items they are the
main items that are going to apply the
style to the list items of the main ul
tag
float that all the text to the left
and set the given formatting
we will set the background color with
the hash value 003542
you can choose your own value from our
website known as colorpicker.com
we will fix the line height to 40 pixels
this will center the text vertically
text align to center
this will align the text horizontally
and font size to 20 pixel
font size 20 pixels
let's see what it looks like now you can
see the text is floated to the left
now let's tell the actual menu link so
the menu link will be uli a
uli a
keep the text decoration
to none and color white
keep the display as block now it's time
to set the hover effect of our array the
url hover will set the formatting when
the user hovers over the menu
we will use the background color of the
hash value de1 fcb
save the file and let's see what our
page looks like up to this point
you can see we have the hover effect
over our menus and we have the sub menus
under the main menu we want our set menu
should be visible only when we hover our
menus so we'll set the uli to display
none and we'll set the hover effect to
the block
let's save the file and see what our
page looks like up to this point
now you can see
our navigation bar is ready
with all the sub menus and menus at
proper places we have this nice hover
effect over the menus
in this video we will discuss some cool
tricks that every web developer should
be familiar with and which will help you
during the time of your designing of a
web page so let's jump onto the sublime
text editor and see these tricks so
the first trick is called the css blend
mode the css background blend property
sets the blend mode for each background
layer and you can blend it with image or
with different colors with the help of
this property we can blend background
image or blend them with colors
so
here's an example of the css
blend mode here you can see the images
are blended with different colors
so let's see how we can achieve this
so for our example purpose i am going to
use this image
to our page
so in the body tag add the image url
and the location of a file
keep the margin left and margin right to
auto
now let's add some style to our body tag
in the blend mode there are several
modes such as normal multiply darker
lighter or screen
let's blend that image with
one color
so you can select the color from the
html color codes
i use this color for my purpose
so just copy paste here
and in the background blend mode let's
keep it to lighten
now if you save
and then refresh here
you can see we have blended our image
with color
let's go back and change here something
different
let's keep it to darken
let's try something different
let's keep it to screen
so as you can see there are several
properties for this blend mode and you
can use according to your needs the next
trick is called clipping the css
clipboard property creates a clipping
region that specifies the region that
should be shown on the page
so let's understand this with the help
of an example
here we'll create a div
and give this class any class say tr
the easiest way to generate the clip
value is to use a generator
there are several websites that give the
value of the clip
so we'll use this
website to generate a clip value
suppose we want a hexagon shaped
image on our page
so here you can
adjust it according to your needs
the any shape that you want
here you can see the clip value just
copy paste it from here
now here we will use that class that we
are specified
we'll just copy paste the clip value
here
we'll keep the height to say
fifty percent or let's say sixty percent
set the width to sixty percent as well
select the color you want to give to a
clipped image
i'll use the same color from the
previous example
so just copy paste this color code
keep the position to absolute
and the z index to minus one
just save and go back to the page and
refresh
now you can see we have the clipped
image on our page let's try something
different
um let's say i want
a left arrow
so just copy paste this
clip
value clip path value
[Music]
just save the file
and you can see we have the arrow on our
page
another must have for web developers is
animations
css allows us to animate almost every
property that we use in the css
let's look at one example
so here an html file we'll just add one
div tag first
and to start with animation we'll have
to mention a keyframe the keyframes
allows us to create different steps for
our animations
we'll keep the keyframes name to blink
so here in this example we'll create a
box and we'll add different colors at
different points of animations right so
we'll write zero percent and we'll set
the background
to indigo
we'll change the colors five times so
just copy paste this code five times
we want next change at 30 so we'll set
the background here
suppose say red
at 50 we wanted yellow
at 70 we wanted green
and finally we'll change it to say blue
so inside the div tag we'll mention the
height and width of the box first let's
say 400 pixels and width also 400 pixels
now i will mention the
border of the box so just set it to say
one pixel
solid black
now for the animations part
we'll set the animation for 10 seconds
and for infinite number of times
write this webkit so as to support in a
google chrome
now just save the file and go back to
our page
and here you can see we have the
animation on our box
you can style each and every element in
html using animations
another thing you can do is add css
gradient the css gradient property
allows you to add smooth transitions
between two or more colors
for this purpose you can get the
gradient value from a website called css
gradient dot io
here in this website you can get the mix
and match of the different colors you
want to use
let's look at an example to understand
better
so here in this html file first let's
set the height
so we'll set the height to 100 percent
now inside the body tag
will keep the height as hundred percent
will mention when background color
let's select different color this time
so we will use save this color
this time
just copy paste the value here
now for the gradient value just go back
here in this website and you can select
the color you want
let's say i want a mix of this color
and
you can change the shades from here
now when you're done with the colors
just go back below and copy this
code here
to your page
now when you go back to the page you
will have a beautiful gradient here
let's try one more
this time a linear gradient
just copy this value to your code
just save the file and go back to the
page
and you will have a linear gradient here
in this video we are going to learn some
of the more advanced features that can
be used to optimize your web page and
add some extra features to it
so let's get started so the first
function we are going to discuss is css
sudo class
a css pseudo class is a keyword added to
a selector that specifies the special
state of the selected elements
sudo class lets you apply a style to an
element not only in relation to the
content of the documentary but also in
relation to external factors like
history of the navigator the status of
its content or the position of the mouse
like hover which lets you know if the
mouse is over an element or
not so the first pseudo class we are
going to discuss is css hover
this pseudo class is used to add a
special effect to an element when our
mouse pointer is over it
let's work an example to understand how
this works
so we are on our sublime text editor and
we have added a standard wall update to
it
so first i'll create a box element
we get the div class box
let's save this and see right now what
is the status of our page
so as you can see
we have this
simply learn tag and the heading that we
have given and the color changes when
you hover over me
now add a style tag to define the
styling of the box
so
we'll keep the background color of the
box as
pending
keep the width to 300 pixels and height
to 200 pixels
we'll set the margin to auto
let's keep the font size to 40 pixels so
that we can see the text
clearly
and we'll align the text to the center
just save and go back to the page
now you can see
we have this box
with the tag the color changes when you
hover over me
now to add the hover effect you just
have to mention the class
with semicolon and hover so we'll
mention the class box
with a semicolon and hover
we'll mention the background color to
which the box will change when we hover
our mouse
so we'll keep the background color to
say a cyan color
just save and go back to the page
so if you refresh and when you hover
over it you can see the color changes
so this is how the pseudo hover class
works
the next pseudo class we are going to
discuss is an active pseudo class
the active sudo class represents an
element that has been activated by the
user either by pointing a device or by a
touchscreen device let's work on an
example to understand how to use the
active class to change the color of
active elements the possible values
could be any color name in any valid
format
so we'll use the same example with some
minor changes
first
let's change this text here
we'll keep it to click here
to see the effect
we will keep this part as same
and instead of over air we will use the
active pseudo class so
we type active and we keep the
background clear to san
let's text align this h1 to the center
when you refresh and go back
so
you see here it is click here to see the
effects
now
to see the difference now you can see
when we are hovering over it the color
does not change it instead of it when we
click on it the color changes
so
this is how the active hover class works
the next advanced property we are going
to discuss is css sudo elements
a css pseudo element is a keyword
it to a selector that lets you style a
specific part of the selected element
you can use one sudo class element in a
selector
it must appear after the simple
selectors in the statement
as a rule double colon should be used
instead of a single colon this
distribution the pseudo classes from the
pseudo element so the first pseudo
element we are going to discuss is the
first letter pseudo element this pseudo
element applies tie to the first letter
of the first line of the block level
element
let's work out an example to understand
this better
just delete everything
so let's add some content to the body
and we'll add an h1n
which says welcome
to simply learn
and we'll add an h2
which says
this is an example
of
first
letter
sudo element
let's add a style tag
we
align the text in the body to the center
so we'll use text align
center
let's just give proper spacing here
now to this h1
tag we'll add the first letter sudo so
to add the first letter sudo element
just use the double column and type
first letter
we'll keep the font family of the first
letter assay lucida
calligraphy
this spelling mistake
we will keep the font size to 3
centimeters
we'll keep the color to red
and just add a text shadow
for better animation so we'll keep the
text shadow to 5 pixels
8 pixels
9 pixels and color cn
now when you save and go back
just refresh so this wc is a first
letter sudo element
as you can see we have changed this
first letter with the proper shadowing
of a cn color and a different font size
so this is how the first letters
pseudo element works
the next one we are going to discuss the
before sudo element
the before sudo element can be used to
insert some content before the content
of an element
let's work out an example
so just add the standard wallet plate
inside the body
list add
welcome to simply learn
we'll add the text inside the queue tag
the queue tag defines a short quotation
so inside the queue tag
we'll add welcome
q tag closed
now that we have the text inside the
body let's add the styling
so we'll keep the font size to of all
the
text to 30 pixels
this is the all selector we have used
font size 30 pixels
now before the text we are going to add
some symbols so we'll use double column
queue before
we add the content with sun symbol like
this
will keep the color of this
symbol to blue
and we'll use the after sudo class to
add the content
like this
we'll keep this color to red
now that we have everything in place
let's go back to see how it looks
you can see the symbols before and after
our text
so this is how the before studio element
works
so the next function we are going to
discuss is css loader
the css loader is an animation that
shows the visual about the page when it
is loading
it is helpful when a page takes some
seconds to load the page content it is
similar to the buffer sign so let's see
how to create a
loader so i hope you remember the
concept of the keyframes and animations
if you want to revise the concepts you
can watch the previous videos on the
keyframes and animations from the
playlist
so
let's create the loader
we have the standard wall upgrade so
inside the body tag
just add the center tag and inside it
will add one h1 which says
welcome to simply learn
we'll add
5 div tags with a class a1 a2 a3 a4 and
a5
just copy paste it five times
so this is a1 a2
a3 a4
and a5
let's open our style tag
inside our style tag we'll first add
color to our h1
so
let's keep the color
of our h1 to orange
now comes the div tag
so for the div tags
we'll keep the display to block
keep the position to absolute
we set the width and height to 10 pixels
each so width 10 pixels
and height 10 pixels
we'll use the cat function to determine
the left margin
so to use the calc function to add calc
and -1 em
the calc function performs a calculation
to be used as a property value
we'll keep the border radius to say 1.3
am
em is related to the font size of the
element
1.3 em means
1.3 times the size of the current font
we'll use the transform origin function
with the value 1.3 em
and two em
the transfer margin property allows you
to change the position of the
transformed elements
2d transformations can change the x and
y axis
keep the animation
to rotate
i will keep the animation iteration
count
infinite
and will keep the animation duration to
2 seconds
let's save and go back to the page to
see how it looks at this point
so as you can see we have our heading
and
you cannot see it but we have a loader
ready
and we just have to add some keyframes
and animations here
so
let's define
keyframes
the name of the animation rotate
so at zero percent
we use the transform
function to rotate it to
zero degrees
just copy copy this
at hundred percent when it's complete
it'll rotate to the complete 360 degrees
so here we give the value 63 degrees
now let's design each of the classes
here that we have defined
so
dot a1
the animation delay
will be of 0.1 seconds
so for each of the classes that we have
here we have to define them with a
different color
so that when the loader appears we can
see them clearly with the different
colors so
for this
a1 let's keep the background color to
say san
just copy paste it
so that we don't have to write down code
again and again
three
four and five
let's make changes here so for the a2
we want it
to appear after 0.2 seconds
with the color pink
let's keep this to 0.3 seconds
the color purple
color black
we kept the animation delay to so close
like 0.1 seconds point two seconds point
c seconds so that the
loader appears in a complete sync with
each other
so just save the file and refresh and go
back to the page
now you can see this is the loader we
have our heading and
this is like a buffer
and it will show when you have some
content to load
in this tutorial we are going to discuss
what is concept design and how we can
achieve this using the css media queries
so let's get started making a website
with an adaptable layout is called
responsive web design and css media quiz
are one of the most important part for
responsive design
in the past building a website was much
simpler today a website layout should
adapt itself not only to computers but
also to tablet mobile devices and even
tvs
so
let's see how we can create a responsive
web layout using css media case within
help of an example so here we are our
sublime text writer we have us our
standard wallet ready so let's create
something
so let's start by creating the four days
here
we'll give it a class name box
with an id box one
we'll name this windows
just copy it four times
let's rename this id to box to and here
we'll type mac os
uh for the box three will have
linux and the box four
will have android
let's add some styling over here
so just open the style tag
i will text align the text too we'll set
the text align to center
we'll set the background
select some color
so we'll go to this html color code
choose a good color
connect the color
we'll set the text color to white
and we'll set the font size to say
something to the pixels
and just save the file let's go back and
refresh the page
so as you refresh you see we have our
lives with windows mac os linux and
android and with this background color
so
to design the responsive web pages use
the media queries
so what are media queries let's first
discuss this so a media phrase are used
when you want to customize the website's
presentation according to the user's
screen size with the help of the media
queries you can display different
markups based on the device's general
type mobile desktop tablet you name it
a media query is a logical operation
whenever a media query becomes true then
the related css is applied to the target
element
so
to start the media query just type at
the rate
and media
now here we'll mention the max weight
to save 400 pixels
and inside this media query we write the
css code that should
take in effect when this condition is
satisfied so here
we'll set the box 1
to display block
now
if you go back to the page and you
refresh
you see nothing happens because we have
not made this display to none so first
go back to the css code
and set hit display to none
now you can see we don't have any
display here so let's inspect the page
first
so you'll see we have our contents here
now you can see this is the
layout we are currently using the
current weight is 685 pixels into height
255 pixels
now we are setting the max bit to 400
pixels this means if this bit decreases
to less than 400 pixels how this css
code will kick in so let's decrease the
width here
so as you decrease
this width
you see as soon as you get less than 400
pixels our css kicks in so we have our
windows displayed here which is
the box id1 so this is how the media
query works
let's add some more media queries to
understand it better so just copy this
code down
so now let's set this minimum width
to
401 pixels
and maximum to say 600 pixels
now when this condition is true let's
say we want our box to
to display block
with color
green so let's set the background color
here
to let's
say green
now
we will add one more media query
so just copy this code
[Music]
paste it here
so when the bit is from 601 pixels to
say
800 pixels
so we'll set the box 3 display
to block and color
to
shifting
so just save this and let's understand
it
on the page
so
let's
change the width of the screen
so see as soon as the width goes less
than 400 pixels we have our windows on
display
now when we increase the width size and
it goes more than 401 pixels we have the
mac os display keep on increasing it
now see the width is more than 600
pixels and we have linux on display so
this is how we create the responsive web
design for the different devices in this
session we bring to you all the
fundamental concepts of javascript first
let's have a look at the agenda for the
session
first we look at a simple hello world
program using javascript
then we'll understand the different
types of arrays deployed in javascript
we look at the concept of loops
objects this keyword and functions in
detail
then we learn about form validation
javascript regular expressions
and javascript email validation
then we'll move on to more advanced
topics like promises and async await
so without further delay let's begin
so what is javascript
javascript is a dynamic computer
programming language which is
lightweight and object oriented
now the best part about javascript is
the fact that it's open source and is
cross-platform compatible meaning one
piece of code written in any system
regardless of the operating system
functions the same in other operating
systems as well
lastly most commonly used as a part of
web pages that allows client-side script
to interact with the user and make
dynamic pages
now moving on to the next important
question why javascript
now being the most popular language in
the world javascript has a huge fan base
and benefits from a large community
support
javascript is now being used in many
industrial fields such as web
development mobile application
development and also game development it
is very diverse in nature
there are great career opportunities for
javascript developers as this technology
seems to be holding on its own when
compared to other languages
all right now moving on let's go ahead
and execute a simple program
to understand javascript better
so we'll go ahead and execute a simple
hello world program
all right for that first thing you need
is a text editor in this case we've used
the vf code editor
so now let's go to our
text editor that is vs code and here
let's open a file you say
file
and now you can uh type in your code
here so we will have to add the
javascript to the html code and then
print out the words hello world on the
browser window right that's our
objective so let's add the html
boilerplate in this file
so let's type in
html
this is our tag
and then next we have the body type
so within the body tag
we can add the script tag to insert the
javascript into html page right so we
say script
language
equals javascript
and type
equals
text
slash
javascript
all right
let's close the tag
and then
in the script we call a javascript
function that is document.write which
writes the string to our html page
right so we say document
dot write
and within braces we say hello world
okay and now we close the tags
you also close the body
and finally the statement
all right
now when we save the file
we're going to save it say on my desktop
and i'm going to call it index dot html
right so make sure the extension is html
and then save it
and that
exists
i say replace it
and now once you save it as an html file
you can see that the colors have
appeared so any errors will be easily
indicated here
so now let me see this and now let's go
ahead and execute the file that is
stored
so let me go back
to my desktop
and here i have index.html
there you go when you click on the file
it opens in your browser
and you can see the words hello world
in this we will be learning all about
javascript arrays and the popular
methods of the array object
so what's in it for you we'll start by
understanding what a javascript array is
then we will get to know about the
operations that we are performing on the
array
after that we'll get familiar with some
of the most used array methods
and lastly we'll go through map reduce
and filter functions
so what exactly is an array
now an array object lets you store
multiple values in a single variable
it stores a fixed size sequential
collection of elements of the same type
now an array is used to store a
collection of data and it uses only
integers as element indices
however associative areas can also use
string indices
moving on let's understand what array
operations are
now we can perform various operations on
an array in javascript
but let's start by creating an array
so for that let's go ahead and create a
folder first which will consist of the
file that we're creating right so for
that
let me just
go ahead and create a folder
and i'll call it demo underscore adding
so once you're done with that open your
visual studio code editor
and here say open folder
and click on demo array
okay it's creating the workbench all
right and now here you can see the new
file icon so go ahead
and create
demo.html file
all right here you go now let's start
typing the code
the first thing we do is type in our
html tag
and here i have the head tag
[Music]
and let me say javascript
tutorial
all right and now let's create the body
tag
now within the body tag i create a
paragraph tag
and create an id
and let me call it
demo
and then close the tag now i'll explain
to you why we're doing this a little
later
so first let's go ahead and create the
script tag
so say script
and within the script let's create our
array so let me use the keyword let
and say we give the name of the array
cars
equals in square base braces
we say bmw
and
volvo
[Music]
and then say
honda
all right so now we create an array now
one more thing is that we use the
keyword let so that which indicates that
the array can be changed throughout the
program
all right so now we go ahead and display
it so
i say document
[Music]
dot get element by id
and here i say now the id
created was demo so i say demo here
and i use the dot
inner html property
which is equal to cars
okay let me change this to bmw first
all right so what exactly in our html
does is that it is responsible for what
is being displayed on the web page
okay now since we've taken id as demo
any changes made is reflected in this id
and then displayed onto the web browser
all right so let's save this and now
execute the file
so here i go back to my folder and then
to the file and go ahead and click on it
so there you go
the heading is displayed and the entire
area is displayed here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
okay so i hope this was easy to
understand
now let's go ahead
so the next operation is to access an
array element
so let's go back to our vs code
and here
let's create another variable say let
bmw bmw is a variable don't get confused
with the array element
so bmw equals
cars
of the index 0.
so basically
cars of 0 is nothing but
bmw all right so that is being saved in
the variable bmw
and now let's just go ahead and display
this
so let's just copy this
and paste it here and instead of cars
you use the variable name bmw that is
this one
all right
so now let's save this
and when we
execute it
you see bmw here
that's how you retrieve an element from
an array
next up we have the addi length property
which displays the length of the array
so again let me show you how to do that
let's go back to our code
and here
let's create a variable and let's call
it length variable so i say let l-e-n
equals
cars dot left
now you can use the length property
which will retrieve the length of the
array for us it's as simple as that
and now after this
again let's just
copy the same
code here and then
let's pass len
okay
now let's save this
and when you execute it again
it says three
so we've successfully retrieved the
length of the array
all right so the next operation is to
access the last array element right so
let's go back to our vs code
and now
let's create another variable
and let's call it last
and we'll just say last equals cars
and within square braces
cars dot length
minus one
right
so basically
the length of the array is three and
three minus one is two so it should
retrieve
cars of two which is honda right
so let's just
execute this and we pass last here
save it and see if it
displays honda for us
there you go
it's as simple as that
all right so moving on
the next array operation is loop over an
array item
so for that let's go to our
code and here
let's use the for loop so i say cars
dot
for each
and within this we'll say
item
comma index
comma array
and now we use the arrow function
and display the content on the console
so i say console.log
of item
along with its index
so let's save this
and now let's go ahead and execute it
all right now as you can see nothing is
printed on your web page right because
whatever is being printed has to be
printed in your console so now click on
f12 which opens the developer options
and here you can see console so click on
that
and now you can see the name of the item
in the array along with its index so you
see bmw 0 volvo 1 and honda 2.
all right
so moving on
now that we've learnt about the array
operations let's go ahead and learn
about the array methods
so the first method is tostring now as
the name suggests it is used to convert
an array into a string
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and now
let's copy the same
code here
and here instead of last i just say
cars dot
to string
now you can use this method
to convert the array into a string
so let's save this
and let's execute it
all right
now here the same output is shown
which means that the type has only been
changed to string type
all right moving on
the next method is pop now pop basically
removes the last element from the array
so let me show you how that works
let's go back to our vs code and here
we have to save
the pop element into a variable right so
let's create a variable say last
okay and oh since last is already used
let me call it last one
[Music]
last one of cars dot pop
now you can use the pop method to pop
the element
and now you can just
copy the same code
to display this onto our web page
and here
i just say
last one
now since we've popped the last element
the array has only two elements right
that is bmw and volvo so if you want to
display the last element it should
display volvo right so what we can do is
we can just create another variable say
last two
and just
use the same logic here
okay
and now let's just
display it on your console and let's say
last two
all right
so now let's save it
now the popped element has been saved in
last one which is displayed on the web
page
and the last element of the array after
the pop function has to be displayed on
our console
so let's go ahead and execute the file
all right so honda has been displayed
that is the element that has been
removed from the array
and now once we check our console
here you go here you can see volvo
which means that is the last element in
the array
moving on
the next method is the push method now
as the name suggests it is used to add a
new element to the array and remember to
the end of the array so let's go back to
our vs code
and here let me say cars
dot push
push is the method that we're using
inside of which we'll say
audi all right
and now let's just display the same
things so let me copy this
and here let me say
cars
okay so let me save it
and once i execute it it says bmw volvo
and audi so we've successfully added
another element to the end of the array
so the next method is the shift method
now basically shift is used to remove
the first element from the array
now this method shifts all the elements
reducing the indexes of every element by
one all right let me show you how this
works
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just say cars
dot shift
it's as simple as that
and let's just display this
let me copy the same thing
save it
and when we execute it
here you can see it just displays volvo
and audi so now cars has array elements
volvo and audi
with array indices 0 and 1.
all right so moving on the next method
is unshift
all right so to add an element into the
beginning of an array we use the unshift
method
therefore this method increases the
array index by one
right so let's go back to our vs code
and use the same function
unshift
let's say cars dot unshift
and here we go let's
save it and here we have to specify what
we're adding right let me say hyundai
okay
let's save this
and when we execute it
you can see hyundai volvo and audi
as simple as that
all right moving on the next method is
the concat method now this is basically
used to merge two different areas
right so let's go back to our vs code
and here
let's create another area first
and let's just call the array
bikes
okay
and let's create say
yamaha
and
let's say suzuki
[Music]
and then we'll say royal enfield
okay
and now
let's save this
and say let
vehicles this is another array
which is basically the after
concatenation
the entire array is saved into this
array all right so let's say cars dot
con cat
[Music]
or bikes we just concat bikes and cars
together
okay and then let's just
display this over the web page so
let me change this to vehicles
[Music]
all right
let me save this
so let's go ahead and execute it
there you go now both the areas have
been merged together into a single array
so the next array method is the sort
method
now basically sort is used to sort the
entire array into ascending order
all right so let's go back to our editor
and here
let's just use the
sort method on the
array vehicles
all right
vehicles dot sort
okay
and
let's just
display this on our web page
so
again
let's go back and
executed and here you can see it has
been sorted
the next method
is the reverse method so the reverse
method is again used to reverse the
elements in an array so it's logic right
so sort was used to sort it in ascending
order now when you reverse it it just
sorts it in the descending order
so let's go back here
i'm going to copy the same thing
all right and here instead of sort
let me just say reverse
so let's save this
and execute it
there we go
it is displayed the entire array in the
reverse order
all right
with that we finish the array methods
next up we have map reduce and filter
first up we have array.map now the map
method is used for creating a new array
from an existing one by applying a
function to each and every one of the
elements in the first array
and it does not change the original
array all right so to make you
understand this better let's go back to
our
visual studio code
and now here let's first create another
area
okay so let me call this num1
and let's have
integers let's say 2 3 4 5
6 and 7 okay
and now let's have another array
num2
so let's go ahead and say num1
dot
map
of let me define a function
say multiply
okay
so multiply the function that is that
i'm going to define here
so let's say function
multiply
of value
okay
and inside this let me say return
value
into 2
okay
so what this basically does
is that it multiplies each and every
element of the array num1 by 2 and saves
the new elements into the array num2
okay
now after this
let's go ahead and
display the content so let me copy this
and let's display the content
in the array num2
right so let me save it
let's go back here
execute it
so there you go
every element has been multiplied by 2
and then displayed again
i hope this was clear for you
now the next method is the filter method
so the filter method takes each element
in an array and applies a conditional
statement against it
and if this condition returns true the
element gets pushed onto the output
array but if it returns false the
element does not get pushed
all right so let me show it to you
now
let's
go ahead and create another
variable say
num3 and here i say num1
dot
filter
of say com
now comp is a function
let me define the function here
let me say function
comp
of value
takes a value as a parameter
within which i am going to check
if the value is greater than 4
now it only appends the element into the
array num3 if the value is greater than
all right
so now let me just
go ahead and change this to num3
all right
let's save this
and when we go back and execute
here we go now the values so let's go
back here let me check
now num1 had the values two three four
five six and seven right so according to
this it has to only display five six and
7. do not get confused with num2 here
we've passed num1 here so it checks put
this array
right
so according to the logic it should
display 5 6 and 7
and it has done so here
okay
moving on
the next method
is the reduce method
now the reduce method reduces an array
of values down to just one single value
now to get the output value it runs a
reducer function to each element of that
array
okay now this method does not reduce the
original array again
so let's go back to our vs code
now let me create
another
variables in num4
and say num1 dot reduce
and let me call it sum so what we're
basically doing is that we're adding all
the digits 2 3 4 5 6 and 7 in num1 to a
single value right that is the sum and
then we're going to be displaying that
so what we're going to do is let's
define the function here
function sum
basically is total comma value
right
and then here let's say return
total plus
the value
okay
and after this
i'm going to
display the content so let's say
num 4
okay
let's
save it
go back and execute
here we go it displays the sum of the
entire values in the array we're
learning all about javascript loops
if you're new to javascript i suggest
you go through our previous videos on
this topic
so without further ado let's begin and
look at what's in store for you
so we're going to be covering topics
like for loop
while loop which also includes the do
while loop and then we're going to learn
about breaking out of a loop and then
we'll see how to skip a loop cycle
now before jumping into the for loop
let's first understand what exactly a
loop is
right so a loop is basically a
programming construct that executes a
piece of code as long as a certain
condition is met
all right and there are two different
types of loops we have entry control
loops and exit control loops
now what exactly are entry control loops
now these are the loops where the test
condition is checked before executing
the piece of code
for example you have the for loop and
the while loop so in their case before
entering the loop
the condition is checked and only if the
condition is met it enters the loop and
executes the code
all right when it comes to exit control
loops the test condition is checked
after the loop has been executed
all right so in this case the loop at
least gets executed i mean the code in
the loop gets executed at least once
so the example for this is the two while
loop
all right with this basic knowledge
let's go ahead and learn about the
different loops
so the first loop is the for loop
all right
so what exactly is a for loop
this is the basic logic and the
flowchart in front of you so what
exactly happens is that say for example
you want to print the word looping
say 10 times right so what you can do is
you can start and you can have a for
loop which goes from 0 to 9
and then you increase the number by 1
every time you print the loop
once it's equal to 10 or even greater
than 10 it ends the loop
right
so let me help you understand this
better with an example so let's go to
our editor that is vs code
here i've created a folder called demo
underscore loops within which i created
a file called for loops all right
so now let's just write down our initial
code for html that is
html
and then i have a head tag
[Music]
within which i say javascript
loops
all right
now i have a body tag
[Music]
within which i give a heading for
clearer understanding let me have a
heading say
javascript
[Music]
for loops
all right
let me just call it for loop
now let's have the script tag
[Music]
within which
i'll have
a variable say
x and now we have the for loop so we say
for
x equals
x less than
x plus plus
within which i say console.log
of x
so basically
what happens is
now you have the first variable which is
called the counter variable now this
keeps track of how many times the code
is being executed
right and next
i less than 5 is the condition now
the loop keeps executing as long as the
condition is met
and lastly the counter variable is
incremented and usually it's incremented
by one
right so here we've done the same thing
and
inside the loop we print the value of x
all right so let me save the file
and then execute it
all right it's printed javascript loops
here let me just go back
okay my bad i missed out on the title
tag
so this has to be enclosed within the
title tag
so let me just
change it here
now let's save this
let's go back and just refresh the page
and that is it so whatever is in the
title tag basically appears here all
right so now since we're printing the
value of x on our console we have to
inspect our element so let's go here
and here let's check on console
and here you can see all the values have
been printed from 0 to 4.
all right now this is a simple for loop
so next up is a while loop
now the logic is similar to that of a
for loop
first the condition is checked and if
the condition holds true then the code
is executed and if it is false it
terminates
all right so moving on let's understand
the general syntax
so here first you have the variable
whose value keeps changing
and then you have the ending condition
which is basically the maximum value a
variable can reach all right so let's go
back to our vs code
and here for better understanding let me
just change this to
javascript while loop
all right let's just
delete this and here
let's initialize the value of x to 1
and now i say while
x
less than or equal to 5
within braces i
say console.log
of x
and then i increment the value of x
all right so let me save this
and let's execute the file
all right so it says javascript while
loop and let's inspect
and here in our console it displays
the values of x
all right so according to the
logic x is initially initialized to 1
and the value
gets executed once it enters the while
loop
all right it's incremented and then
checked every time
until the value reaches
six right and then it breaks from the
loop since the value does not hold true
and then it terminates
so this is a logic behind the while loop
next up is the two while loop
now here
as you can see
first the code is executed and then the
condition is checked if the condition is
true then the code execution continues
and if it falls it's terminated
all right so this is an exit control
loop
also in an exit control loop
the code is executed at least once
so let's go back to our vs code
and
here let me just delete this
now let's initialize x to say
15 all right
and now i use the do keyword
within which i write the code
so first i am going to print the value
of x
console
dot log of x
and then i increase my value
and here i mentioned my test condition
which is while
x
less than say 10
all right so according to the logic
initially the value is x
and once it enters the loop
here
it should print the value of x which is
15 all right and then it increments the
value but once it comes out of the loop
it checks for the condition
here the condition says less than 10 but
since x is not less than 10 it prints
the value x that is 15 and then
terminates
all right so let's save this
and execute it
so let me execute this
and here
let's check
the console
so there we go it prints 15. so what it
does is that it prints the value 15
first and then checks the condition
now
let's go ahead and change the value of x
to say
all right
so now it enters a loop
and then it prints the value of x and
then increments it
and when it comes out of the loop and
checks the condition
as long as the value of x remains less
than 10 it prints it
okay
so let's save this
go back here
and let's refresh the page
and here you can see the values five to
nine are printed
so this is how the do while loop works
moving on to the next concept
breaking out of a loop
now as the name suggests break is the
keyword that is used to break out of a
loop
now here is a simple code for you
so according to the logic it prints the
values
between 1 to 10
and say at the value 5 you want to break
out of the loop you can simply use the
keyword break
so let's go back to our vs
code and here
let me just
make it simple
unsaved
or
x equals 1
x less than or equal to 10
[Music]
let's increment it
and within the loop let's
display the value x
on the console and then
we're going to check for the condition
if x equals 5
all right
so if x equals 5
we break out of the loop
so let's save the file and execute it
and there you go it's displayed the
values from 1 to 5.
so basically the code inside the for
loop is executed and once the value of x
reaches 5 it breaks from the loop
simple right
all right so let's move on
next up we have skipping a loop cycle
all right so here
what exactly we do is we make use of a
keyword continue to skip a particular
loop cycle
say in this case we have a for loop
which displays the values of i
ranging from 1 to 10 however we want to
skip the cycle when it reaches the value
3. so what we do is we make use of the
keyword continue here so basically it
displays 1 and 2 and skips the third
cycle and then directly displays four
all right so let me show you in our
vs code editor
here
let me just remove this and save
if
x equals
[Music]
i'm going to continue
all right
after which
i'm going to say console.log
of x
so let me save this
and then execute it
so here
let me refresh the page
and there we go
as you can see it displays one two three
and four and the fifth cycle
is kept
all right and the rest of the digits are
displayed so that is how you can skip a
loop
i highly suggest you also practice all
of this and then play around with loops
to get a better understanding
so taking a step forward we're going to
learn about javascript objects so
without further ado let's begin and look
at what's in store for us
first we'll start by understanding what
a javascript object is
then we learn how to create a javascript
object and also get to know about the
properties of these objects
after that we'll get familiar with using
javascript methods lastly we'll
understand what javascript accessors
are so what is a javascript object
javascript is an object-oriented
programming language so everything in
java is an object
a javascript object is like a real-world
entity having state and behavior for
example a car
now we can take a car as an object it
will have its state like color and model
it will also have behaviors like
accelerate and break
javascript is template based and we can
create objects without having the need
to create a class
generally object is accompanied by a
class that defines an object's
blueprints but javascript doesn't
require any class to be defined for
objects
moving on to the next concept
to create a javascript object
now basically there are three different
ways of creating a javascript object all
right so we look at them one by one
the first one is to use a literal to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go to our vs code editor
now if you have any doubts regarding the
initial setup then i suggest you go
through the previous video that is
javascript arrays
to get you started with it so here i've
created a folder called
demo objects
and now i'm going to create a file
called
create
underscore objects
dot html
all right
so we'll begin by writing the initial
code
that is the head and the body so i say
html
[Music]
but in this i
create the head tag
[Music]
and then i create a title tag
and let's say
javascript
objects
then after the head tag i'm going to
create a body tag
and
let's create a heading and say
creating javascript
objects
okay
and now we create
an id
all of this is explained in the previous
video i really suggest you go through
the video before hand so that you get a
clear picture
and then i say id equals
say demo
and then i'm going to close it
now the first method that we're going to
use to create an object is by using
object literals
right so what we can do is say script
within which i declare a variable
say
where student
now within the object we're going to
create three different properties now
this is basically like a dictionary it
has a property a key and then a value
okay so i say name
property
and let's say
chris
and then another property say age and
say 21
and another property say
studies
and say maybe computer science
[Music]
okay
so this is the syntax used to
create an object using an object
literally
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to display this right now we
want to display the message saying chris
of age 21 studies computer science so
what we can do is say document dot get
element by id
and the id that we're going to pass is
demo
and we say
in
html
equals
student dot name
which is chris
after which we display the message
of the age
and then the age that is student dot age
studies
student
dot
studies
okay let's save this
and when we
execute the file it says chris of the
age 21 studies computer science
all right this is one of the ways in
which you can define an object
all right so moving on to the next way
of creating a javascript object it is to
use the new keyword now this is the most
traditional way of creating an object
right so let's go back to our vs code
let's create another script
within which we say
where student
equals new
object
i'm sure everybody has learned the same
way the same syntax
so this is one of the ways
after which we can say student top name
equals
chris
again student dot age
equals 21
and then
student dot
studies
equals computer science
[Music]
all right
now after this we again
display the message so let me just copy
this
[Music]
all right
so let's save this
and run our code again
and there we go it displays the message
chris of the age 21 studies computer
science
all right this was the second method
used to create an object
all right so then moving on to the third
method
it is to use an object constructor to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go back to our code editor
and here
[Music]
we define a function
so we say function
say start
with three parameters
that is name
age
and say
studies
okay
and now
within the function we use the keyword
this
so we say this dot name
equals name
all right
we say this dot h
equals h
we say this top
studies equals studies
now what we do is that we can
create a variable and pass parameters to
the function so we say that
student
equals stud
and within braces we say
chris
comma 21
comma computer science
[Music]
all right so we've done passing the
parameters
after this
we're going to copy the same
print message
here
[Music]
all right so let's
save this and execute our file
so let's refresh the web page
and there we go it still displays the
message chris of the age 21 studies
computer science so this was the third
method that can be used to create
objects
moving on to the next topic
object properties now a javascript
object is basically a collection of
unordered properties right
values associated with the javascript
object are called its properties
and properties can usually be added
updated or deleted excluding read-only
properties
so now let's have a look at the demo to
help you understand this better
so let me go back to my
vs code so this is where we left off and
this is how we created objects right
so now let me create another file
and let me call it
objects underscore properties
html
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to copy the first piece of code
here
all right let me just copy this
into my
new file
and here as you can see student is the
object that we've created and name agent
studies are the three properties
now say we want to update the age all
right so what we can do is here we can
just say student
dot h
equals
let me change it to 24 all right
and let me save this
and when we execute the file that was
object underscore properties
you can see chris of the age 24 so 21 is
updated to 24
so this is one of the ways you can do it
or there's another method
you can just assign the property to a
variable and then display the variable
instead so what we can do
is we can just assign student.h
to a property say x
and here instead of displaying
dot age
we can just say
x
all right so let's save this
and when we run it
it says 21 because we haven't updated
21 to 24 anywhere all right
so 21 remains the same
so another method we can use
is we can just say
x equals h
so we're directly assigning the property
to the variable
and here
when i'm displaying it i say student
of x
all right
so let me
save this
and when you look at the web page
it still displays the same thing these
are different ways of accessing the
properties you can update them delete
them unless they're read only
all right so let's move on to the next
concept object methods
now basically a javascript method is an
action that can be performed on the
objects
so you'll understand better with the
help of the demo
so let's go back to rbs code and here
i've created another html file called
objects underscore methods all right so
let's let me just copy the initial
code
paste it here and let's have the
enclosing tags as well
[Music]
and html all right
now here i declare another tag that is
the button tag so we're going to be
making this a button here so i say
button
[Music]
id equals click me so that is the action
that i'm going to
be performing
and the message that is going to be
displayed on the button will be
click
all right
so we're going to see the usage of it a
little later
now let's go ahead and create an object
so i say script
[Music]
within which i create
the user object
so we created using a object little here
and i declare the property name
as chris again
and age
say 24
okay
so let's close this
all right so the next thing i'm going to
do is i'm going to create a new function
that we will use as an object method
all right so i say function
and let's give the name say hi
okay
within the function we declare
we basically display a message
so we're going to see alert
and hello
all right so this is going to be
displayed in a separate dialog box
so now once the declaration is done
what we're going to do
is we're going to use
create another property basically say
user dot
let's say message
and assign
say hi to
it so basically what we're doing
is we're adding the previously created
method
to a new property that is user dot
message the message property
all right
so now i say
document
dot get element by id
[Music]
and say demo
and the message that i want is just
hi
plus the username
all right
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to display the message hello
all right when the user clicks on the
button
so for that let's say
let's just copy this
[Music]
and here
instead of demo
right we're going to be passing the id
click me
as per this
and the event is going to be on click
event
so here i say on click
after which
i'm going to simply pass
user dot
message
let me just delete this
[Music]
all right
so here i notice that i've given an
equal to sign i'm sorry it's a colon
all right
so let's save the file and
let's go ahead and execute it
all right so here you can see hi chris
being displayed and once we click on the
button
you can see
an alert which says hello
all right
so now let's move on to the next concept
that is java object accessors
now getters and setters allow defining
an object accessor all right to get the
value of a property in a javascript
object we use a getter and to set the
value of a property of a javascript
object we use a setup
so let's go back to our demo
and now let me create another file
and let's call it
object
accessors
and now again let me just
copy the first initial part
[Music]
all right so now
let's go ahead and create a new
object so let me say script
within which i say where
and let's call it car
all right
so let me define the properties say
model
and
the model is say bmw
320d
and
another property is a color
and let's say it's navy blue
and the last property say fuel type
[Music]
and let's say it's
diesel
[Music]
now what we can do is we can you make
use of the keyword get
to access the properties so i say get
and say fuel
within which i return
this dot
fuel
type
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's display it
document dot
get element by id
[Music]
demo
dot inner html equals we say car
dot fuel
all right so now let's save it
and execute our file
here you go it retrieves diesel for us
now this is one of the ways of accessing
the properties
now to help you understand setter
let's go ahead and create another
object all right say where car again
now let's say the model
is
audi a4
[Music]
color be bright
red
[Music]
and if you will type
let's keep it blank
all right
now to set the value we use the set
keyword we say set fuel
the parameter is fuel
within which we say this
dot fuel type
[Music]
equals fuel
right
now let's set the value for the fuel
say car dot
fuel
equals
petrol
all right
now let's display the same
let me copy this
and what we want to display is the fuel
type right so here we say fuel type
so let's save this
and let's go ahead and
execute the file
and there we go it retrieves petrol
so what it does is basically it assigns
the value petrol to the property fuel
type and then we display the same on our
web page
so this is how you make use of getters
and setters
we're going to be learning all about
javascript this keyword
so without further delay let's jump
right in
so you must have heard about this
keyword several times
so in javascript this keyword basically
refers to an object which is executing
the current piece of code well in simple
terms this keyword basically just
references the object that is executing
the current function
now if the function that is being
referenced is a regular function
then this keyword references the global
object
all right i'm sure it must be a little
tricky at the moment but please hold on
and if the function that is being
referenced is a method in an object
then this keyword references the object
itself
so to help you understand the concept
better and to clarify all your doubts
let's look at a simple demo
so here in vs code i've created a file
called this.html
all right you can give it a name of your
choice
now here let me first
define a variable
and let's call the variable
say
value
and let's set it to say 50.
all right
now let's go ahead and create a simple
function
so let me say function
[Music]
my function
all right and within this
let me define the value for value
let me set the value for
the variable value as hundred
okay
and now let me just alert it all right
so let me say alert
value
[Music]
okay plus value
and then let me have another alert
message
which is going to display this dot value
so let me just say this value
[Music]
and
instead of just saying value i say this
dot value
all right
now after this let's go ahead and call
the function
my function
so let me just save this and execute it
so here it says value equals hundred
and then when you see this dot value it
says 50.
so now here you can come back to the
code and see
now when i just say value it takes the
value 100 all right which is taken
locally but when i say this dot value
since it is a normal function its
references to the global variable which
is here
this value
i hope this makes sense to you now
now moving on let's look at the behavior
of this keyword within an object method
so let me create an object here
but before that let me just
comment this out
let's say script
and now let's create an object so
let's say const
and then i give the name of my object as
random
and within this let me say name
and
let's call it
john
and then i create a method called info
okay and within this i display a console
message
that says hi
my name is
and now i make use of this keyword i say
this
dot name
all right
and now let me just go ahead and call
this method
so i say random
dot info
all right so let's save this and execute
it
so let me check my console
and there you go it says hi my name is
john
so if you clearly observe here
when we say this dot name since it is
being used within a method that is
defined inside an object
its references to this
property here
all right unlike this case where it
reference to the global variable that
was mentioned outside
so i hope this helped you understand the
difference between the two
now let's look at another simple example
so now let me just change the value of
name here
to say tutorial
and now let's define another property
which is basically an array so let me
just call the property video
within which i have an add a let's say
javascript
[Music]
another value
say this
and then let's say keyword
and in my info method i'm going to just
display these video tags so
let me just
say this
okay let me just delete this first
and let's say this
dot video
now since it's an array we can make use
of for each
and now for each intern takes a callback
function
and then i say
i'm going to call it
a tag
the parameter that's being passed within
which i just console log it
and say
tag
all right so let me save it
and then execute this
now here you can see that the values in
the video property are displayed that is
javascript this and keyword
now let's suppose
that you want to display the name along
with every
string here
right so
naturally you would go ahead and just
say
this dot
name
right it makes perfect sense
so let me just
save and execute this now if you see
just the values of the property video
are displayed here
now the main reason for this is
if you closely observe that this
function here is mentioned within the
callback function
right so when it is referencing it is
referencing to the global object
which is unclear which is undefined in
this case so to overcome this what we
can do is that
the for each method takes in two
properties one is the function the other
one is the object
so here we just pass this
all right so what happens is it's going
to reference the current object that is
random so let me save this and then
execute it
and there you go
you can see that tutorial that is the
name has been displayed
all right i hope you understood the
concept of this keyword it could be a
little tricky but as you work on it
you'll get the hang of it
we're going to learn all about
javascript functions in our previous
videos we've covered topics like
javascript arrays and loops
if you're new to this topic i suggest
you go through these topics before
all right so before jumping in let's go
ahead and look at what's in store for us
first we're going to learn what exactly
javascript functions are
then we'll look at javascript function
expressions then the function
constructor
self-invoking functions functions as
values functions as objects arrow
functions generator function and the
predefined functions
also don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to our first topic
what are javascript functions
so basically a function is a group of
reusable code which can be called from
anywhere in your program right
when you have a piece of code that you
want to execute repeatedly in your
entire program
it makes more sense to define it once
and call it over and over right it makes
the code more efficient and readable
this also helps programmers write
modular codes
so this is the syntax you make use of
the function keyword followed by which
you mentioned the name of the function
the name of the function is completely
your choice
next you mentioned the parameter list
and within curly braces you can define
the function now the function body is
basically the code that is executed
every time the function is called so
let's go to our vs code editor
and here i've created a folder called
demo functions within which i've created
an html file called functions.html
all right and now i've just typed in the
initial code
now let's create a function
so let me say script
within which i use the keyword that is
function keyword
and now i give
the name for my function i say my
underscore
function
and the function takes
a parameter say value now this function
basically returns the square of the
digit all right
so within which
i say
document dot get element by id
the id is demo
and now it just displays value into
value
all right so the function basically
displays the square of the number
now outside the function let me call the
function
does
my function
let me pass the value 5
all right now let's save this
and execute it
so let me go back to my file
and here we go it displays the value 25
so this was a simple function which took
a value
a digit as a parameter and then returned
the square
moving on to the next concept function
expression
now what we learnt previously was
function declaration
but a function can also be defined as an
expression
now this is what the syntax looks like
now here the function is created and
assigned to the variable explicitly like
any other value
the meaning remains the same that is you
create the function and store the value
that it returns into a variable and in
our case it's x right so let's go to our
vs code and let me help you understand
this better
so now
i create another function
[Music]
and here i say
let
x equals let's use a simpler function so
i just mentioned
function
and within curly braces i display an
alert message
and i display a message saying hello
all right
now
after that to display the message what
we can do is let me just copy this
output
code
and replace it here
and here what we're going to be
displaying is the value x right now
since it consists of a function you'll
have to type the curly braces now this
is crucial for its execution all right
so let me save this
and then execute
let me execute this
and here you go it says the site says
hello so we've successfully executed the
piece of code
we can also assign this variable x to
another variable and then call that
variable instead
right we can say let
y equals x
and instead of calling x here
we can simply call y
let me save it and then let me refresh
the page and there we go it still
displays the message hello
all right so this is one of the ways of
defining a function that is as an
expression
moving on to our next concept function
constructor
now javascript functions are defined
using the keyword function right now
functions can also be defined using a
javascript built-in function
now this is the basic syntax so here
we've created a function called my
function and we've used the keyword new
after which we've used the constructor
function
and inside we provide the parameter list
after that the return value
next you can call the function here
right so let me just go back to my vs
code
and now
let me just make changes to the same
piece of code here
i create a function say
my underscore function
okay
all right let me just change the name
to my function all right
and then here i use the keyword new
and the function constructor that is
function
[Music]
within which i'm passing all the
parameters
so i have
a
b
and i'm going to return
the sum of the digits
all right
and now while calling the function
let me just store the value in a
variable say x
and let's call the function that is my
function
with the parameters
2 and 3.
all right
and now let me
display it so i'm just
going to copy this
and i want to display the value of x
right
all right so let me save this
and execute it
if you refresh the page it displays the
sum that is 5.
to make it more readable let me just
display another message here
let me just say
the sum is
x all right
let me save it and then refresh the page
it says the sum is 5.
all right now this is how you make use
of the function constructor
next up we learn about self-invoking
functions
now as the name suggests these functions
are invoked automatically without being
called
now previously when we learnt about
function expressions we saw that
parentheses were crucial
so you have to add parentheses around
the function to indicate that it is a
function expression
so here is a syntax value so what we've
done is we've made sure we've enclosed
the entire function within parentheses
so let me help you with that let's go
back to our vs code
and let me create another script
[Music]
and here
let me create the function within the
parentheses
and say function
it's not taking any parameters
instead it is going to
alert a message so let me say
hello
welcome
all right
after which
we're going to call the function so
again we have to mention the parentheses
let's save this
and execute
so when we
refresh the page
it says hello welcome
so we never called the function
rather it got invoked by itself so these
are self-invoking functions
now let's go ahead and look at functions
as values
now in javascript a function is
basically a value so we can deal with it
as a value now here is a simple syntax
now if you closely look at the syntax
you might think that this is same as
function expressions well no in this
case what we do is we first define the
function and then we assign it to a
particular variable but in the case of
expressions the function definition was
defined during the initialization of the
variable right and also we have to
specify the parenthesis in order to call
the function
so to help you understand this better
let me go back to our vs code
and here
let me just erase this
let's define a function
that returns the product of two digits
so let me just call it product
[Music]
which takes two parameters let me say a
and b
within which we return the value
a into b
all right now after this let's create
another variable say y
equals
function oh i'm sorry the name of the
function is product
so product
of 2 and 5
all right so this basically returns us
10 right so let me just
copy this to display this on our web
page
and here i change the message to the
product
and here let me change it to y
so let's save this and execute it
so let me refresh the page and here you
go you can see the message the product
is 10.
now what we can do is we can make
alterations to this
now say i want to multiply the value
with 5 again
right so basically this returns 10 and
that value is multiplied by 5. so let me
save this
and
refresh our page and there we go it
returns
and there we go it displays 50. so this
is how you can make use of functions as
values
moving on to the next topic functions as
objects
now javascript functions are a special
type of objects called function objects
now a function includes a string which
holds the actual code that is the
function body of the function
the code is literally just a string
although not recommended you can also
create a function with the help of the
function constructor
i will show that you a little later on
but for now let's look at the syntax
now here we have a variable called body
which basically consists of the function
body it's enclosed in double quotes
that's a mistake please ignore it all
right so next we have variable function
name here we create a function using the
keyword new and then we pass the
parameter list
and the body basically tells us what the
function returns
all right
next we have an alert message to call
the function
so let me just show how this is executed
back in our vs code let me create
another
function and let's say the function
returns the area of a circle right so
let me just create
a body variable
which returns
so the area of a circle is pi r square
so we make use of math
dot pi
into radius
right
so it's basically pi r square
after which
let's see
where circle
[Music]
and here let's create a function using
the new keyword
function
and then here we pass
the value that is the radius
and then the body
right so basically
this is the definition of our function
so let's use alert
to display the area so we say alert of
circle
of five
all right let me save this
and execute it
so when you refresh the page
it displays the area of the circle
so this is how you can use functions as
objects
moving on to our next concept arrow
functions
now functions can be written more
compactly and more precisely with the
help of arrow functions all right now
arrow function expressions are
ill-suited as methods and they cannot be
used as constructors
now also while using arrow functions
using const is a safer option because a
function expression is always a constant
value
so this is the syntax now you can only
omit the return keyword
within the curly braces if the function
is a single statement
so this is the syntax first you provide
the name of the function
with an equal to sign followed by the
argument list
and later you make use of this arrow
icon
and define the expression
so this is basically nothing but this
so let's go back to our vs code and
check for ourselves
so let's create another function
and here let me say
const
my funk
equals
now say we want to display the product
of three digits so let me just pass a b
c of my parameters
and we make use of this icon which
indicates that this is an arrow function
within which i say return
a
into b into c
all right
now let me just
assign this to a variable
okay let me say
product
because we've used x here
and then let me call my function that is
my func
and pass the value 2 3 and say 4.
all right so let's display
the product so let me just copy this
code
and here let me say the product
of the three
digits is
and let me say product here because that
is what is being used here right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
all right first it displays the area of
the circle
all right and then we say okay
and there we go it displays the message
the product of the three digits is 24.
so let me do one thing let me just
comment this out
okay
let me save it and then execute it again
it just displays this
alright so this is how we can make use
of arrow functions
moving on let's look at the generator
function
now regular functions typically return
only one value right or a single value
or sometimes even nothing but a
generator function can return multiple
values
and the speciality is that it can do it
so on demand all right now to create a
generator function we make use of an
asterisk
so an asterisk indicates that the
function is a generator function
so here you can see that we have a
function followed by asterisks and we
created a function called generator
sequence
so here you can see we have the asterisk
after the keyword function followed by
the name of the function right
but the main method of a generator
function is the next method when this
method is called it basically runs the
execution until the nearest yield value
all right or the nearest yield statement
then the function execution pauses and
the yielded value is returned to the
outer code
all right so the result of the next
method is always an object with two
properties it has a value property which
is basically the yielded value
and then it has a done property which
displays true if the function code is
finished or false if it's otherwise
so let me show it execution for a
clearer understanding so let's go back
to our vs code
and here let's create the generator
function
let's say function
asterisk
generate
function all right
now within which
i make use of the keyword yield
and i say yield one first
followed by yield
two
and finally i make use of return which
indicates the termination so i say
return 3
all right
now let me make use of
a variable say generator
and assign it to the generator function
that is generate
func
and now i create another variable say 1
which will basically
return the value when i call the next
function so here i say generator
dot
next
okay
so whatever generator dot next returns
it's stored in one
so to display the message i say alert
and now i'm going to make use of a
method called json.stringify
[Music]
all right so basically this method
converts a javascript object or a value
to a json string
all right so within which i'm going to
say
that is this
all right
so now let me save this
and execute it
let me refresh the page and there you go
here it returns
two properties that is value and done it
says value is one and done is false
right it is false because we haven't
reached the return statement yet
so what we can do is to display the rest
let me just copy these
and display it one by one
so there let's see this
and here let me say 2
and this is 3
let me copy this
[Music]
okay here i say
and then i say 3.
all right so let me save this and then
execute it
so when i refresh the page
it says one and false
after which again it says two and false
and finally when it displays three it
returns true for the done property that
means we've reached the end of the
function definition
so this is how you make use of a
generator function
now let's move on to our last topic that
is predefined functions
now javascript has many built-in
functions all right now here are a few
of them we have eval parse end pass
float escape and unescape now let's go
through one by one
all right first up is eval now this
basically evaluates a string and returns
a value
all right so to help you understand this
better let me go back to our vs code
and now let me just create another file
and let me call it
predefined
functions dot html all right
and i've just copied the initial code
all right so for eval
the syntax is eval
within which
i say
expression
all right now this is the general syntax
so what this eval does is that it
evaluates the expression
and if the result is not a string the
result is just returned and if the
result is a string it is taken to be a
javascript program and evaluated
so let me show you how it's done
so first let's create three variables
all right let's call them
x
and initialize it to five
then y
with six
and then let z
be b7 all right
now let's just displace the result on
the console so let's say console.log
eval
or let me say x plus y
all right
after which i again say console.log
of eval
of z
here since the expression is a string
this gets evaluated
and here since it's not a string it just
returns the value z
and here since it is not a string it
just returns the value of z
so let me save this
and then execute it
all right so let me just
check
our console
there you go it evaluated the expression
and added the two values that is x and y
and returned 11. while z is returned as
it is
all right this is what eval does
next up is parse int now as the name
suggests it parses a string argument and
returns an integer of the specified
radix or base
and the syntax basically includes the
keyword parse
and the string within paranthesis
parse float on the other hand passes a
string argument and returns a floating
point number again the syntax has the
keyword parse float along with the
string within parenthesis
next up is escape now this returns a
hexadecimal encoding of an argument
and on the other hand unescape returns
the ascii string for the specified value
we're going to learn all about
javascript form validation
so what exactly is form validation
now i'm sure you must have filled
several online forms right a simple
example would be a new registration for
a website
now every time you miss out on giving a
particular detail or end up giving
faulty information the website alerts
you
so this process of ensuring that the
information provided is legit is called
form validation
now this generally happens on the server
side however javascript facilitates form
validation on the client computer before
sending it over to the server
now there are two functions performed
one is the basic validation which
ensures that all the mandatory fields
are filled now this is implemented with
the help of a simple loop
and the other is a data format
validation now this checks the data for
its correctness
so to help you understand form
validation better let's look at a simple
demo
all right so back in my visual studio
code i've created a file called forms
all right it's an html file and i've
typed down the initial code
now the simple use case that i'm going
to show will include the validation of
the email and the password fields in a
form
all right so for that let's go ahead and
first create a simple form
so here html allows the form tag so i
say form
within which i'm going to provide
our fields so i say input
and then the name i'm going to be
providing is email
[Music]
all right and then i'll provide a
placeholder and call it
email
and then the type of the input is going
to be text
all right
and then let me just give a break tag
here
so now let me just copy the same thing
for my password as well
so here we go i say
password here
and then the placeholder again will be
password
and then i'm going to keep the type as
text
and finally i'm going to have a button a
submit button right so let me say button
type
is basically submit
all right
and let me just play submit on my button
okay
so with the help of this we've created a
simple
form so let me show you how this looks
so here we go we have successfully
created an email field a password field
and a submit button and every time i
click on the submit button you can see
that my page is getting refreshed
now once the user provides the correct
email id and password we want to display
a message all right so for that i've
created another file called message.html
and this is a simple file where i'm
displaying the message hello there
welcome
all right
so this is a simple message that i want
to display
so for that i have to
add it in my form tag
now once the form gets submitted
an action has to be performed and the
action is to navigate to the
message.html file right so let me just
say action
[Music]
equals
message.html
now you can also provide a name to your
form so let me call it
[Music]
my form
all right
so let me just save this
all right so moving on we have to now
validate the information that is
provided for that i'm going to create a
function here
so let me call the function
validate
all right
so here i'm going to check for my fields
right
now if the email field is empty then i'm
going to alert the user saying please
enter the email
and if the password field is empty i'm
going to again alert the user to provide
the password
so for that we're going to make use of
this simple if else logic
so let me say if
document
dot my form
[Music]
dot email
dot value
is null
so i'm going to check if the value
provided on my email field in my form
is null all right
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
alert
please
provide
your
email id
okay
and then
i'm going to say
document.myform.email.focus
now what exactly focus does
is that it makes sure that the cursor
remains at the email field that is it is
focused at the same field
all right
so let me just copy the same thing for
my password field
so let me say else if
let me just copy this
instead of email
i say password
within which i'm going to alert the user
to provide the password
[Music]
i'll say please provide
your password
all right
so basically it first checks for the
email field and then for the password
field so let me just say finally else
do nothing
all right
okay so now what we're going to do is
every time we click on the submit button
the form gets submitted correct now we
can control when the form is getting
submitted
so basically the form gets submitted
when this function is executed
so for that we can use another property
here
called on submit
and here i'm going to call my function
that is validate so let me say validate
here
all right so let me save this and let's
check the output
so here as you can see
let me just try submitting it without
providing the email field
all right so here we go it alerts us all
right and once i click on ok
it still displays the message hello
there welcome now that is not what we
want right
so once the email field is empty it
should remain in the same page
and the form shouldn't get submitted but
here in our case it is getting submitted
so for that we're going to have to make
use of return values
so what happens is if my email field is
empty then i'm going to return a false
so here i say return false
and here as well
and finally when both my email and my
password fields are filled i'm going to
return true
all right
and same goes here
let me just say return validate instead
of just validate
right
so
here we go
let me save this
and now let's check the output
so here let's first submit the form
without providing any information
all right so it says please provide your
email id when i click on ok observe that
the cursor remains at the email field so
here let me just give some random value
and then let's try submitting it again
without providing the password
and then it says please provide your
password
all right
okay now if you observe that the cursor
is remains at the email field so let me
just check my code once
here we go i haven't mentioned password
here
so let me change email to password
so let me just provide some random value
at my email field
and say submit
and then i get a message saying please
provide your password
and now you can see that the cursor is
at the password field right so let me
just give random information there
and then i say submit
and here we go
the message hello there welcome is
displayed
so this was a simple demo on form
validation
so i really suggest you pause the video
here and then go through the code once
we're going to learn all about
javascript regular expressions
so now without further delay let's begin
so what exactly are regular expressions
now a regular expression is basically a
sequence of characters now these
characters could be digits or the
letters of the alphabet and this
expression usually searches for a
particular pattern
now the user can basically define what
has to be searched in a text all right
and these expressions could be alphabet
or digits as i explained before
also one of the main reasons that we use
regular expressions is for text search
and text replacement operations
so this is a general syntax you have a
pattern that needs to be checked and you
have a flag associated with it so
further on in the video i'll explain to
you what flags and patterns are but
before that let me give you a small
example of what a regular expression is
so i have made use of this website
called
regexar.com i'll link it down in the
description box below
so this is the website
now here let me just show you a simple
regular expression now say we have a
text that says
apple
all right and now we have to search for
the letter a so what i do here now this
is going to be my expression so i first
provide a pattern right so i just say
capital a
so when i say capital a you can see that
the letter a has been matched
in my text all right so it's as simple
as that now one thing to remember is
that here it is case sensitive
all right so if i say
a regular small a it does not get
matched
all right so if i want to match ap i can
just say ap and it gets highlighted here
all right so this is a simple regular
expression that matches with the text
so moving on
let's see what exactly these flags
patterns and quantifiers are
so what exactly is a flag so we
previously saw that the syntax consists
of a pattern and then a flag right so
these flags basically specify to alter
the behavior of a regular expression now
these flags are generally appended after
the red x literal and can be specified
as a second argument in your expression
right so let's see the different flags
that are supported by javascript
now you have these five flags here you
have g which is the global flag now this
finds all matches instead of stopping
after the first
all right then you have i which is
ignore case which makes the entire
expression case insensitive and then you
have m which is multi-line
so the carrot and the dollar match the
beginning and the end of each line
respectively
then you have unicode and if this flag
is not supported you must match specific
unicode characters and then finally you
have y which finds all the consecutive
or adjacent matches
so moving on we have
patterns now these patterns are
basically brackets and are used to find
the range of characters
now again we have these patterns you
have a to z which finds all the
characters from a to z in lower cases
only then we have 0 to 9 which finds all
the digits between 0 to 9 and finally we
have the letters of the alphabet and the
digits separated by a pipe all right so
this basically finds any character be it
an alphabet or a digit
i hope this was clear to you so moving
on we have quantifiers now these
quantifiers define the number of
occurrences of a particular string
now consider n to be a string so we have
three quantifiers here we have the plus
we have the asterisk and we have the
question mark so plus indicates one or
more occurrence of the character n
all right and the asterisk indicates
zero or more occurrences of the
character end while a question mark
indicates zero or one occurrence of the
character n so now that you know flags
patterns and quantifiers let me help you
understand them better with the help of
a demo
alright so here i have a simple text
which says welcome to this tutorial on
javascript this video teaches regular
expressions
now here
when i search for a particular word say
let me search for the word this okay
so i say this
now ideally even this has to be
highlighted
right however it does not that is
because as mentioned earlier it is
extremely case sensitive right so what
we can do is here we have flags
so here i say case insensitive so once i
click on that both these words get
highlighted
all right so this was how you make use
of the i flag
now moving on let me help you understand
patterns
now as mentioned you can have a range of
characters
now just in case here
[Music]
say i just make it case sensitive again
and here
i would like to select all the letters
of the alphabet
from a to z
all right so when i do that you can
observe all the letters are highlighted
except the ones that are in the upper
case
correct
because that is not mentioned here so
here when i make it insensitive you can
see all of them get highlighted
so this is how you can make use of a
pattern
now to understand quantifiers
let me use a separate text all right
let's have a couple of a's and a few b's
now here when i say a
you can see all the characters a are
being highlighted
right which is correct
but when i use the asterisk
symbol here what happens is you can
observe
all the four a's are considered to be a
single unit what aztecs does is that you
can see here it says match is 0 or more
of the preceding token now the preceding
token is a
and matches 0 or more occurrences of the
character a
now same if i say b next to it
you can see all the characters b are
matched
right
however you can check
the characters a in this particular text
are not highlighted
i'm sure you can understand why because
the expression that i'm looking for is
any occurrences of a
followed by the character b
in this text here there are no
characters a and b together
correct so here you can see that a is
not highlighted
but once i give an asterisk again
what happens is that the character a
gets highlighted
what happens is that b can have zero or
more occurrences so here there is a zero
occurrence of b so a gets highlighted so
this is how
dash does quantifier works
now one of the most important concepts
of using regular expressions
are the special characters
so here you're gonna indicate the
special characters with the backslash
so we have backslash w for example
now what w does is that it matches any
word character
right so all the characters here get
matched
now it also has a counter character
which is the capital w all right so what
this does is that it does not match any
word so it matches everything that is
not a word including the periods
now let's see if you want to match
all the white spaces you can make use of
the character
s here
all right and when you have the
uppercase s
it matches any character that is not a
white space
now let's say you want to match
a digit you can just have
backslash d
so let me just type in a few digits
and here you go all of them get matched
now let's say you want to have a range
of values that get matched right now
let's say i want to match just
three digits
so i can make use of curly braces and
within which i can mention three now
here you can see that it matches three
of the preceding token correct so the
preceding token is basically a digit so
it groups them in threes
so let me just add two other digits and
there we go
same goes with the matching of words so
here let me say w
so when i say three
all of the characters are grouped in
threes all right
now let's say i want to group the words
that are three or four in number so here
i can just say
comma four
all right now it gets matched
all right so now it gets grouped in
force
so this is a simple example to show you
how special characters work in a regular
expression
moving on let's see how you can use
regular expressions to search for phone
numbers
now here in my phone number
i'm going to have an area code
so let's say
080 followed by a neat digit number all
right so let me give a random number
all right so it's 8 digits so some
people write a phone number like this
while others could write it something
like this you could have a hyphen in
between and then
an eight digit number
all right now how are you going to look
for this text
so what we're going to do is we're going
to make use of the special character
that is for a digit
we'll make use of hyphen d
and first we're going to look for
the area code that is a three digit
number right so let me just say
three here
and next we're going to have an optional
hyphen so for that now since we learnt a
pattern can be enclosed within square
brackets so let me just
say hyphen here
and let me say a question mark now a
question mark indicates zero or one
occurrence of the preceding character
right so we're going to have a hyphen
for a question mark
and then finally we're going to have a
digit again
and here the number of digits is 8. so
let me just specify that all right so
when this happens you can see both my
numbers are getting highlighted
although the text remains the same it
could be specified with different
formats right so just like this you can
create expressions that match various
formats so this was just a simple video
to acquaint you with regular expressions
we're going to be learning all about
javascript email validation let's begin
so first of all validation is an
essential part when you're communicating
with the user almost all the websites
and applications that you use have forms
that you need to fill in and every time
you fill a form that information you
provide needs to be validated so this is
an essential and a crucial part now when
you're providing more critical
information like user credentials say
your id your password your date of birth
all of that needs to be validated so
javascript enables this with the help of
a feature called email validation
now email validation first of all
ensures user authenticity
it also facilitates email validation on
the client side so that all the
processing that takes place on the
server side is faster
and lastly with javascript one can
validate a name password email date etc
now i'm sure everybody has used email
ids right so here's a dummy email id for
you one thing that you must have noticed
is that all ids come with an ad symbol
now the first part before the act
character is the personal data
now here it could include your name you
can provide digits etc so the length of
this personal information can be up to
64 degrees and following the at
character you have the domain name the
domain name can be up to 253 characters
talking about the personal data
now this data can include any sort of
information you can provide your name
your birth date etc so basically it can
consist of all uppercase and lowercase
letters of the alphabet
it can have digits from zero to nine
you can include all special characters
and lastly it could include the period
character one thing to remember is that
the period character cannot occur twice
and is not supposed to be either the
first or the last character
all right so this was just a brief
introduction to email validation now to
give you a better understanding let's go
ahead and look at a simple demo
so back in our visual studio code i've
created a folder called javascript demo
and i've also created a file called
email validation
i've also typed in the initial code also
if you haven't watched our videos on
javascript regular expressions and
javascript form validation then i highly
recommend you go through them
email validation is basically just a
combination of the two so i suggest you
first head back and watch those videos
and come back here all right so the
first thing that we need to do is create
a form that includes the email field
right so for that let's go ahead and
create our form
here i'd say
form
within which i give input
let the id be
text
and i'll give the placeholder property
and let it be email
and the type
text
all right
and then i will
break the line
and finally i have a button
that's basically the submit button right
so let me just say button
type
say button
and then
the message displayed is submit
all right
so now when you're validating a form you
will have to
provide certain cases that is the if
else conditions
to validate it correct now first i'm
going to create a function wherein i'm
going to pass the information typed in
by the user as an argument and this
function consists of a regular
expression against which the id provided
by the user is checked and if the
pattern matches it then the id is valid
and if it does not then you'll have to
alert the user so now let's create our
function
let's say
script
and now let me
create a function
called validate
all right
[Music]
and now i'm going to create a variable
called mail
and i'm going to get
the information provided by using this
id
from the input now i'm going to get the
text using this id correct so let me
just say document dot
get element by id
within which
the name of the id is text
let me say text dot value all right
so the next thing is to create a regular
expression
now consider two different ids here now
the domain of the first id ends with dot
com
while the next one is ending with dot co
dot n
so when we're defining the regular
expression we'll consider all possible
scenarios so now let's head back to our
vs code
and here let me just say
variable reg x
beginning with a forward slash
and then
you have
a carrot now the carriage symbol
indicates the beginning of the regular
expression
now since we can have the lowercases
uppercases and all the digits
let's go ahead and mention them so
here
let me say a to
z
all lowercases then we have uppercase
and we have all digits
[Music]
0 to 9
followed by which we can also include a
period and an underscore so when you're
including a period symbol you will have
to use the escape character that is
backslash and then you mention the
period now one thing to remember is that
a period symbol in regular expression
means that it can include any of the
characters
but here since we're using the literal
character that is the period we have to
include backslash after that we can
all right
followed by which we have a quantifier
that is plus
now plus here indicates one or more
occurrences of all these characters
so here we include plus
after which we have a literal that is
the act symbol
followed by which we have the domain
name so again the domain name can
include all the letters of the alphabet
and the digits
so for that let me say
a to z
a to z and zero to nine
again to remember we have to include the
plus symbol
indicating that it
let me just get rid of this
so we include the plus symbol to
indicate
one or more occurrences of of these
characters
again followed by which we have a period
symbol
so for that let's just go and type in
period now you must be wondering why i
didn't use the backslash
now a backslash or an escape sequence
here can only be used within the squared
braces outside of it it is considered as
a literal
so here i just mentioned the period
again i highly recommend you go through
the javascript regular expressions video
to clarify all your doubts
so moving on
after this i have to mention
the extension that is dot com or dot co
dot in
now generally these extensions are in
lower cases so for that let's just
go ahead and mention a to z
again followed by a plus that is a
quantifier
with an optional
again
followed by
the letters a to z
again these can
again i mentioned plus
followed by which i'm going to add the
question mark
now the question mark indicates zero or
one occurrence of the preceding
expression so in this case
this
extension that is dot in
is optional now the question mark here
indicates either a zero occurrence or
one occurrence
all right
so
uh to end the expression you have
the dollar symbol and then
the front slash
oh i might have missed something
okay yeah i haven't closed this so let
me just add the parentheses all right
so this is your regular expression
against which we're going to be checking
the email id right
so now
we're going to use the simple if else
logic
so for that let's say if
reg x
dot
text
dot mail
mail is basically what has been
passed by the user
all right now if this is true
that is if the mail when checked against
the regular expression comes in to be
true
then i'm going to alert the user
saying
you have
[Music]
provided
um
a valid email id
and i'm going to return
true
else
if the expression does not match
then i'm going to alert the user with a
message
saying sorry
incorrect
email id
and i'm going to return a false
so now you must be wondering where is
the return value going so for that i
have to add the on click event on my
button
so here let me say on
click
it's going to call the validate function
all right so there we go
let me save this
and execute it
in my browser when i type in xyz
gmail.com
and when i click on submit
it alerts me saying
you have provided a valid email id so to
check the other condition as well let's
type in dot co dot in and submit
and again it says that we've provided a
valid email id
now
let's just add
a period and an underscore as well
so if i say x
y z
dot
a
underscore bc at gmail dot co dot n
and when i submit it it again says it's
a valid email id
for a false case let's go ahead and
remove the add symbol
and submit it it says
sorry incorrect email id
or you can also go ahead and remove the
period here
and i submit it
it still says that the id is valid now
here what happens is that gmail co is
taken as one domain name with an
extension dot in so here this is valid
so this was a simple video to explain
email validation
i encourage you to play around with
regular expressions and also uh
consider all possible scenarios while
you're validating your id in a previous
few topics we learned about areas
functions and loops however this time
we're going to take a step forward and
then learn about promises
now you must be wondering why javascript
promises even came into picture and what
exactly these promises are
so don't worry i've got your back in
today's video we're going to learn about
promises why they were introduced and
also i'll explain their functionality
so let's go ahead
first up why javascript promises
now javascript is predominantly single
threaded meaning
all processes contain the execution of
instructions in a single sequence
so basically in simple terms one command
is processed at a time now if a function
relies on the result of another function
it basically has to wait for the other
function to finish and return and until
then the current function remains idle
now this can be extremely frustrating
because it's time consuming and very
restrictive i mean you're not using the
system to its full capability so to
overcome these drawbacks asynchronous
concepts or asynchronous programming
came into picture
so in this case the main thread
continues its execution while javascript
allows long network requests and other
tasks to happen simultaneously
now with the help of features like call
backs promises and async await
asynchronous programming can be easily
achieved
i hope now you understood why promises
or asynchronous programming came into
picture
moving on what are javascript promises
now in the case of synchronous actions
you could instead of arranging for a
function to be called at some point in
the future return an object that
represents this future event
this is what the standard class promise
is for
now a promise is basically an
asynchronous action that may complete at
some point in the future
and when it's completed it produces a
value
now it is able to notify when its value
is available the easiest way to create a
promise is by calling the
promise.resolve method now this function
ensures that the value you give it is
wrapped within a promise
now a promise basically has three states
first up is the pending state now this
indicates that the underlying operation
has not yet been completed
next up is the fulfill state this
indicates that the promise has been
fulfilled with a particular value
lastly we have rejected now this
indicates that an error has occurred
during the operation and the promise is
rejected with the particular reason
moving on a promise is said to be
settled when it is either fulfilled or
rejected
because remember promises are immutable
they cannot change their state so once
they're either fulfilled or rejected
they're said to be separate
so when a promise is fulfilled it has to
do a particular job so for that we make
use of the then method now the then
method basically runs for a result and
this is used to attach a callback when
the promise has been resolved
all right same with the case of the
scenario when the promise is rejected
it makes use of a catch method which is
used to attach a callback when the
promise has been rejected
don't worry you'll understand the
concepts better when we get to the demo
so moving on let's look at a quick flow
chart to understand promises better
first up you have a new promise now the
promise is in the pending state
now this promise runs for an
asynchronous action now we check if the
action is successful if it is a yes then
we call the then method and if it is a
no then the catch method is called
and to end it if it is fulfilled then
the asynchronous action is performed and
if it is not that is if it is rejected
then error handling is performed
and lastly the values of these methods
is returned to the promise
i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the
general syntax
you can use the lead keyword and provide
a name for your variable and then you
create a new promise now this promise
object takes a function which in turn
takes two parameters that is resolve and
reject
so to help you understand all of this
better let's go ahead and look at a
simple demo
so in vs code i've created a folder
called demo promises within which i've
created an html file named promises
so i have the initial code ready here
so let's begin typing our code
so let's say script
and here as i explained we say let and
let's give the name
car
to our variable
say car and we create a new promise
all right so the promise
object returns a function
which takes two
parameters called resolve
and reject
all right
so within the function
let's define
a simple use case now let's assume that
we're checking the car for its fuel all
right so we'll create variable called
fuel
underscore full tank
now let's set the variable to say true
all right
now let's set the variable to true
now this indicates that the fuel tank is
full
so now if the fuel tank is full
what i can do is i say resolve
all right
else
i reject it
okay i hope you understood what i'm
doing here i'm just checking for the
fuel tank and if it is full which is
true then it gets resolved and if it is
false then it gets rejected
so if the promise gets resolved
the then method is called right so let
me call it here i say car dot then
now this runs a result right so it's a
callback function
within which i say document
dot right
the fuel
tank
is full
happy driving
[Music]
all right
and if it is
rejected
i say
dot catch
which also returns a function
[Music]
that says document
dot right
let's just display a simple message
saying that the fuel tank is not empty
[Music]
all right so let me save this and
execute it
so here it displays the message the fuel
tank is full happy driving
now that happens because we have set the
value to true here
now in case we change it to false
let's see what it displays
all right it displays the message the
fuel tank is not empty
so this was a simple example showing how
a promise works
now let's go ahead and understand nested
promises
so for that
let me just
comment this out
and now let's create a function that
returns promises so in our case what
we're going to do is first we'll check
for the fuel tank now in our case we're
taking a scenario where the fuel tank is
empty and the engine of the car is
overheating
so as a result the car is not safe for
traveling all right so let's go ahead
and create these functions
so i'll say let
empty underscore
tank
okay which returns
[Music]
a promise
so within which i say return
new promise
and the function takes two parameters
that is resolve
and reject
which in which i'm going to display a
message
saying
resolve
it says the car
doesn't
have enough
fuel
all right
now let me just copy the same piece of
code
to check
for the engine all right
so let me just change the name of our
variable here
let's call it engine
and here it displays the message
the engine is overheating
all right
and lastly
when both of these scenarios hold true
that is the car doesn't have enough fuel
and the engine is overheating
we say that the car is not fit for
travel
let me just call it
and here
i'll display a message
saying the car
is not safe for traveling
[Music]
all right
so
right now we've created three functions
that returns promises
so first we check for the empty tank
right so let me just call the function
here
empty tank
and we make use of the then method
which is executed when the promise gets
resolved
which takes
a callback function
all right so basically when we check for
the empty tank
after this is executed we check for the
engine right so here we simply call the
engine function so let me just say
return
[Music]
engine
all right
now this is a nested promise in itself
so on top of it i can run the then
method again
[Music]
so if
the tank is empty and if the engine is
overheating
then i'll just check if it is safe for
traveling or not
so let me say
function
[Music]
and here let me just return
the method travel
all right
now after this
if all of these are executed
then i say
function
finally i'll display a message
saying
saying done
all right
so let's save this file and execute it
so here i go and click on promises
let's go and check our console
and there we go
the message done is displayed
so here since every time the promise is
being resolved a message is displayed i
can basically catch the message in a
result
okay
and this result can be passed to the
coming methods so here i just say result
i see result again
[Music]
all right
so now we get the message the car
doesn't have enough fuel so we have to
append it with the next message so let
me just say message here
i've used msg
[Music]
and let's just append it here
and the final message gets appended here
with result
okay i have to add message here as well
all right so let's save it and execute
the file
all right so here you can see the
message done gets displayed first
and then since we're appending it after
the message done it says the car doesn't
have enough fuel the engine is
overheating the car is not safe for
travelling
so this is how you can make use of
nested promises we're going to learn
javascript asynchronous concepts that is
async and away
firstly let's understand the basic
concepts of synchronous and asynchronous
programming in case of synchronous
programming all the actions are
performed sequentially so you have the
execution of the function 1 after which
you have function 2 and then you have
function 3 and after all of these are
executed the program terminates now
although synchronous programming is
clean and has lesser errors it has its
own drawbacks the entire system is
halted when a particular process is
being executed now as a result of which
it is time consuming and the system is
not used to its full capacity
so to overcome that asynchronous
programming was introduced now in this
case let's assume that a particular
function of the process is being
executed
now let's consider that this particular
function is waiting for a resource let's
say a network resource now instead of
waiting for the function to acquire this
resource the main thread continues its
execution with function2 and function 3
and when the resource is acquired it
receives a callback indicating that the
function 1 has to be called and finally
the entire chain is terminated so this
is how asynchronous programming works it
makes sure that the system does not halt
when a particular process is waiting for
a resource this makes the entire system
very efficient
now that you know the concepts of
synchronous and asynchronous programming
let's move ahead now async and await a
purely asynchronous programming concepts
i again suggest you check out the video
on promises before watching this
alright so moving on
what are javascript async functions that
is async and await now async and await
are built on promises the function is
basically accompanied by the keyword
async
indicating that it returns a promise
within this function the away keyword is
applied to the promise that is being
returned and the await keyword ensures
that the function waits for the promise
to resolve now on the surface the
execution looks synchronous while it's
actually asynchronous
now at the place of usage of the await
keyword the execution of the function is
practically blocked now async functions
make the code more readable and are easy
to handle when compared to promises now
to give you the general syntax you have
the async keyword associated with the
function name within which we have the
await keyword with a particular promise
now to help you understand the entire
concept better let's look at a demo
now i've created a file called async
await in my visual studio code
so what we're going to be doing is that
we're going to have two functions that
help you check for the result now you
pass this code as a parameter to these
functions which in turn return promises
telling if you have passed and will also
give you the grade that you scored all
right so let's go ahead and say let
let me call the variable result
and let's have a function
which takes the score as a parameter all
right
within which it returns a promise so i
save return
new promise now as you know a promise
basically
has a function
which takes two parameters that is
resolve
and reject
now i just display a message saying
calculating
[Music]
results
all right now if
my score is say above 50
i resolve it
by displaying a message saying
congratulations
[Music]
you have passed
all right
and
if it is less than 50
i reject it with the message
saying you have faith
all right so this is a very simple
promise that i created
so moving on let's create another
function that returns a promise
so basically this function will tell you
the grade that you've scored so say let
grade equals
function
now this takes response as a parameter
so let me just say response
now again let me just copy this
all right
within which
i'm going to console.log a message
saying
calculating your grade
[Music]
and we're just going to resolve the
promise with the message
your grade is
a all right
and then we append the response
[Music]
now the first promise either results
saying that you've passed or it rejects
saying you failed and in case it gets
resolved then the next promise is
automatically resolved with the grade a
all right so moving on
let's call the functions so here let me
first call the function result so i say
result
and let me pass the value 80 since it
gets resolved and now i make use of the
dot then method
now here i catch the response
all right and then i just display a
message
indicating
results received
okay
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pass the response to my next function
that is the grade function so what i say
is i say return
grade and the parameter is response let
me just pass that
now what exactly happens is that the
grade function also returns a promise so
on top of that i can use the dot then
method
so i use the then method
and let me just say final grade
[Music]
now within which i just display the
message
final
grade
all right now lastly we make use of the
catch method
in case of errors this catches the
errors
so let me just say error
and then
we'll console.log it
[Music]
all right
so this is the code
let me save this
and let's execute it to see its normal
execution so this is without using async
and await all right
so let's go ahead and execute this
so here let me check the console
and there we go it says calculating
results results received calculating
your grade your grade is a and
congratulations you have passed
so this was basically without using
async innovate so now let me show you
how you can use async and await and how
easier the code becomes all right so
what we can do is let me just comment
this out
all right now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to call my function right so
i'm just going to make use of the async
keyword while calling it so i say async
function and let me call the function
calculate
results
okay
so now inside this method i'm going to
call the functions result and grade so
when i first call result the value that
is returned by result is going to be
stored in the variable response so for
that let me just say const
response
now i make use of the await keyword here
i say a weight
result
of 20 or
in our case let me just say 80
all right
so what the await keyword does is that
the function result ceases to execute
until the promise is resolved and
whatever the promise returns gets stored
in the variable response
all right so now after this let me just
display a message
that says
results
received
all right
now next i'm going to call the other
function that is great so again i'm
going to say constant and i'm going to
have to create another variable let me
call it final grade and it's the same
procedure i use the await keyword
and call the function grade
and i pass response as the argument
all right
and after this i'm going to say
console.log
for final grade
so it's as simple as that so first we
call the result function which returns a
promise which gets stored in the
variable response
all right then we're going to call the
grade function and pass the response as
an argument
and the result of which is being stored
in final grade all right and lastly we
display final grade so now you must be
wondering if this executes what about
errors what if the value that i pass is
less than 50 right for that i'm going to
have to catch an error
so what i can do is that i can place
this entire code within the try block
all right so let me just say try
and now what i can do is i can catch
now if there is an error it gets caught
and then i display it
let me say console.log
error
all right
and lastly let's call the function
calculate results
okay so let me save this and execute it
so all right here we go
it displays the same messages in the
same sequence that we saw before
so now to give you an example of
rejection so here let me just pass 20
all right
let's save it
and there we go it says calculating
results you have failed so you can make
use of async and await instead of
complicating the entire piece of code by
using promises react.js is a widely used
front-end development library so if
you're just starting or wish to brush up
your basics then you're in the right
place this video will cover all the
basic concepts of react.js
first we look at what react.js is
then we'll see how to install and set up
the react environment
then we'll move on to learn the
fundamental concepts of components
props and states lastly we'll conclude
the session by creating a simple
calculator app i'm sure you're excited
to learn so let's dive right in let's go
ahead and begin with what is react react
is a javascript library used to build
fast and interactive user interfaces for
both web and mobile applications now one
thing that makes react extremely
powerful is the fact that it's open
source any user can access its source
code modify it and enhance it in a
typical model view controller
architecture react defines the view part
of the application it is also
responsible for how the app looks and
feels fun fact react was built by jordan
walkey an engineer at facebook now let's
go ahead and see how react works in real
time consider a typical web application
say instagram the entire ui of the web
page is divided into several components
we have the search component a profile
description component stories component
and a post-list component these
components make the code easier to debug
and always remain discrete components
also make development and maintenance of
web applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on now let's see how
it works when we trigger an action the
dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know before you
can actually start working on react you
should be familiar with programming
concepts like functions objects arrays
and classes one should also have a basic
knowledge of javascript and a
familiarity with html don't worry if you
feel like you're not good at them once
you start working on them you'll get a
good hang of it finally let's go through
the impact of react on the it industry
and get insights into the salaries of
react developers statistics show that
react developers earn way more than
other web developers according to pay
scale the average salary for a react
developer in the united states is a
whopping 91 000 us dollars the average
salary for a react developer in india is
7.25 lakhs per annum over the recent
years react has gained immense
popularity and is being adopted by many
companies according to the data by
google trends react has had a better
growth scale compared to other
frameworks like angular and vue
statistics show that front-end
developers have wholeheartedly adopted
this lightweight framework forgoing
other available options if you are
skilled and have a knack for front-end
development react can help you gain
fantastic career opportunities lastly
talking about a few companies that use
react devotionally we have facebook
instagram netflix dropbox whatsapp among
others
in this video we'll be learning all
about react installation on windows to
set up the react development environment
we need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing node.js we can head
to the official node.js website save
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page
say download vs code click on the first
link and download the 64-bit version for
windows once you're done with the
installation of both node and your text
editor you can start creating your first
react application so for that let's
create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
[Music]
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd
my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file open folder go
to your desktop or the drive that you
saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in this video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components so we'll be touching on
topics like what are components types of
components nesting components higher
order in pure components and a brief
description about component lifecycle
all right to begin with what exactly are
components components are the building
blocks of a react application wherein
each component represents a part of the
user interface now to make it more
understandable consider the facebook
home page the entire ui can be broken
down into several elements say we have
the credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks all right reusability is one
of the salient features of react
components one component can be reused
several times across the application and
this improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or a dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components alright so
i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
simply let me save it and if you look at
the browser you'll have hello welcome to
simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div
and i enclose it so let me save and
check my browser again here you go so
multiple html tags have to be enclosed
within the div tag moving on let's
create a first functional component to
do that i'll first create a folder in my
source folder say components within that
i'll create a file say
functional component.js
all right so the first thing we have to
do is import react so i say import react
from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class the act.component so going
ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
feature is used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export
profile and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this component
slash functional component also let me
get rid of these
unnecessary files here now let's define
functional component in our app.js
component so here i say functional com
let's compile it and check our browser
here it says this is a functional
component moving on to my class
component it's the same syntax here as
well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i say so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
comp one and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right in my app.js
while importing it i want to import both
the classes so i'll include them within
curly braces here i say class com comma
class comp one and then again i define
it here class comp one let's compile it
and run it and here we go here you can
see hey i'm another class so we've
successfully exported both the classes
from the class component and imported it
back in our app.js component one
advantage of using named export is the
fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to now say for
example i do not want to import class
component here so let me take it off and
here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
here another class the second class got
imported while the first class i was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now i won't get into
the nitty-gritties of it because they're
advanced topics but to give you a brief
insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this benefit rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
0. so for that i'm going to use another
snippet called r const and here this dot
state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals
this dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals is going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot account plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change x to
come now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented 2 i say
this dot props dot name let me save it
let me do the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked zero times and the
user incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you learn about this
method a little later in the video now
this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say
pureform.js so here i'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag i'll
display the text say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regular component.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it
simply done itself moving on let's
import pure component and the regular
component into our parent component and
then pass name as a property so to do
that first import pure comp
from your component and then i say
import regular comp from regular com.js
and here let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name
and here i again say this dot prop dot
name and finally let's import parent
component into our app.js component so
here i say import parent com from okay
and here let me define parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply learn and i'm the pure
component simply on we've got the result
as expected now to check if the pure
component is actually re-rendering or
not let's include simple console.log
statements so here i say clg snippet and
here i say
pure
component
render and in my regular component i do
the same thing i say console.log regular
component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well here i would
say
parent
component render all right so let's go
back to our browser and inspect it in
our console first the parent component
gets rendered then the regular component
and then the pure component after that
for every three seconds only the parent
component and the regular component is
rendered for the same state and prop the
pure component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
comprehend life cycle explains the
stages the component goes through the
entire life cycle of a component can be
divided into three parts we have
mounting updation and unmounting so the
first thing that gets invoked in the
life cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once the component
is inserted into the dom component did
mount gets invoked coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component's
state should trigger a re-render or not
to do that should component update
method is called component will update
is invoked right before re-rendering
after re-rendering component did update
is called that makes updates to the dom
and the last phase is unmounted
component will unmount method does all
the necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and cycles moving ahead
let's learn about another striking
feature of react.js called props props
short for properties allow the user to
pass arguments or data to components a
pairing component can pass additional
information to its children using props
properties help make components more
dynamic props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of html track
attributes now we'll look at this a
little later in the video props in a
component are read only and cannot be
changed one thing to remember is that
props are sent by the parent to the
children components hence the children
components cannot make any changes to
these props now that we've learnt about
props in brief let's go ahead and create
our application using props if you're
new to this tutorial i suggest you go to
the react installation and react
components video on our channel
so back in my code editor that is vs
code i've opened a folder called react
props
and now i'm going to create a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
[Music]
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here i say import
class props
all right now we define the class
component in our render method
let's say
all right
now if we go back to the browser you see
hello learners welcome to simply
learning now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is app.js to the
child component and render this onto the
browser so let's do that so here
while i'm defining my child component i
say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
i say i use the keyword this
dot props
dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner one
welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner 2 and learner
3 so i again say class props
name
equals
[Music]
learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
place x so i can here
define another property say place
[Music]
and say place
similarly i can do it
for the rest to
say place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello
learner1 from
this dot props
dot
place
let me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello learner1 from
place x place y and place z we can also
display whatever we want between the
opening and closing tags when invoking a
component now this is facilitated using
props.children reserved keyword now let
me explain to you how it's done with an
example here let's split the self and
closing tag into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my child component
after my h1 tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props dot children
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialog that represent generic boxes
so let's go ahead and create a button
tag and check again
so here
i'll split it and add a button tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go
we get the output as expected all right
we saw the usage of props for class
components similarly we can use it for
functional components so let's go ahead
and create a functional component let me
call it
i say import
react from
react
and then i say function
function props
and here i return an h3 tag
i'll say this is
functional component
and i'll return another h3 tag saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it
export
default
function props
and import it
in our app.js again
import
function prop from
[Music]
function prop
and here in our render method
let's define it
let me call
function prop
name
let me give learner 4
and
place
place say a
let me close it
and back in our functional component
instead of learner
i say
props dot
name
let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says props is not defined
so let's go back to our code editor and
pass props here
to our functional component also
let me define hello props dot name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected let's begin and learn what
exactly is a state in react typically a
state is an object that stores the
values of properties belonging to a
component now these values can change
over a period of time either via user
interactions or network changes and the
state helps facilitate this
functionality every time the state
changes react re-renders the component
to the browser the state is initialized
in the constructor a state can also
store multiple properties a method
called set state is used to update the
value of the state object now this
function performs a shallow merge on the
new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learned about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while state on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once set by the parent they
cannot be changed state holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about state let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of state alright so in my
code editor that is vs code i've created
my application say state and here in my
source folder i have my app.js file now
here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that i'm not going to
be using also i suggest you go through
the react installation on windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react dot component inside i
have a render method that returns an
html tag let's display a message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the html tags within the div
tag so i say
div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import
app dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome now let's
beautify our code to do that let's add
some styling so here in my app.js class
component i say styles
equals
and i say font
style and i set it to say bold and
i say color say
and here in my h1 tag i say style equals
this
dot
styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first i create a
folder and i call it components and
inside this folder i create a class
component and i call it new comp dot
js and i use the snippet rce to create
the class component to give you an
insight into what we're doing today
we'll display a message asking the user
to subscribe to simply learn once the
user clicks on the subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state object in a constructor so let's
use the snippet r const to create a
constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this
dot state
dot message let's save it and now let's
import it in our app.js component so
i'll get rid of export here and here i
say
import new com from components and new
comp and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to simply
learn all right again to make our code
look more presentable let's add in
styles so i'll just copy the same styles
that i've added here and i'll paste them
here and instead of bold i make it
italic
and i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag i define
style and initialize it to distort
styles so let me save it and now if you
look at the browser it's in italic and
it's in purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should read
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that i want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here i
create a prop i say sub and i say
subscribe here and back in my render
method i say this dot state dot sub so
let's save it and if you look at the
browser now you have a button which
displays a message subscribe now once
the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call another method
and let's call the method
button
change okay so this method should update
the state and change the message and sub
values to do that we make use of a set
state method now a state can be updated
in response to event handlers server
responses or prop changes now all the
updation can be done using the set state
method now this is the general syntax
used by the method we'll have a look at
this further in the demo now the set
state method conventionally encuse all
the updates made to the component state
and instructs react to re-render the
component and its children with the
updated state now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here i define the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions i suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here i say this dot
set state and inside i change my message
to
hit the bell icon to never
miss an update and my sub value changes
to subscribed
let's save this and now if you look at
the browser when we click on the
subscribe button the message changes to
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen so for that i have two
images i have bell a and bell b so i
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from
bell a dot bng
and again i say import bell b from
bell b
dot png all right let me save it to
display the image on the screen we make
use of the image tag now this tag has
two attributes one is the source
attribute that specifies the url and the
other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image so here in my component i say i
make use of a paragraph tag that will
help
display the image in the next line and
then i use the image tag now since my
image changes once it's clicked i have
to define a property and pass the event
handler click that will update the image
so here
before specifying the source let's go
back to our state and define another
property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first let me save it and
here in my image tag i say source
equals
this
dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag and i do not want to display any
message so i leave it as it is now let's
save it and if you look at the browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell so back
in my vs code i define style
with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image they emit
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click i define a method say this
dot
image change and now we define
this method here i see image change i
make use of an arrow function again and
again i use the set state method i
update the image so i say image url is
now set to bell
b and the message
is updated to thank you
happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
subscribe button and now it says hit the
bell icon and once i do that the image
updates and the message changes in this
session we're gonna cover the topic of
what is angular i'm sure all of you use
mobile and web applications be it from
social media to health care e-commerce
and net banking these apps are used by
billions of people across the globe now
the main reason we use these apps is
that they offer seamless user experience
and interface but how are they developed
to provide such reliability one of the
frameworks that is widely used to build
such robust apps is angular so let's
dive into the session now so here is a
list of topics that we're going to be
covering
first up we'll see why angular was
introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture
advantages and limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we'll look at some of the
companies that deploy angular so without
further delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into html
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications
and also provide scalability and
maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework written completely in
typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for developers it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing
we have the document object model type
script data binding and testing now
let's look at them one by one now the
document object model treats an xml or
an html document as a tree structure
now here every node in the tree
structure defines an object representing
a part of your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single html page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding dom or the tree structure
needs to be updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
javascript which helps you write
javascript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason is highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package now to do that you
just have to run the command npm install
hyphen g type script on your command
prompt next up is data binding now data
binding is a process that allows you to
manipulate web page elements using the
web browser now it mainly employs
dynamic html and does not require
complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes needing the ui element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state
are reflected onto the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
term to the model data via the
controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests the jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner for the tests
that use a configuration file to set the
startup reporters and testing framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates to real dom mvc short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic
view on the other hand is used for ui
logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed
angular allows you to effortlessly move
your data from your javascript code to
the view and react to user events
without having to write any code
yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same don't worry
if you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for server communication
routing and more
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross-platform
and browser compatible an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers
beat chrome firefox safari and platforms
like windows mac os and linux now many
versions of angular have been released
ever since its inception all of these
versions have added to the efficient
working of the framework now here are
two different versions released first up
was angular 1. it was built on
javascript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire ui was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation angular cli or command line
interface 1.0 was introduced however not
deployed in this release the angular cli
was optimized and commands like ng
update and ng add were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in cli
about the functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the iv renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learnt about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a steep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
learners to begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options
now angular offers limited seo options
and poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers
its verbose and complex
now a common issue faced by the angular
community is the verbosity of the
framework
it also poses to be complex compared to
other front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to port legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
backward compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular some of them are directives
modules declarators components services
dependency injection
pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool it becomes way more easier to
comprehend and understand what is going
on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like nike
forbes google hbo sony upwork among
others readily deploy angular so moving
on let's look at the prerequisites for
angular
first up we have nodejs angular uses
node.js as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have nodejs
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system
next up is the angular cli now this
command line interface is a tool that
makes it easier to bootstrap and develop
your angular applications now to install
the latest version run the command npm
install hyphen g
at angular
front slash cli you got to run this
command on your command prompt
and finally to confirm installation
check for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an ide or a text editor to type your
code now there are several ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites i think you're ready to
create your first angular application
so let's head to our vs code and begin
here i've created a folder called
angular on my desktop and opened it on
my visual studio code so to create your
app you need to open the terminal just
go here and
select new terminal
and now type in the command
ng
new
and provide the name for your app
so i'm just gonna say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
hello world in our case
and it includes a bunch of files and
installs all the necessary dependencies
for the angular application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say cd
hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but i'll rush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component
now the root component here is the
index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is a part of the bootstrapping
piece all right so the index.html file
is responsible for deciding which files
are to be loaded correct the main.ts
file on the other hand identifies which
angular module is to be loaded when the
application starts so this is just a
brief explanation as to what they are
doing
next we have the app folder now here we
have the
app.module.ts file now this application
module file can be thought of as the
code configuration of your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts so these are all
typescript files hence the extension ts
now this file basically is a root
component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser so let
me just change the message that is being
displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this
and when we go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are
then i'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo and
lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos also hit the bell icon
to never miss an update so what exactly
are angular components
now i'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application so in this
case here we have the logo component
then you have a sign in component
an image component and then a create
account component now all of these
components generally don't affect the
working of each other
but however when embedded they define
the ui of your application
so i hope you understood what components
are
so to go ahead let's discuss some of its
common features now firstly they are the
building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
detectives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom html elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator now the decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the ng module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when i show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a visual studio code
now here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo within which
i've created an angular application
called demo components
once executed the browser looks
something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on getting started with angular
that is angular hello world i highly
suggest you go through that video first
it helps you create your first angular
application so um
now let's go ahead and create our first
component now the command used to create
our component is ng gc and your
component name
once executed it creates four different
files now let's just see how this works
on rvs code
now what you can do is head to your
terminal and type in the command ng
g
c
and provide a name for your component
for example i'm going to just call my
component text component
all
right so what it does is that it creates
four different files you can see you
have four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created so
here in your source folder
within which there's an app folder and
again here you can see that your four
different files have been created first
is the html file where you can define
all the code that you want for your
component next you have the css file for
your styling
then you have the dot ts file which
includes the component decorator and
finally you have spec.ts which is
basically a unit test file
all right and then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the component that
you've created that is text component
has been imported that is what the
message conveys here all right now let's
go back to our app.component.html
now this basically has all the code for
your application so let me just get rid
of it
[Music]
and i'm just gonna
display a basic
heading
saying hello
welcome
all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our component
dot html file
and here
let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components
all right
now in your text component dot ts file
which is your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component now go ahead and
copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom html tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is the text component is being
incorporated in the final render
so what happens is that whatever is
defined in the component.html file is
also being rendered in your final output
so when i save this
let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed
so this was a simple creation of a
component now for this let's give it
some styling
so here go to your dot css file and
provide some styling say for example
here i just say
text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.cs i'm going to give the
same thing
and say each one
text align
is center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component
now the components are executed
sequentially so now let's create another
component just to give you a brief
insight into it let's say nggc
image component
now here i'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so i'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here i've added the
logo so what i can do is back in my html
file i can go ahead and create an image
tag so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then
let me say
image
source
equals
so the source is basically assets
slash
logo
dot png
and class
equals
center
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide any sort of styling
that you need
so let me just say
text
align
to be center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this
and from the dot cs file
let's copy the selector
and create a custom html tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go
let's save this and check the output
and there we go
first the hello welcome message is
displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component
so this is how you can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own html tag
however the same has to be included in
the parent component so to help you
understand that better let's head back
to our vs code and say for example in
our text component
here
the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it to say n component
[Music]
all right
now when you save it and look at the
browser
the message is not displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector and then include this
here
and now you can see
that the same component has been
rendered onto your output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the ui
next up we have template url now it is
the url for the external file containing
the template for the view
so here you can see this is basically
the external file that contains the
template for the view
next up you have styles now these are
also inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view
so any code that you provide in the dot
css file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets that
are applied on your components view
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire ui of the
application is divided into several
components
now what if all of these components
perform similar tasks be it accessing
the database rendering images etc now
instead of writing the same piece of
code for every component you could write
the code once and then perhaps inject
the same code into every component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes a and b
now let's assume that a uses the objects
of class b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class b is
created so that a can accesses objects
but using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the code more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own
and lastly gi benefits directives pipes
and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider class
postal details that is dependent on the
number and the address class
in the postal details class the
constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class
the constructor instantiates a unique
number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code
let's assume that the number and address
class constructors now accept parameters
when we change the numbers class the
postal details class gets broken
now to overcome this what we need to do
is we need to pass parameter to the
number constructor so this applies to
address as well
the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change the
postal details class needs to be changed
as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules
components all of these are benefactors
of dependency injection so in the demo
i'm going to be showing how dependency
injection can be used with the help of
services and injecting these services
into classes so the main
thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience
these components do not generally
execute tasks so to execute these tasks
we make use of services so a component
can delegate tasks like fetching data
from the server any network related
issues etc to a particular service and
these services can be made available to
components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list
later we're going to inject the service
into the class using dependency
injection
so let's head to our visual studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then i have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
nggc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is amp
info
all right so as you can see here in my
app folder i have the component
with four different files all right so
the next thing we have to do is we have
to create a service so to create that we
make use of the command
ng g
s
you can either give s or service and the
service name i'm providing is records
so let me just say
records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spec.ts file and the
dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed right so let's go ahead and
write the data so first we're going to
make use of three arrays i'm going to be
displaying employee records for three
employees so i'll have to create three
arrays and provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the area i'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and i'm going to be passing
information like name employee id and
the email id
so the arrays of type string
and within which let me just mention the
details i'm giving random information
i'm just saying adam taylor
and some random
employee id
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so i'm going to be creating
three records so i'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and
let me change the name of the idea as
well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot in four one
all right i'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
i'm just gonna return different arrays
here
all right and lastly info three all
right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data let's
go back to our component dot ts file
here
and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct
now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help of dependency injection so
what we need to do is we'll have to
first import the service
into the component.ts file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component an
instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
[Music]
records
services
i'm sorry service
from
and let's say records.service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the providers
area of the component
all right
so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class
right however to access this instance an
object is also created so this object
will in turn access the methods and
variables of the service class so for
that we have to create another object so
let's do that here in our constructor
method
let's say constructor
private
and the object i'm creating is called
our service you can give a name
of your choice
and then i'm going to just say records
service
all right now this
object will help me retrieve data from
the service so let's go ahead and use
this in order to get the employee
details
alright i've created three different
methods here get info from service class
2 1 and 3 and these methods will
retrieve the data and add it to our
array here that is info received all
right
and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here we haven't added
anything so let me get rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info
and then i've
interpolated
info which displays the contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file we have to bind them with the
button so since it is bound with the
click event every time you click on the
button the information is
displayed so now the last thing we have
to do is we'll have to create a custom
html tag for the component and then add
it to the main component
so let's just do that
let me copy
this here
and then in my
appcomponent.html let me get rid of this
and then let me just create this
i've just created the custom html tag
for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say
employee
details
and then i'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
i've i've added the image here so let me
just say logo
dot png
i've also added some styling to it
all right so now let me just save this
and have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when i click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the id and
their email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
we'll understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information or also
to perform any sort of data related
tasks so now let's look at the different
types of form building supported by
angular
up angular supports two types of form
building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one
so talking about template driven
approach in this method the conventional
form tag is used to create forms
so angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the ng model tag
now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module so it
basically uses several module classes to
provide controls now if you don't get
this don't worry you'll understand
better when i'm showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic html validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the anti
pattern of updating the data model by a
two-way data binding so it does not use
two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
now these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they are
either touched untouched dirty pristine
valid invalid and so on so this allows
you to check every field for the value
it makes it easier to understand which
fields value is invalid or which field
has not been entered etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features i'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo
so for that let's head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
i've created a component called form
component
and
i've also included the simply learn logo
just to beautify the appearance so once
you execute the code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser
so you just have the logo at the moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh uh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is so we're going
to be creating a user registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name email
id and a password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file
you will have to import forms module
from angular forms
all right and then uh in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and
start our form creation
so here in my component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag
so here
let me see div
class
is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field so
say div
class
equals form group
i'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this we have to do for all the other
fields
so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag pre
for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
[Music]
so let's just add that here
with a type
submit
and let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have passwords so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our
user registration form ready but i would
like to
align it to the center so let me just do
that
so here in my css file
i'm just going to uh
align all the div tags the center and
the label tag to the left so let me save
this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have a registration
form with a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
ng model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will
provide form controls to every input
field
all right so here let's just go ahead
and say ng
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this
and back in my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched ng pristine
ng ballet are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form tab
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields so this
is achieved when you add the ng model
directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code now every form has an
output property attached to it called ng
submit all right so this property can be
bound within a method that method called
the subbit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just save
form
ng submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file
and let me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
or submit
and then here let me just
console.log
form submitted
alright so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step is to
generate javascript representation now
we'll have to make use of another
directive called ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay so
this javascript representation helps
with validating all the fields so i'll
help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right
and say ng
form
okay
now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation
so now while you're calling the submit
method you're going to pass login as a
parameter
so let's just say log in here
and in my ts file
again let's just say login
and along with it
i want login to be displayed so
i say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so
within form
i can
check
for
email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see
invalid is it invalid or is it
untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now
let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty
and the form only accepts names with a
minimum length of 2 and a maximum length
of 7.
all right so here in my input tag
i just mentioned a required meaning this
field cannot be empty
and min length
to 2
and
max length
to say 7.
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when i submit it
and i look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name
you can see that
an error is shown here it says
required equals true
that means that there is one error
now you can make use of these form
control objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation and display a
message whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid
or touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable
let me call it
name
and
let's say
ng
model
all right here the variable name
receives the control object
so here back in my browser when i submit
again without
the first name
you can see that the
invalid property is set to true
correct so this helps us use this
property to alert the user with the help
of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code
let me create
another
div tag
within which i mentioned ngf
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic
so let's say mgf
name which is
our template variable
name
dot touched
and name dot invalid
is true
right then i'm going to alert
so i'm gonna
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert
danger
all right
so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're going to have the background
color red
for
danger all right and here i'm going to
display the message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement
say suppose the length of the first name
is too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or
suppose they have missed out on filling
a form field then you can again alert
the user so you can basically make use
of the nested if condition right now
just to help you understand that better
let me just show it to you
now back in my html
file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ngif again
now ngf
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then i display the message
first
name
required
all right
and
if
the length of the first name is
[Music]
not two
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then i'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts so i hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now i highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun
so i hope this tutorial helped you out
i'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided into several components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component an image
component and say a create account
component
now these components are standalone and
each of them represents a part of the
user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
accessing the database
or rendering images on the view
tasks like those
now instead of having to write the code
for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
then injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it
now the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it
components make sure that whatever is
being rendered onto the screen is right
and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end now for example if you want
to make ajax calls you can have methods
to those calls in the service and then
use it as a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created
and the same instance is used by each
and every building block in the
application and finally a service can be
registered as a part of a module or it
can be registered as a part of the
component now to register it as a part
of the component you'll have to specify
it in the provider's array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo
so in the next section we're going to
look at a demo but before that let me
tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee id and
their email id will create a database of
say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular services
hands-on
so here first i've created a folder
called demo underscore angular within
which i've created a file called hello
world
so this was previously used for a
tutorial so the name is just hello world
so don't get confused
however when you look at the browser
i've written
an initial code here which is angular
services and i have the simply learn
logo
so back in my browser this is what the
ui looks like
so uh to
so to understand the concept of angular
services
first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here i'm going to say ng
g c
e info
i'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see inside my app
file we have the e info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then i highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g
service
here g stands for generate
and we're generating a service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be
a dot ts file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service
all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file i'm going to
create an array
that displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating uh three
different employee records so for that
i'll have three different arrays
so let me just call the areas info
received
one indicating this is the information
of
first employee
and this is going to be of type
string and i'll just initialize it to
null
for now
all right and i'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
i'll have to create a method again i'm
creating three methods for uh the three
different employee records
so i'm gonna call the array get
info
[Music]
from service
one
indicating it's again for employee one
and
i'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records
so let me just
copy paste and here
i'm just going to change
the name of the methods
all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we'll have to create the
employee record in our service
so back here in my data.ts
file
what i'm going to do is
i'll create
three different
records for the employees so let me say
info 1
which is going to be of type string
all right and
let me just give a random names say for
example i say john
matthew
[Music]
all right
and
employee id say
e
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm at abc.net
all right so i'm going to do the same
for the other two uh records
so let me just create another one and
call it info two
and the name i'm providing is say rob
wilson
with a different employee
id say 673
and i'm just going to make it
rw at abc.net
and another record
for employee number three
and i'm just gonna say rose adams
[Music]
with
some employee id
and
an email id all right
so now
we've created the employee records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct so for that i'm just going to
create another method called get info
one
which is of type string
and it just returns
this
dot info 1
all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just going to retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in 4 2
and get info
2.
and again
i'm just going to make it get in for
three
and this is gonna
return
in four three
all right so i'm sure you've got an idea
as to what i'm doing here
so basically this information is going
to be retrieved in our employee
component correct so for that i'll have
to make use of dependency injection
so here i'll have to import the service
that i've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data.service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular
that when the component is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks and for that we'll also
have to include this in our providers
area so here
let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so this property basically allows us to
access all the methods that are defined
in the service class
all right so here in my constructor
method i'm just going to say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just giving the
name d service
all right
and which is of type
data service
all right
so now with the help of this property i
can retrieve information from the
service
class so here i'm just going to save
this
dot
info received
equals this dot
d service
dot
get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service
which returns the information of the
first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next
two methods i'm just going to use the
same piece of code
let me just change it here
and
same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the ui for it
here in my html file
i'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now i'm going to make use of the ng
for director
to basically loop over the record and
display everything
so for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just say
let info
[Music]
of
info received
so
you can check here in our ts file the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first in
employee record i'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create
a class a bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here is where let me
create a bootstrap
class called list
group
all right i hope this was clear to you
so basically here
the information is being retrieved with
the help of this method right that is
get info from service one so in order to
call this method we'll have to bind it
with a button all right so that's what
we're going to do
let's just
copy this and here i'm going to create a
button
all right
and the type
is button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it
this particular method gets called
all right i'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just provide the name
employee 1
for the button
all right
so similarly we'll have to do the same
for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so uh what i'm gonna do is i'm just
gonna paste the same
twice
and here i'm gonna just change the names
i'll say 2 here
and this is again for employee 2
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee i'm sorry it's
going to be in 4 received 2
this is going to be in 4 received 3
and finally employee 3
all right
and lastly we'll have to include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component
or html so here
let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that three different
buttons have been created for employee
one two and three and when you click on
it
it retrieves information that is
the name the employee id and their email
ids
so we've successfully created an angular
service and injected it into our
component to retrieve information all
right so now the last part of the use
case that we discussed
was uh to add another
detail that is the employee detail in
the record
all right so for that we'll have to take
input from the user and in our case
we're taking the location
now uh we're also adding the same
location for all three employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit
and you can change the entire
view of your application you can add
information you can delete you can
retrieve you can alter etc
all right so for that what we're going
to do is back in the html file
we'll create a form
that basically takes the input
so i'm just going to say
[Music]
form
all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
[Music]
within which i'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside of which i'll have
the input tag
of
type
text
and
the name i'm going to be providing it
will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and i'll just
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model so if you're confused as to what
i'm doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms
video it basically teaches you uh how to
work around with angular forms
all right and now
after this we're gonna have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
and i'm gonna just say add
info okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form i'll also have to create a
template variable to access all the
values within my form
so if i have to access the location then
i need a variable to access it so here
let me just go ahead and create a
template variable let me call it
frm and i'm going to make use of the ng
form directive
so this tells angular
that
this variable can be used
to
access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here i'll have
to import it in my
module
file
so here
i just go ahead and say
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
i'll just say forms
module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now uh back in my html file
what i'm going to do is that i'll have
to make use of this template variable
to update my information correct
so i'll have to create another method
that will update information into the
records
so here in my component.ts file i'll
have to create another
method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method
all right
and uh this basically takes in the
template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do
is that it updates
the record correct so i'm going to say
this
dot
d service
add info now you must be wondering what
ad info is
i'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've uh
provided as an input which is nothing
but form
dot value dot location
all right so now
what happens is that i'll have to again
specify what ad info is and this method
is going to be defined in the service
file correct
so here
i'm going to create another
method that's add
info
and i'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since i'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info one in photo and
info three i'm just going to say this
dot info one dot push
off info
[Music]
all right and the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly i'm doing is that i have
i have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also i
have to return it so i'll say return
this dot info
[Music]
all right
and i'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls
uh the add info method in our service
and passes the value to it and in my
html file
also note that the button type here is
submit
and not button
so
what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
passed on to the method that is update
enforce so here
i'll say ng submit
and
i'm going to call the method update
info
and i'm going to pass
frm
as
the argument
and now let's save this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now i can just go ahead and see type
usa
and when i say add info
and when i check on my
employee 1 details usa has been added to
the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better i highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
pages it is a free and open source
project based on github and originally
created by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of handy reusable bits
of code written in html
css and javascript
it's also a front-end development
framework that enables developers and
beginners to design quick and responsive
websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page
these components could be navigation
bars drop downs progress bars thumbnails
etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive
user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it first up
is by using the bootstrap cdn or the
content delivery network
now this enables users to load css
javascript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jquery and other packages and
frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that i am going to be
showing you i have embedded bootstrap
using npm alright so i'm sure you'll
only understand the concept better when
you look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what i'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post
so uh let me show you what we're going
to be doing
so here i've created a simple
blog
for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo i've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer
i've also mentioned their tag line
and when you scroll down you can see
that i've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for full stack web development
as well
and
the same for the last one that is cyber
security
and finally i've added a simple video
here to just make it more
beautiful so i've added a simple video
and lastly
i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the youtube channel
to our youtube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating
uh using angular bootstrap so i'm
hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in
so first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and i'm just going to click on the first
link that i get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like
so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just
say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags
and then you have the title
and then you also have the css file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the
ui there's code for navigation bar and
then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that
and lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that
when you scroll down you can see that
it has certain dependencies so here it
has the bootstrap dependency and then
you have jquery so we have to
download them
so we'll have to install them
and as mentioned earlier we're going to
be installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code i've created a
folder called angulardemo
and then i've also created a file called
demo components
and here
i'm just going to say cd
demo components
within which i'll say npm
install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jquery go
ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery and bootstrap
so now we need to add the references to
these javascript files to do that
go to your
angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we define the relative
path to these javascript files
so these files are generally uh stored
in your
node modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and
then in your dist file
and then click on js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to uh
make it a path by providing by providing
forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jquery so here there's
jquery and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here
in the beginning they've also included
the css file
so we'll have to embed that as well so
here back
in
bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css i'm just going to copy
the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these
to forward slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so i think we've added all the
dependencies
and the custom style sheet and
everything so now let me just
close all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and
take the code from the
source here so i'm just going to copy
the body tag
all right
so
i'm going to copy this till the footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the ui in these
components
so
let me just see if i've got everything
here
okay
so i'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be uh to
display the courses that we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components i've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so i just have to
type in the command
ng g c
first we'll create
the
component for the top navigation bar so
i'm just saying n g g c so i'm just
going to say components
[Music]
slash navbar
all right so
the component has been created so what
i'm going to do is i'll just
copy this
[Music]
and paste it here
all right and the next component i'm
going to be creating is for the
introduction right so i'll say ng
g
c
components slash intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so i'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
[Music]
so let me do that and then i'm going to
have the main course content
component so for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until
till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here
and finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so
i'll say ng gc
components slash
footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
html tags for these components and then
place it in our html file
right so first one that we created was
the navigation bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copied the selector
[Music]
and then your
and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
i'm just going to copy the
selector
[Music]
and then for courses
so
yeah app hyphen courses
that is well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact
so here let me just say ng
serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed so you have the navigation bar
you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the photo component
right okay so now that we have the
template ready we can go ahead and
customize it according to our needs
so now i'm going to be making a few
changes to the code we're going to add
the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here i'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component
let's go to the html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
alright
so when you save it and when you look at
the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that i want to do is
i want to add the image right i simply
learn logo
so what i've done here is i've already
added
the logo
dot png file in my assets folder
so i'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this
so that's going to be in our intro files
so here
image source
is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
[Music]
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change
this part of the ui so the information
that i want to display is this
i'm gonna be displaying
world's number one online bootcamp and
other information so what i'm gonna do
is back in my vs code i'm just gonna
delete
this
and instead of that i'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online boot camp
and then within the paragraph tag i'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message i'm going to display a
explore programs message
so let's go back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then
lastly
instead of this message here
i want to display the message get
certified get ahead with our programs
so back in our vs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you
have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what i'm going to do is i'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so i'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here i'm just going to mention style
and then say font size
and i'm going to make it xx large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in our vs code
we'll have to go to the courses
component
so here i'm going to just uh type in the
code for the different courses so i
already have it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display let me just copy that
and for our first tag i'm just gonna say
postgraduate program and in six sigma
and the next information i'm gonna be
providing is the duration
so here
let me just get rid of this
[Music]
paste that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the
code
and then
and here for our reference link i
already have the link here
so i'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the
more info button it will automatically
navigate to this page
all right
so let me save this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in full
stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also
provide a blind break
and then
link i have it here so
i'm just going to paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card
i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra code and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
[Music]
all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that
the information has been added
you can see it displays postgraduate
program in lean six sigma full stack
development and cyber security so once i
click on more info it leads you to that
page
that shows the overview all right so now
the next thing on the agenda was to uh
display a short video and then the link
to our youtube channel
so let's go ahead and add that in our
courses
component so what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to get the code to add a
video from google and then i'm going to
provide the source
which is going to be the video that i
want to
display so i've received the code i'm
just gonna paste it here
so you can get the code uh on google so
go ahead and just paste that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder which i have provided here
so when i save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for youtube and then
the link to navigate to the youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again i've pasted the code for
the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube.png in my assets folder and i've
provided the source
and accordingly i've also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned the
text to the
center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out our youtube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then i provided the link to our
channel on youtube so let me just save
this and head back to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube logo
and we have the message displayed so
once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in
footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply on solutions and
all rights reserved
and i save it and look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you uh
make use of bootstrap and embed it into
your angular
for more responsive and better user
interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now i'm sure that you observed that the
url changes every time you click on a
particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create single
page applications
now these applications are loaded just
once and new content is added
dynamically
applications like google facebook
twitter and gmail are a few examples of
single page applications the best part
of using single page applications is
that it provides an excellent user
experience and you don't even have to
wait for new pages to load which by
extension makes single page applications
extremely fast but how is this new
content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now i'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it hands-on
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our visual studio code
so basically the objective of our
application
is to navigate to home
and the login pages so when i click on
the login icon here
it loads the login
page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the url changes
with the slash home appended
all right so this is the main objective
of our application so to create it let's
head back to our vs code all right so
here i've created a folder called demo
and underscore angular and i've created
a file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added
now although this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the url while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your
app.module.ts file and check if the app
routing module has been imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your imports array
with that or the initial setup is done
now to create the nav bar the code that
i'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap i highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so the code is already available i'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it
and paste the code in it so let's do
that
let me say
nggc
navbar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my html file
i'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go i've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file
i'll just remove all the
unwanted
code here
and just specify the
custom html tag for my navbar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when i open the browser
the navigation bar has been created
along with
these different options that's home
about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content
now again i have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files you can easily find the code
online just search for
bootstrap login templates and depending
on your requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
ngc
i'm just going to call it login for my
login component
all right and then i'm gonna say nggc
home for the home component
all
right so i'm just going to copy the
code for the login component
so back in my login.html
file
i'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that i've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the photo message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'll just
paste it here
so this basically has all the content
one thing i want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this i've just
added all the code in the same component
now i agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom html
tags in your home component
i'm just hoping you're following me
right now
and also here in my assets folder i've
added
a video and the youtube logo that needs
to be displayed when the home icon is
clicked
all right so now that we've created the
home and the login components
the next step is to configure the routes
for the application
all right so here you can see that we
have a file called app
routingmodule.ts file
so here
we have the routes and the router module
that is imported
and we also have a constant called
routes which is strongly typed to routes
from the router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path
so here in my routes array
i'm just going to go ahead and create
the paths that is we have two different
routes right one is for login and one is
for home
so i'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
i'm sorry within curly braces i say path
[Music]
and then the path that i'm going to give
is
login
this is basically what will appear
on the url
all right
and the component that needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
as you can see the login component has
been automatically imported
now same with
the home
path so let me just say
path
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the nav bar that is the home and the
login button right so we're going to
make use of the nav tag and an anchor
tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives
from the router package called router
link and router link active
now these are specified within the
anchor tag
the router link basically holds the path
to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more css classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just
add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're going to have another
director called
router link active
[Music]
and we're just gonna save
active here
[Music]
all right
same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your ui
now despite of all this
how are we specifying where these
components are to be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router outlet directive now again this
directive is available in the router
package
so we have to add that in our app
component.html file
so here just go ahead
and type
router
outlet
all right so with that we've created a
simple navigation bar which has
different options that is home about
services and link and once the user
clicks on the home icon it displays the
content that is in the home component
dot html file
and once the user clicks on the login
component it displays the content in the
login.html file
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's go to the browser and see
if it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once i click on the home i can hear
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our url you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so we've successfully
created a route here
and for login component when i click on
this icon
you can see that the path changes here
and the login component gets displayed
alright so this is how routing is
achieved in angular and so with that we
come to this complete full course
tutorial on front-end development i hope
you found this helpful if you have any
doubts or queries regarding any of the
topics covered please let us know in the
comment section below
thank you so much for being here keep
learning and stay tuned to simply learn